>> WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED
BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
MINNEAPOLIS, MINNESOTA.
CHECK THAT OUT.
LOOK AT THAT BREWERY, BILL
RIPKEN.
BRAIN BELT -- GREENBELT BEER.
HAVE YOU EVER HAD THAT?
BILL: I DON'T KNOW.
I USUALLY STICK WITH BUDWEISER.
>> LOOK AT THAT SHOT.
BILL: I'VE BEEN TO THAT MALL,
AND IT IS JUMBO.
>> I'VE HEARD YOU NEED A BIKE OR
A CYCLE TO GET THROUGH IT.
A GORGEOUS SHOT.
LOOK AT THAT.
TARGET FIELD WITH THE TWINS AND
THE WHITE SOX, WHO WILL FACE OFF
TODAY.
YOU HAVE THE TOP OF THE
DIVISION, THE WHITE SOX, THE
TWINS.
YOU ARE WATCHING THE PREGAME
SHOW RIGHT HERE.
BILL RIPKEN -- I MEAN, YOU TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS WHITE SOX TEAM,
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE TODAY.
WE ARE GOING TO INTERVIEW LIAM
HENDRIKS LATER ON ABOUT SOME OF
THE SIZE OF THE GUYS ON THAT
TEAM FULL TIME EVERY GUY -- IT
IS LIKE THOSE OLD DOLLS WHERE
YOU FIT WHEN INSIDE THE NEXT.
BILL: THE NESTING DOLLS.
BILL CO. WHATEVER THEY CALL
THEM?
-- MATT: WHATEVER THEY CALL
THEM.
ILL: THAT IS WHAT THEY CALL
THEY HAVE SOME BIG DUDES.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION THEY ARE A BIG TEAM.
I LIKE THE STARTING STAFF.
YOU LIKE THE OFFENSE, THE
BULLPEN.
SO WHERE IS -- I DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE ONE, BUT I THINK
RIGHT NOW THEY ARE PROBABLY THE
FAVORITES TO MAYBE GO AHEAD AND
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN LEAGUE AS
THEY STAND RIGHT NOW.
AM I GOING TOO FAR OUT THERE?
MATT: I DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU.
THEY ARE CLEARLY GOING TO THE
POSTSEASON.
BILL: WHO DO YOU HAVE FAVORITE?
MATT: I WOULD SAY TAMPA BAY OR
HOUSTON.
BILL: I'M NOT NECESSARILY MAD AT
YOU, WHAT I HAVE TO DISAGREE
PEW.
I THINK THEY ARE COMPLETE.
MATT: YOU CAN.
OTHER THAN PLAYING THE
LAST-PLACE TEAMS IN EACH
DIVISION OF THE AL, THE CHICAGO
WHITE SOX ARE BASICALLY A 500
TEAM.
THEY ARE 23-FIVE AGAINST THE
O'S, RANGERS, AND TWINS.
FUNNY 3-5 AGAINST EVERYBODY ELSE
-- AGAINST EVERYBODY ELSE, THEY
ARE ONE OR TWO GAMES OVER.
I DO WORRY ABOUT THAT.
BILL: AS LONG AS YOU'RE OVER AND
YOU PLAY A FIVE-GAME SET AND YOU
WIN THREE AND THE OTHER TEAM
WINS TWO, YOU MOVE ON.
MATT: HOW ABOUT HIGHLIGHTS OF
LAST NIGHT'S GAME?
>> ABREU HITS ONE DEEP, LEFT
CENTER.
DON!
-- GONE! INTO THE BULLPEN.
THEY GO BACK TO BACK.
TO THE PLATE WITH A MAN ABOARD.
DOWN THE LINE, PUTS THE TWINS IN
FRONT.
HOME RUN NUMBER SIX.
>> FLIPPED IT RIGHT IN THE
SEATS.
WHAT I NICE SWING AND A NICE BY
TORTUGA.
MATT: MAN OH MAN.
OUR FRIEND HERE, THE FORMER GM,
WHEN HE SEES A PLAYER WHO HE
LOVES, HE SAYS THAT'S WHAT THEY
LOOK LIKE.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE,
BUT HE CAN HIT.
BILL: HE WOULD ALSO SAY HE'S A
BIT OF A GUY.
IT IS NOT NECESSARILY WHAT THEY
LOOK LIKE BUT CAN THEY PLAY.
MATT: HOW ABOUT JIMENEZ?
BILL: THAT'S WHAT THEY LOOK
LIKE.
MATT: TALK ABOUT EASY POWERFUL
TIME IN SAYING TO ME.
BILL: BIG JIM THOME SAYS HE HIT
STUFF HARD.
BIG JIM HAS 612 OF THOSE BIG
BALLS FLYING AROUND THE BASEBALL
YARD, GOING INTO THE SEATS.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
HOW TO PAD YOUR STATS.
I KNOW IT'S NOT THAT EASY, BUT
THIS GUY MAKES IT LOOK THAT
EASY, AND I THINK HE HAS
REALIZED IN HIS YOUNG CAREER, HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO TRY TO DO TOO
MUCH.
THAT BALL IS ABSOLUTELY HAMMERED
RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
THIS BALL IS DOWN AND IN.
AND HOW TO PAD YOUR STATS HERE.
HE HAD TWO HOMERS IN TWO GAMES,
NOBODY IS GOING TO GO HE HAD
4-10 IN TWO DAYS.
SO PAD YOUR STATS.
WHEN YOU ARE HOT, PUT UP NUMBERS
LIKE THIS GUY.
NOT ANYBODY CAN JUST GO OUT
THERE AND THROW FOUR HOMERS UP
IN A TWO-DAY PERIOD.
THAT BALL IS ABSOLUTELY SQUASHED
ON AN UP AND AWAY SLIDER.
ALL THE POWER PROVIDING.
85 MILES PER HOUR, YOU WATCH
THIS THING SPINNING UP TO HOME
PLATE SAYING HIT ME, HIT ME.
WHAT DID HE DO?
HE HIT HIM, BEAT HIM TO THE
SPOT, WHICH IS THE GLOVE.
IT WAS POINT A TO POINT B ON THE
SWING.
92 MILE PER HOUR, HITS IT IN THE
SEATS.
HOW TO PAD YOUR STATS -- IT'S
NOT THAT EASY.
I'M HAVING A LITTLE FUN WITH IT,
BUT THIS DUDE, GOING BACK TO
WHAT JIM SAYS, HE HIT STUFF
HARD.
MATT: WHAT YOU JUST DID, IT IS
RIGHT, CENTER, LEFT.
I MEAN, TO ME THAT IS ALBERT IN
A WAY.
THE EASY POWER, HE CAN GO TO ALL
FIELDS.
BILL: I THINK YOU WILL FIND IN
THIS LEAGUE THE BETTER HITTERS
ARE THE ONES YOU CANNOT
OVERSHIFT ON BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
HONOR THIS LINE TO THAT LINE,
AND EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE THE BEST
HITTERS BECAUSE THEY WILL HIT IT
WHERE IT IS PITCHED.
KIND OF WHAT HE DOES.
TEXTBOOK, UP AND AWAY SLIDER.
THE MIDDLE PART OF THE PLATE,
OUTER THIRD, JUMPED TO DEAD
CENTER FIELD.
HE IS NOT PULLING OFF OF THAT.
HE'S NOT POPPING IT UP OVER
THERE BECAUSE HE'S TRYING TO HIT
IT NINE MILES THAT WAY.
HE TOOK A NICE EASY PASS AT A
BALL THAT IS ALREADY ELEVATED.
HE HAD A LONG WAY TO DEAD CENTER
FIELD MINNESOTA.
MATT: HE'S BATTING CLEANUP
TODAY, AND JOSE ABREU IS BATTING
THIRD TODAY.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK PAUL
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
WHO WILL WIN TODAY'S GAME, WHITE
SOX OR TWINS?
REYNALDO LOPEZ IS NOW ON THE
MOUND TODAY, SO NO LANCE LYNN.
CARLOS RODON WAS PUT ON THE
I.L., SO THEY MOVE THINGS AROUND
A LITTLE BIT.
GOING TO START THE GAME IN IOWA
TOMORROW, BUT RODIN ON THE IL --
RODON WITH THE SHOULDER FATIGUE.
THAT'S NOT A GREAT SIGN.
MY GUESS THEY ARE BEING VERY
CAREFUL, KNOWING THEY HAVE A
VERY LARGE LEAD IN THAT
DIVISION.
SO THOUGHTS BEFORE WE GET A
BREAK HERE.
YOU HAVE FIVE SECONDS.
BILL: LOVE THOSE GUYS ON THE
GROUND CREW, MAKING THE FIELD
PRETTY FOR THOSE GUYS TO PLAY
ON.
MATT: WE'LL BE BACK.
>> TO MOST TRY TO THROW HIM OUT
AND HE DOES! -- TIM WILL TRY TO
THROW HIM OUT, AND HE DOES! WHAT
A GLOVE.
LONG THROW, AND HE GOT IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CALL THAT.
IT IS A 4-3 GROUND OUT, BUT COME
ON.
>> THAT WAS PRETTY MUCH IN RIGHT
FIELD.
THAT WAS A FINE PLAY.
>> HE'S GOT IT.
A NICE CATCH TO END THE INNING.
TIM TO THE GLOVE SIDE.
>> SPARKLING DEFENSE.
THE FOOTWORK ON THE SPIN MOVE.
>> GOLD GLOVE OF STUFF.
FLY BALL WELL HIT, GONE.
>> WHAT DID YOU SAY ABOUT POWER?
THAT IS AN ENORMOUS INSURANCE
HOME RUN.
CESAR HERNANDEZ, HIS FIRST WHITE
SOX HOME RUN.
THE CUBS AGAINST THE CROSSTOWN
RIVALS.
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE
PREGAME SHOW CUMBER PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE SHORTS.
WE WILL IN LIAM HENDRIKS OF THE
WHITE SOX, THE CLOSER FOR THAT
FIRST-PLACE TEAM IN THE AL
CENTRAL.
WE ARE GOING TO GET RIGHT TO THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM.
LET'S MAKE THIS CLEAR, I'M NOT
CALLING CRAIG KIMBREL AN
ELEPHANT.
HOWEVER, I'M GOING TO ASK YOU --
I SAW THE QUOTES THAT YOU HAD
AFTER THE ACQUISITION, ABOUT
JUST WANTING TO WIN.
YOU DON'T CARE, YOU JUST WANT TO
WIN.
DID IT TAKE YOU A LITTLE TIME TO
GET TO THAT POINT WHEN YOU HEARD
ABOUT THE ACQUISITION?
LIAM: NOT REALLY, BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY, IN 2019 ONE OF
MY BETTER YEARS, I STARTED AS
THE LONG GUY.
I DIDN'T CARE WHAT ROLE I HAD
FULL TO I JUST WANTED TO PITCH.
WHEN I GET A LITTLE BIT
EGOTISTICAL, KIND OF HOTHEADED,
THAT IS WHEN I START STRUGGLING.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO MAKE
SURE IS I NEVER WANT TO FEEL
LIKE I'M GIVEN SOMETHING.
I HAVE TO EARN IT EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND KEEP PUSHING US BOTH
BECAUSE I THINK NOW WE HAVE A
LITTLE STRIKEOUT RECORD JUST TO
ATTACK EACH OTHER AND SEE WHO
WINS.
BILL: I WILL GO WITH THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM, TOO.
WE ARE WORKING ON COFFEE NUMBER
TWO, SO WHETHER IT IS THE
SEVENTH OR EIGHTH OR NINTH, YOU
HAVE THAT GAME GOING ON TODAY.
YOU MAINTAIN THIS COFFEE FLEW
ALL THE WAY THROUGH, OR DO YOU
TAKE A BREAK SOMEWHERE?
LIAM: ONCE I FINISH THIS ONE,
I'M GOING TO HAVE A DOUGHNUT AND
ANOTHER COFFEE.
I WILL TAKE IT OUT ON THE FIELD
WITH ME.
I WILL HAVE A COUPLE OF NIGHT
CAPS AFTER THAT WITH COFFEE
BECAUSE I DON'T DRINK IT ALL
THAT I DON'T DRINK AT ALL.
I AVERAGE SEVEN OR EIGHT CUPS AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
MATT: THAT'S HEALTHY, BY THE
WAY.
MY WANT TO POINT THAT OUT.
THE DOUGHNUT ON TOP OF IT MAKES
IT BETTER.
BILL: I LIKE THAT MORE.
MATT: THE THREE OF US WOULD GET
ALONG GREAT IF WE HUNG OUT
TOGETHER.
LIAM: I JUST HAD MY CARDIGAN
DONUTS FROM OUT HERE.
THEY HAVE A MIAMI HEAT, WHICH IS
MANGO WITH CHILLI PEPPERS MIXED
IN THERE AS WELL.
MATT: WOW.
LOOK, YOUR G.I. SYSTEM IS GOING
TO HAVE A REALLY HARD TIME WITH
THIS.
LET ME GO TO THIS.
WHEN YOU ARE ON THE MOUND, WE
APPRECIATE THE FIRE, THE
INTENSITY.
I TALK TO YOU OFF-CAMERA A
COUPLE YEARS AGO IN OAKLAND.
YOU WERE NOT THE GUY WE SEE ON
THE MOUND DURING A GAME.
HOW DO YOU KIND OF TURN IT ON,
TURN IT OFF?
YOU ARE A PITBULL, MAN.
LIAM: IT TOOK A WHILE TO GET TO
THAT POINT.
BUT I LIKE TO JOKE AROUND COME
HAVE SOME FUN ON THE MOUND
FULL-TIME I'M ALL BUSINESS AND
GET A LITTLE ANGRY.
TALKING TO CORY PROVUS, THE
RADIO BROADCASTER WITH THE
TWINS, AND I SAID EVERYTHING A
LITTLE HITTER DOES ANNOYS ME.
WHETHER THEY SWING TOO HARD,
LOOK THE WRONG DIRECTION,
WHETHER DIDN'T -- WHETHER THEY
DIDN'T SAY HELLO AND AS I WALKED
INTO THE BULLPEN, EVERY LITTLE
BIT IS ANGST AND ANGER I CAN USE
AGAINST THEM.
YOU CAN TELL WHEN I'M REALLY MAD
BECAUSE MY SKIN GOES RED.
BILL: WE SIT HERE FROM A
DISTANCE NBC KIND OF A COMPLETE
TEAM.
-- WE SIT HERE FROM A DISTANCE
AND WE SEE KIND OF A COMPLETE
TEAM.
DO YOU GUYS FEEL THE SAME WAY
WHEN YOU'RE WALKING INTO THE
CLUBHOUSE, THAT WHATEVER DAY IT
MIGHT BE, ONE PART OF THIS TEAM
-- WHETHER IT IS THE OFFENSE,
DEFENSE, STARTING PITCHERS, THE
BULLPEN -- THEY ALWAYS SEEM TO
PICK UP THE SLACK.
IT'S A PRETTY COMPLETE SQUAD YOU
HAVE.
LIAM: IT'S AMAZING FULL TOP THE
ONLY DOWNFALL ABOUT THIS IS THAT
BATTING PRACTICE IS NO FUN FOR
ME BECAUSE -- IT IS AMAZING FOR
ME.
THE ONLY DOWNPOUR IS THAT
BATTING PRACTICE IS NO FUN FOR
ME BECAUSE NONE OF THE BALLS
COME BACK.
IT IS FUN.
IT'S A GOOD TEAM.
THE BIGGEST THING ABOUT THIS
TEAM IS THAT -- THAT IS PIVOTAL
TO SUCCESS IS THAT WE READ EACH
OTHER AT ALL THAT WE RAG ON EACH
OTHER AT ALL TIMES.
WE DON'T LET ANYBODY GET
BEHEADED, ANYBODY GET
EGOTISTICAL.
BILL: YOU TALK ABOUT GETTING
YOUR LINEUP BACK.
IN A LITTLE BIT, SOME OF THE
YOUNG GUYS, THAT WHEN YOUR BIG
PIECES WERE OUT OF THE LINEUP,
SOME OF THE YOUNG BOYS COMING
UP, THEY HAD THEIR HAND IN QUITE
A FEW WINS AS WELL.
TALK ABOUT THE GUYS WHO STEPPED
UP WHEN SOME OF THE GUYS WERE
OUT OF THE LINEUP.
LOOK AT ANDREW VAUGHN.
--
LIAM: LOOK AT ANDREW VAUGHN.
THEY TOLD HIM WITH TWO DAYS OR
THREE DAYS LEFT TO GO, LET'S TRY
OUT LEFT FIELD, RAN OUT THERE
AND WAS ABLE TO NAIL IT DOWN.
THEN YOU MIX IN GUYS LIKE OUR UP
AND DOWN WITH -- AS ZACK COLLINS
HAS SHOWN, CAN WORK ON THINGS
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR.
IT JUST SHOWS THE WORK ETHIC HE
IS PUTTING IN.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE, THE NEXT GUY
UP MENTALITY, THE GUYS THAT HAVE
COME UP HERE.
I THINK THAT PLAYS INTO THE
WHOLE MENTALITY.
WE MAKE FRONT OF EVERYBODY.
WE DON'T CARE IF IT IS 10 OR 15
YEARS IN THE BIG LEAGUES OR IF
IT IS YOUR FIRST DAY.
WE ARE STILL GOING TO MAKE FUN
OF YOU FULL-TIME IT IS A FAMILY
HERE.
IT HAS WORKED SO FAR AND
HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE THE REST
OF THE YEAR.
MATT: BUT IF YOU ARE MAKING FUN
OF PEOPLE TWICE YOUR SIZE, THAT
CAN BE DANGEROUS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ON TELEVISION
A BASEBALL TEAM WITH BIGGER
PEOPLE IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
EVERY GUY IS BIGGER THAN THE
NEXT GUY FULL-TIME YOU WALK IN
THAT CLUBHOUSE, YOU ARE NOT
SMALL.
DO YOU WALK IN THERE AND SAY
WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON AROUND
HERE?
LIAM: I JUST MAKE SURE TO STAND
NEXT TO BILLY HAMILTON.
HE MAKES ME FEEL BIG.
THIS TEAM IS THE MONSTERS FROM
SPACE JAM.
IT IS NOT FAIR, IT IS NOT RIGHT.
BUT IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE WE GO OUT THERE AND
REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE -- ELOY
IS JUST A BIG BABY, AS EVERYONE
CALLS HIM.
NOW I GET A CHANCE TO SEE THAT
FULL-TIME.
THE GUY DOESN'T STOP SMILING.
IT'S JUST THAT ATTITUDE THAT WE
LOVE.
MATT: IOWA COMING UP.
YOU HAVE THAT GAME TOMORROW IN
IOWA.
I SAW A GREAT QUOTE FROM YOU.
DO YOU KNOW THE ONE I'M TALKING
ABOUT, REGARDING A HOME RUN?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT?
LIAM: I DON'T WANT TO BE THE
FIRST ONE TO GIVE UP A
BIG-LEAGUE HOMER IN IOWA.
THERE IS STILL TIME.
THE GOOD THING IS I'M NEVER
GOING TO BE THE FIRST, GOING TO
BE GIVING UP A WALKOFF HOMER, SO
THERE IS THAT.
MATT: THAT'S GOING TO BE A WHOLE
LOT OF FUN.
REALLY IMPORTANT -- STAY
HEALTHY, HAVE FUN, AND I HOPE
YOU GET TO THAT WORLD SERIES,
MAN, BECAUSE YOU'RE PUTTING IN
YOUR TIME AND YOU HAVE GOTTEN TO
THE POSTSEASON.
MAYBE THIS IS THE YEAR.
LIAM HENDRIKS, THANK YOU.
LIAM: THANKS, GUYS.
APPRECIATE IT.
BILL: THANKS, LIAM.
MATT: TIME NOW FOR OUR CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT, AND WE WELCOME IN
ANDY LEON, ALSO KNOWN AS ANDY
DY RULLO.
HIS FAVORITE TEAM, THE MARINERS.
HIS FAVORITE MOMENT FOR HIM, THE
2012 PERFECT GAME THROWN BY
FELIX HERNANDEZ, THE ONLY GUY TO
DO THAT AND MARINERS HISTORY.
WELCOME INTO THE SHOW.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE GAME FOLKS
ARE GOING TO SEE TODAY.
THE WHITE SOX AND THE TWINS, AND
YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS ON EACH
TEAM.
WHO ARE THEY?
ANDY: FOR THE TWINS I WOULD SAY
BYRON BUXTON, LOVE A GOOD CENTER
FIELDER.
I KNOW HE'S NOT ON THE FIELD
RIGHT NOW, BUT WHEN HE GETS
HEALTHY AND IS OUT THERE, HE IS
DOING HIS THING.
FOR THE WHITE SOX, I WOULD
PROBABLY SAY TIM ANDERSON.
JUST BECAUSE HE IS UNABASHEDLY
HIMSELF ON THE FIELD THERE.
HE BRINGS SWAG, THAT NEW STYLE
OF BASEBALL THAT THE KIDS
HOPEFULLY LOVE.
I LOVE IT, YEAH, I LOVE
ANDERSON.
MATT: THE KIDS DO LOVE IT, BUT
HE IS CERTAINLY EXCITING TO
WATCH.
SOME PEOPLE SAY, NO, NO, THAT IS
NOT OLD-SCHOOL.
HE'S ACTUALLY NOT IN THE LINEUP
TODAY.
THEY GAVE HIM A DAY OFF.
GIVE ME YOUR TAKE ON YOUR M'S,
YOUR MARINERS.
THIS SEASON, HOPING THAT -- DO
THEY REALLY HAVE A SHOT TO GET
IN, IS WHAT I'M ASKING?
ANDY: WE WERE RIGHT THERE A GAME
AND A HALF BEHIND THE LETTER A'S
FOR THAT WILD-CARD A WEEK AGO,
AND WE DROPPED DOWN A LITTLE
BIT.
ALL THE PIECES ARE THERE, ALL
THE YOUNG PIECES.
I'M A BIG KYLE SEAGER GUY, SO
YOU HAVE THAT VETERAN
LEADERSHIP.
HOPEFULLY WE PICK UP THE CLUB
OPTION FOR HIM NEXT YEAR AND
KEEP THINGS ROLLING.
WE BUILD OFF THIS YEAR.
IT COULD BE A FLUKE.
MARINERS ARE GOING TO BE THE
MARINERS.
I NEVER KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
THAT 20-YEAR PLAYOFF DROUGHT, 19
YEARS, TOO LONG.
WE WILL SAY.
MATT: THEY ARE 5.5 GAMES OUT OF
THE WILD-CARD.
I AM WITH YOU ON SEAGER, BY THE
WAY.
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH INTENTION --
ATTENTION.
I'M A BIG FAN AS WELL.
BACK IN 2012, FELIX, THROUGH HIS
-- FELIX THREW HIS PERFECT GAME.
I KNOW THAT'S BIG FOR YOU AS A
FAN.
WHERE WERE YOU, AND YOUR MEMBERS
OF THAT?
ANDY: I WAS HOME.
I HAD JUST WOKEN UP.
IT WAS A DAY GAME.
I WAS BROWSING FACEBOOK, AND ONE
OF MY FRIENDS SAID FELIX IS
DOING SOMETHING, TURN ON THE TV.
IT WAS LIKE THE SEVENTH, EIGHTH
INNING.
I WAS LIKE, OK, THIS IS GOING
ON.
YOU DON'T SAY PERFECT GAME.
I AM SUPER SUPERSTITIOUS.
I'M COUNTING OUTS, AND PROBABLY
TWO OR THREE OUTS TO GO, I
REMEMBER MY LITTLE BROTHER WAS
MOWING THE LAWN IN THE BACKYARD
OUTSIDE.
I DON'T WANT HIM TO MISS THIS
BECAUSE MY OLDER BROTHER WAS THE
REASON I MISSED RANDY JOHNSON'S
PERFECT GAME.
I WAS IN THE OTHER ROOM AND HE
IS SUPERSTITIOUS.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO BE LIKE, CHECK
THIS OUT, SOMETHING'S HAPPENING.
THEN I HEARD HIM CELEBRATING.
JOHNSON HAD A PERFECT GAME.
SO I MISSED THAT.
I DIDN'T WANT MY LITTLE BROTHER
TO MISS FELIX DOING THIS.
I YELLED AT HIM, GOT HIS
ATTENTION.
HE COMES IN, HE'S LIKE WHAT'S
GOING ON, IS IT A PERFECT GAME?
I'M LIKE SHUT UP, SHUT UP.
HE OBVIOUSLY GOT THE PERFECT
GAME.
WE WERE HOOTING AND HOLLERING
AND STUFF.
MY MOM WAS THERE.
MATT: THAT'S ALL MOST A WHOLE
DECADE AGO FULL-TIME INSANE.
YOUR YOUTUBE CHANNEL, WITH VIDEO
OF THE SOFTBALL GAMES -- TELL US
MORE ABOUT IT AND YOUR FAVORITE
MOMENTS.
ANDY: SO I LIKE TO WEAR THIS
HELMET.
I GOT IT RIGHT HERE.
I GO TO THIS LITTLE JOHN OLERUD
HELMET.
MARINERS LEGEND.
MATT: LOVE HIM.
ANDY: I'M JUST OUT THERE GOOFING
OFF, SAYING WHATEVER.
YOU'RE OUT THERE PLAYING WITH
YOUR FRIENDS, SAYING CRAZY
STUFF, DUMB STUFF, FUNNY STUFF,
JUST GOOFING OFF, AND OK COME
HERE YOU GO, YOU'RE SHOWING A
VIDEO OF IT.
WENT OVER THE FENCE, BROUGHT
THAT ONE BACK.
IT IS STUFF LIKE THAT.
NO YOU GO.
GETTING PROPS FROM COWBOY JEFF
RIGHT THERE.
HE'S BEEN ON THIS BEFORE.
HITTING DINGERS, DOING MY THING.
MATT: VERY COOL.
ANDY: WITH MY SOFTBALL BUDS.
MATT: WITH THE VIDEO, YOU CANNOT
DOG IT.
YOU GOT TO HUSTLE BECAUSE THEY
WILL BE -- THERE WILL BE VIDEO
PROOF YOU'RE NOT GIVING IT YOUR
ALL.
I JUST WANT TO POINT THAT OUT.
ANDY: TRUE, I'M ALWAYS HUSTLING.
I PLAY IN A PAIR OF SANDALS.
EVERYBODY GIVES ME GRIEF FOR IT.
BUT I PLAY IN LEGITIMATELY A
PAIR OF TEBOW LIKE -- OF TEV
A LIKE SANDALS.
THAT CATCH RIGHT THERE WAS IN
SANDALS.
MATT: ARE WE TALKING FLIP-FLOPS,
OR SANDALS WITH A STRAP?
ANDY: THEY STRAP ON.
YOU CAN KIND OF SEE THEM RIGHT
THERE FOR A SPLIT SECOND.
LITTLE STRAP.
THEY ARE ATTACHED TO MY FEET.
MATT: THAT MIGHT BE A NEW THING
AT SOME POINT.
I DON'T KNOW, THE GAME IS
CHANGING.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS CHANGING
THAT MUCH.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD LUCK AND KEEP MOVING ON
WITH THAT GOPRO.
THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF FUN.
ANDY: THANKS, MAN, APPRECIATE
IT.
MATT: COMING UP, THE GAME HERE
ON
REYNALDO LOPEZ ON THE HILL TODAY
, A LATE CHANGE IN THE ROTATION.
YOU WILL SEE LOPEZ, NUMBER 40,
ON THE HILL.
>> A HIGH FLY TO LEFT FIELD OFF
THE BAT OF GARVER.
HE HAS TOUCHED OFF FOR THREE RUN
HOME RUN.
WITH TWO OUT.
HE PUTS THE TWINS IN FRONT.
>> A SWING AND A DRIVE TO RIGHT
FIELD, AND DEEP DOWN THE LINE.
THAT BALL IS GOING TO BE FAIR
AND A HOME RUN.
A THREE-RUN NINTH INNING SHOT
DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
>> IN LEFT FIELD, THE LONG RUN
AND HE MAKES THE CATCH.
RUCKER WITH THE DIVING CATCH
NEAR THE FOUL LINE.
A HIGH FLY TO RIGHT FIELD, WAY
BACK AND GONE.
AND THE TWINS BREAK IT OPEN.
HOME RUNS 19 AND 20 TODAY FOR
POLANCO.
BAREHANDED, THREW HIM OUT!
WHAT A PLAY BY MIGUEL SANO TO
END THE GAME.
>> CAME CHARGING IN, GRABS IT
WITH THAT BIG RIGHT HAND, AND
THROWS IT ON MONEY TO GARVER AT
FIRST BASE.
WHAT A TERRIFIC PLAY.
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
IT IS TIME NOW FOR PICKS TO
CLICK, PRESENTED BY BETMGM.
ARE YOU READY?
BILL: I'M READY.
I'M ALL OVER THIS.
I THINK I'M 144 OUT OF 148 THAT
I'VE DONE THIS YEAR.
MATT: THAT'S A VERY GOOD
PERCENTAGE.
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE PENNANT, AND
THE WHITE SOX ARE FIRST UP.
PLUS 275.
DO THEY WIN THE AL CROWN?
BILL: I TOLD YOU THAT AT THE
BEGINNING.
I THINK THEY ARE THE FAVORITE,
SO I'M GOING TO BE SAYING YES TO
THE WHITE SOX.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN WHEN IT
COMES TO POSTSEASON PLAY.
I LIKE THIS SQUAD AND I'M GOING
TO GO WITH IT.
MATT: I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD
BE INSANE FOR YOU TO SAY THAT.
A.L. CY YOUNG AWARD.
WE HAVE LYNN, RODON, AND
GIOLITO.
WILL ANY OF THEM WHEN, AND WHO
WILL WIN IF NOT ANY OF THEM?
BILL: TAKING MY CHANCES WITH
THREE OF THEM IN THE MIX -- I'M
GOING TO SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WILL SAY YES.
ONE OF THEM IS GOING TO WIN IT.
MATT: DO YOU WANT TO TELL US
WHICH ONE?
BILL: NO, I SAID ONE OF THEM.
THAT IS THE WAY THAT THE
QUESTION WAS POSED.
A.L. ROOKIE OF THE YEAR, ANDREW
VAUGHN IS PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
PLUS 800 FOR ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
BILL: PROBABLY NOT AS GOOD, THE
ODDS WHEN YOU ARE LOOKING AT
THAT.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO SAY NO ON
THERE ARE TOO IN THAT FIELD
RIGHT NOW.
THAT COULD CHANGE IN TWO MONTHS,
I GET THAT.
BUT I'M GOING TO SAY NO.
MATT: WE ARE ACTING LIKE THE
SEASON IS ENDING.
NO, IT'S NOT.
IT'S LIKE SEVEN WEEKS.
TODAY'S GAME, TOTAL BASES, 1.5.
WALKS ARE NOT INCLUDED.
BILL: THEY ARE NOT.
MATT: IS HE OVER OR UNDER TOTAL
OF 1.5 TOTAL BASES?
BILL: HE CAN JAM ONE DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE CREATE TWO
HAYFORD BAG -- WITH A TWO-BAG
HIT.
MATT: THE FINAL ONE IS THE
OVER-UNDER IN RUNS SCORED IN THE
GAME TOTAL.
BOTH TEAMS COMBINED 9.5.
ARE YOU GOING OVER OR UNDER 9.5?
YOU HAVE TO LAY 1.10 TWO WHEN
ONE.
BILL: I'M GOING TO SAY OVER.
THE WHITE SOX LOST YESTERDAY.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE HAPPY
ABOUT THAT.
I'M GOING TO SAY OVER.
MATT: EVEN A DAY GAME, WHERE
THEY WON --
BILL: 6-4 IS THE 10TH SPOT.
MATT: NOW WE ROLL ALONG HERE, AS
YOU SEE THE FANS INTERACTING
WITH PLAYERS.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK POLL
RESULTS -- WHO IS GOING TO WIN
THE GAME?
OVERWHELMINGLY, THE WHITE SOX,
81%.
I'M GOING TO GO FIRST YEAR.
[BILL LAUGHS]
BILL: ARE YOU JUMPING IN WITH
THE 81?
MATT: I AGREE.
WHERE ARE YOU?
BILL: I'M GOING TO GO WITH SOLA
MENTE ON THIS.
THE WHITE SOX ARE NOT GOING TO
LOSE TWO IN A ROW.
MATT: TALK TO ME ABOUT THE
M.V.P..
BILL: HE'S AWESOME.
HE'S A GOOD INFLUENCE FOR
EVERYBODY ON THAT SQUAD.
THE MAN PLAYS EVERY DAY POSTOP.
GUESS HOW MANY GAMES WERE IN THE
SEASON LAST YEAR -- 60.
GUESS WHAT ELSE HE DID THAT I
REALLY LIKE.
HE DROVE IN 60 RUNS.
HE KNOWS HOW TO DO THINGS.
HE HAS 84 STAKES NOW.
IN A YEAR WHERE HE IS NOT
PLAYING THAT WELL WHEN IT COMES
TO THE 249 AVERAGE -- WHEN YOU
LOOK AT SOMEBODY WHO IS AT 84
STAKES, WHEN GUYS ARE OUT THERE,
HE IS WILLING TO HIT THE SAC
FLY, PUT THE BALL IN PLACE TO
MAYBE THE SECOND BASEMENT TO GET
A RUN ACROSS HOME PLATE.
RUNS MATTER.
YOU SCORE THESE THINGS, YOU ARE
AHEAD.
THAT'S WHAT I LIKE.
A CROSS HOME PLATE.
IF YOU ARE NOT SCORING ONE,
DRIVE-IN ONE.
I THINK ABREGO DOES BOTH VERY
WELL.
MATT: THE OTHER THING I LIKE
ABOUT HIM -- I'M GOING BACK A
COUPLE OF YEARS -- WHEN HE
DECIDED TO STAY IN CHICAGO, HE
SAID I WANTED TO WIN HERE.
HE SAW WHAT WAS COMING.
THERE IS SOMETHING TO DO THAT.
A GUY WHO DOESN'T JUMP AT MONEY
WHO DOESN'T SAY I'M GOING TO
CHECK OUT THE CITY -- HE SAID,
NO NO, I'M GOOD.
I LOVE IT.
I WANT TO WIN HERE.
MATT: HE IS STILL --
BILL: HE IS STILL WELL OFF.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT THE WHITE
SOX LOOKED AT HIM AND SAID THIS
IS A GUY WE CAN BUILD AROUND.
THE FACT THAT HE PLAYS EVERY DAY
-- HE HAS BEEN DOING IT FOR A
WHILE.
HIS .162-GAME AVERAGE -- LAST
YEAR WAS NOT A FLUKE WHEN HE WON
THE M.V.P..
THIS IS WHAT THE MAN DOES.
HE STANDS AT HOME PLATE AND
SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT, I COULD BE
THE GUY.
WHEN THEY GET INTO THE
POSTSEASON, THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF
FIREPOWER, WEAPONS ON THE
OFFENSIVE SIDE TO DO SOME
THINGS.
THAT DUDE STANDING IN THE
BATTER'S BOX IS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING BIG COME POSTSEASON.
MATT: HE IS A WINNING PLAYER, IN
MY OPINION.
HE MAY NOT BE THE FASTEST COME
HE MAY NOT BE THE BEST DEFENDER,
HE MAY NOT BE THIS.
HE IS A WINNING BASEBALL PLAYER.
BILL: AS FAR AS THE FIRST BIG
BAG THAT'S THE FIRST BASE BAG,
-- AS FAR AS THE FIRST BASE BAG,
YOU SEE THAT THE WHITE SOX TEAM
CAN COUNT ON HIM EVERY DAY.
MATT: THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK,
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
SCOTT BRAUN, LATROY HAWKINS, AND
LAUREN GARDNER ON THE SCENE IN
MINNESOTA FOBUILT -- FOR BILL
RIPKEN, I MATT YALLOF.
-- FOR BILL
RIPKEN, I MAENJOY!
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> TEMPERATURES LED BY THE
DIVISION --
TWO FRANCHISES WITH --
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS, IT
IS THE CHICAGO WHITE SOX AGAINST
THE MINNESOTA TWINS.
THE A.L. CENTRAL --
THE BALLPARK, SCOTT ALONG WITH
MY GOOD FRIEND LATROY HAWKINS.
IT FEELS GOOD.
YOU CAN FEEL THE LIFE ACTION.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FROM
STUDIOS FOR A LONG TIME.
LATROY: IT IS GREAT TO BE IN THE
BALLPARK.
SCOTTO THAT IS REALLY TARGET
FIELD.
-- SCOTT: THAT IS REALLY TARGET
THE CENTRAL LEAGUE BATTLE, THAT
WE JUST SHOWED YOU, YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
MOST OF THE SEASON.
BACK IN THE LINEUP,
CONGRESSIONAL THE BASEBALL.
NOT LIKE THEY NEEDED IT.
IN THE LINEUP --
FASTER THAN ANY OTHER PLAYER IN
THE FRANCHISE, 180 GATE SEVEN --
187 GAMES.
FOR THE MINNESOTA TWINS, ONE
CONSISTENT FORCE IN THE LINEUP,
HAS BEEN ON FIRE SINCE JULY.
LATROY: HE'S BEEN GREAT IN THE
LINEUP AND ON THE FIELD.
STARTED AT SHORTSTOP.
NOT TO THE POINT WHERE HIS
PRODUCTION -- PUTTING THE BALL
OUT OF THE BALLPARK.
HIT HIS NUMBERS.
LEADING BY EXAMPLE, THE
BREAKDOWN -- 50 R.B.I..
IT IS SHOWING RIGHT NOW.
LAUREN: THE WHITE SOX HAVE --
ONE OF THE LONGEST ACTS IN
BASEBALL.
THE REPLAY, WHEN THEY BEAT THE
TWINS 1-0.
IT WAS A SOLO SHOT.
BECAUSE AT FIRST HE WOULD HAVE
TO RESPECT THE GAME.
WE PROBABLY WON'T GO THAT DEEP
INTO THE POSTSEASON.
THERE'S A LOT TO FOCUS ON, A LOT
TO WORK ON.
YOU LOOK AT THIS ROTATION, YOU
LOOK AT THE BULLPEN, THIS MIGHT
BE ONE OF THE MOST COMPLETE
TEAMS IN BASEBALL.
OF COURSE, THERE SKIPPER SAID --
WE LOVE A CLICHÉ -- THE BASEBALL
GUYS ARE ALWAYS WATCHING.
WHEN WE COME BACK, WE HAVE
STARTING LINEUPS, AND FIRST
PITCH FROM TARGET FIELD.
AND MINNESOTA.
BEAUTIFUL DAY IN MINNEAPOLIS.
FANS GETTING READY FOR AN EARLY
FIRST PITCH.
>> THAT IS TO RIGHT, IT'S DEEP,
AND IT'S GONE.
TWO-RUN HOMER.
TIM ANDERSON.
IT IS 3-0.
TO CENTER, IT'S GOING TO GET
DOWN.
IT IS AN R.B.I. HIT FOR TIM.
HIS THIRD OF THE NIGHT.
>> WHEN TIM STARTS TO GET HOT,
THE BALLCLUB STARTS TO GET HOT.
BECAUSE HE IS SO GOOD WITH A
GLOVE.
>> TRIES TO THROW HIM OUT AND
GOT HIM!
TIM WITH A BASE HIT.
>> THERE IS THE SALVAGE.
8-4.
>> FIRST PITCH SWING, A DRIVE TO
RIGHT.
IT IS GOING TO GO.
ONE PITCH, ONE RUN.
RED SOX LEAD 1-0.
-- WHITE SOX LEAD FOR THIS --
1-0.
2-1.
DEEP RIGHT CENTER, THE BALL IS
GOING TO GET TO THE WALL.
SITS ON THE TRACK.
A THREE-HIT NIGHT.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
TRY SHORTS IN THE YOUTUBE APP ON
YOUR PHONE.
WE ARE STREAMING LIVE GLOBALLY
ON MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
IT'S FREE.
TELL YOUR FRIENDS.
OVER 3 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS TO
THIS CHANNEL.
ALSO CAN RECEIVE NOTIFICATIONS
PRIOR TO UPCOMING GAMES LIKE THE
ONE ABOUT TO BEGIN.
MAKE SURE YOU CAN CHECK OUT OUR
NEW FUTURE.
YOU CAN CHOOSE YOUR OWN
LISTENING EXPERIENCE ON YOUR
FAVORITE DOES ISIS BY SELECTING
PRIMARY, HOME, OR AWAY ON THE
AUDIO TRACK SETTINGS.
WE WILL TALK MORE ABOUT THAT AS
WE CONTINUE ON.
FOR YOUTUBE TV CUSTOMERS.
LET'S GO TOE TO TOE, HEAD TO
HEAD, TAIL OF THE TAPE.
IT HAS BEEN LOPSIDED, LATROY.
NOT ONLY HAS CHICAGO TAKEN 13 OF
18 MATCHUPS, BUT THE 123 RUNS
ARE THE MOST SCORED BY A TEAM
AGAINST THE SINGLE OPPONENT THIS
SEASON.
A.K.A. THEY ARE HAVING FUN WITH
TWINS PITCHING.
LATROY: THEY HAVE A VERY
EXPLOSIVE OFFENSE.
YOU DON'T PITCH THEM SIMILAR TO
THE WAY GRIFFIN JAX PITCHED HIM
LAST NIGHT.
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE UP YOUR
SHARE OF HOME RUNS.
I THINK IT MAKES THEM THAT MUCH
BETTER THIS YEAR, WHEN THE TEAMS
HAS SHIFTED THEM, THEY ARE BIG
BOPPERS LIKE ANDERSON, A
BRAILLE, HITTING THE BALL THE
OTHER WAY.
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE THE TEAM,
WHAT THE TEAM GIVES THEM.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE MOST SENIOR
MANAGERS WE HAVE EVER SEEN IN
THE GAME, TONY LA RUSSA, 76
YEARS OLD, THIRD OLDEST TO EVER
MANAGE IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL,
ALSO THE THIRD IN WINS.
WE HAD A NICE CONVERSATION WITH
TONY FOR 45 MYTHS THIS MORNING.
HE ALSO MANAGED THIS WHITE SOX
CLUB IN 1979 THROUGH 1986.
FAST-FORWARD TO 2021, HIS BACK.
LATROY: OUR INTERVIEW WITH HIM
WAS VERY ENLIGHTENING.
WAS DELIGHTFUL.
I'VE NEVER SAT DOWN AND HAD A
REAL CONVERSATION WITH HIM, AND
IT WAS ENLIGHTENING TO LISTEN TO
HOW HE THINGS ABOUT THE GAME,
USING HIS MIND COME HIS EYES,
AND TRUSTING HIS GUT, THINGS
LIKE THAT.
I WAS A LITTLE WORRIED WHEN HE
WENT OVER TO MANAGE HIS YOUNG,
TALENTED TEAM.
AND AFTER SEEING WHAT THEY ARE
DOING THIS YEAR, I DON'T HAVE
ANY WORRIES AT ALL.
HE'S LETTING THOSE GUYS GO OUT
THERE AND PLAY THE GAME.
DIDN'T TRY TO CHANGE ANYBODY.
JUST SIT BACK, WATCH, ADD A
LITTLE BIT HERE AND THERE.
SCOTT: HE'S RELAXED, AND WHY
NOT?
YOUTUBE SHORTS, STARTING NINE
FROM TONY'S SQUAD.
FEATURING CESAR HERNANDEZ,
SOMEWHAT OF A NEW AD DISH AND.
JIMENEZ HAS BEEN THE BIG BAT.
9-22 IN HIS LAST SIX.
GOODWIN HAS DONE A NICE JOB IN
RIGHT FIELD.
JAKE LAMB GETS THE START AT
THIRD.
LEURY GARCIA GETS THE START AT
SHORT.
THAT COLLINS CATCHES TODAY.
WE HAVE THE OLDEST ACTING
MANAGER AND THEN ROCCO BALDELLI.
I KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE NELSON
CRUZ ANYMORE, AND WHEN HE IS
THERE, HE IS YOUNGER THAN NELSON
CRUZ.
THE THIRD-YEAR MANAGER OF
MINNESOTA, 186 UP, 150 DOWN.
ACTIVEX -- BACK-TO-BACK DIVISION
TITLES THIS YEAR.
WHEN YOU TALK TO PEOPLE AROUND
THE ORGANIZATION AND FM WHAT HAS
KEPT THE CLUB TOGETHER THIS
YEAR, THE ANSWER IS ROCCO
BALDELLI.
LATROY: HE DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE
THE CREDIT FOR IT.
IT ALL STARTS AT THE TOP, AND HE
IS THE LEADER OF THAT TEAM, THE
MANAGER.
HIS WORDS AND HIS ABILITY TO
REACH THE YOUNG PLAYERS AND SELL
THEM ON, YOU KNOW WHAT, WE
WANTED AN OLDER TEAM, NOW WE
WANT A YOUNGER TEAM.
NOW WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
FUNDAMENTALS -- I WANT YOU GUYS
TO GET USED TO PUTTING IN THAT
TYPE OF WORK, AND NEXT YEAR WE
WILL SEE WHERE THEY ARE GOING TO
BE.
SCOTT: THE ROOKIE MAKING HIS
13TH CAREER START.
HE'S BEEN BETTER SINCE JULY.
4.99 ON THE SEASON.
HE IS TALL, 6'9", LISTED AT
6'9", TALLEST EVER TO START THE
GAME.
THIS GUY IS DIFFERENT.
LATROY: THE HEIGHT, HIS ABILITY
TO USE HIS LENGTH TO HIS
ADVANTAGE, HE IS NOT THROWING
95, 90 6, 97 MILES PER HOUR.
HE IS REACHING OUT THERE, AND BY
THE TIME HE RELEASES THE BALL,
HE IS HALFWAY DOWN THE MOUND AND
IT LOOKS HARDER THAN WHAT IT
REALLY IS.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
93 MIGHT FEEL LIKE 96, 97, 98
EVEN?
CESAR HERNANDEZ COMING OFF A
SEASON WHEN HE LED THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE IN DOUBLES THIS YEAR, A
CAREER-HIGH IN HOMERS.
LIVE ON YOUTUBE BUT WATCHING
GLOBALLY, ALL THREE, RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT BRAUN, LATROY HAWKINS, AND
LAUREN GARDNER WITH YOU TODAY.
HERNANDEZ, A GOOD ON-BASE
PERCENTAGE GUY, GOLD LAST YEAR,
WON THE AWARD FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HIS CAREER LAST YEAR.
YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN THE
DIFFERENCES WITH THE WHITE SOX
IN THE PAST WEEK OR SO.
WITH HERNANDEZ BACK, ALONG WITH
LUIS ROBERT MANNING CENTER
THESE DAYS.
SUDDENLY, A DEFENSIVE BOOST FOR
A TEAM THAT IS ALREADY LEADING
THE DIVISION.
LATROY: HE IS A GAME CHANGER IN
CENTER FIELD.
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
HIS SIZE, SPEED, STRENGTH,
ABILITY TO THROW.
FILLING IN WHILE HE WAS ON THE
DL, I.L., EARLY PART OF THE
SEASON, DID A GREAT JOB.
THEY ARE VERY EXCITED TO HAVE
HIM BACK IN THE LINEUP, AND I'M
EXCITED TO WATCH AND PLAY.
SCOTT: TWO PLAYERS WHO WON
GOLDEN GLOVES LAST YEAR, BACK
INTO THE FULL.
94 PRETTY MUCH DOWN THE PIPE,
BUT IT HAS A BIT OF A DIFFERENT
FEEL.
SOME EXTRA LIFE TO IT.
LATROY: THAT FULL SEASON
FASTBALL HAS A LOT OF CARRY ON
IT.
A LOT OF GUYS SWING STRAIGHT
THROUGH THAT.
HE IS ONE OF THESE GUYS WHO CAN
PITCH WITH HIS FASTBALL AGAINST
CERTAIN TEAMS AND BE FINE, BUT
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO MIX IN
HIS BREAKING BALL AND USE HIS
CHANGEUP.
SCOTT: ARE PITCHER BREAKDOWN
PRESENTED BY -- OUR PITCHER
BREAKDOWN PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE
SHORTS.
LATROY: KEEP IT IN THE YARD.
THIS TEAM WILL HIT IT OUT OF THE
BALLPARK IF THEY THROW COOKIES
UP THERE.
HE HAS TOMATOES IN-GAME
ADJUSTMENTS.
MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT RIGHT THERE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE 2-0 AGAINST
THIS TEAM.
SCOTT: GOING UP AGAINST ANDREW
VAUGHN.
LATROY: VON IS ANOTHER EXCITING
PLAYER WITH THE WHITE SOX, PLAYS
WITH HIS HAIR ON FIRE, RINGS A
LOT OF ENERGY TO HIS BALL TEAM.
SCOTT: A BIG CUT AND A MISS ON
THAT 94, THE OVERUSE TO STRIKE
OUT HERNANDEZ.
VAUGHN A FORMER OVERALL PICK FOR
2019.
WON THE GOLDEN SPIKES AWARD IN
2018.
TO SHORT, SIMMONS PUTS HIM AWAY.
CHECK OUT THE TOTAL RUNS.
COURTESY OF BETMGM.
9.5 IS THE NUMBER.
THAT WAS CHANGED A LITTLE BIT.
LANCE LYNN, CY YOUNG FRONT
RUNNER IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE,
GOING TO BE USED TOMORROW IN THE
FIELD OF DREAMS GAME FOR THE
CHICAGO WHITE SOX.
THAT MEANS IT IS OVER AGAINST
REYNALDO LOPEZ.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
ARE WE GOING TO GET 10 RUNS
TODAY?
LATROY: I HOPE NOT.
IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY LONG
GAME TOMORROW.
I WANTED TO BE 2-1, 2-0, A LOT
OF STRIKEOUTS.
WE HAVE SEEN OUR SHARE OF
STRIKEOUTS SO FAR IN THE SEASON,
BUT I'M LOOKING FOR A PITCHERS
DUEL.
SCOTT: I THINK YOU'VE GOT A
SHOT.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE TWO
TEAMS CAN SWING A BAT, BOTH
PITCHERS ON THE MOUND HAVE
SOMETHING TO PROVE.
LATROY: 6'9" COME AS YOU
MENTION.
HE DOES A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
STAYING IN HIS DELIVERY,
CONTROLLING THAT LONG BODY,
WHICH IS TOUGH TO DO.
YOU SEE A SHORTER GUY, THEY
CONTROL THEIR BODY A LOT BETTER.
IT IS A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT
FOR GUYS WHO ARE TALL AND LANKY
LIKE HE IS, AND HE'S ABLE TO
REPEAT HIS DELIVERY QUITE
FREQUENTLY.
SCOTT: JOSE ABREU HAS HAD SOME
FUN FOR WITH HIM.
3-7, A DOUBLE, TRIPLE, HOMER.
LAST YEAR'S M.V.P..
2-2.
THAT IS A GOOD POINT ABOUT OVER,
THE FACT THAT IT TAKES TALLER
PITCHERS MORE TIME TO REFINE
THEIR MECHANICS.
IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A
PROBLEM FOR THE 24-YEAR-OLD ON
THE MOUND.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD STUFF.
A ONE-TO-THREE FIRST.
FREEZES THE FORMER M.V.P., AND
WE WILL HEAD TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE FIRST INNING IN TARGET
FIELD.
LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
>> A SWING AND A DRIVE INTO
RIGHT FIELD, DEEP DOWN THE LINE.
THAT BALL IS GOING TO BE FAIR
AND A HOME RUN.
POLANCO, A THREE-RUN NINTH
INNING SHOT DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE.
A SWING AND A BLAST INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
HEADED TOWARD THE SEATS AND
GONE.
POLANCO DOES IT AGAIN.
1-0, TWINS.
>> 3-0, AND NOW POLANCO.
GARCIA SAFE AT FIRST.
POLANCO BEAT OUT THE HIT AND
DROVE IN ANOTHER RUN.
JANIK SCORES FROM THIRD BASE.
STROKE TO THE RIGHT-FIELD
CORNER, DOWN FOR A HIT.
POLANCO ROUNDING FIRST, WILL DIG
FOR SECOND.
TUCKER HAS A GOOD ARM BUT
POLANCO IS IN WITH THE FIRST
PITCH, DOUBLE IN THE SIXTH
INNING.
POLANCO LIFTS IT TO LEFT FIELD.
ALVAREZ IS BACK, LOOKING UP, AND
IT'S GONE TO LEFT FIELD.
HOMER NUMBER 19 FOR POLANCO.
IT IS A 4-2 BALLGAME.
A HIGH FLY TO RIGHT FIELD, WAY
BACK AND GONE.
NUMBER 20 FOR POLANCO.
SCOTT: AN IMPRESSIVE TOP OF THE
FIRST, AND NOW HIS OFFENSE WILL
TAKE OVER IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
FIRST INNING, LED BY MAX KEPLER.
POLANCO, A CONSISTENT FORCE.
12-24 DURING AN EIGHT-GAME PITCH
STREAK.
HE CAN REALLY SWING THE BAT AND
MAKE CONTACT.
JAKE CAVE, RYAN JEFFRESS, TREVOR
LARNACH, ANDRELTON SIMMONS.
THAT LINEUP BROUGHT TO YOU BY
YOUTUBE SHORTS.
THIS IS REYNALDO LOPEZ, WHO
FINDS OUT HE IS GOING TO BE THE
MAN ON THE MOUND INSTEAD OF
LANCE LYNN TODAY.
THERE WAS A TRANSACTIONAL MOVE
AS WELL.
CARLOS RODON HITS THE INJURED
LIST WITH SHOULDER FATIGUE, TONY
LA RUSSA TOLD US JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF SORENESS.
HE WILL BE BACK SOON.
THE FIELD OF DREAMS GAME A
SPECIAL GEM ON THE CALENDAR IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL, BUT LOPEZ
HAS A 1.59 E.R.A. SO FAR THIS
SEASON.
NINE APPEARANCES, ONE OF THEM
STARTING AGAINST MINNESOTA.
A LITTLE EXCUSE ME SWING FROM
MAX KEPLER, AND THEY WILL PUT
HIM AWAY.
A LITTLE PITCHER RICK DOWN
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
WHAT IS REYNALDO LOPEZ ALL
ABOUT?
HE HAS HAD AN UP-AND-DOWN CAREER
SO FAR.
LATROY: HE HAS.
HIS DELIVERY, NOT GETTING TOO
WILD WITH HIS BODY CONTROL.
HIS FASTBALL LOCATION TENDS TO
MISS OVER THE MIDDLE.
IF HE CAN PLAY WITH THE CORNERS,
HE WILL HAVE SUCCESS TODAY.
GO FOR BROKE.
HE'S AUDITIONING TO BE IN THIS
ROTATION.
IS THERE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF
THE INJURED LIST.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE CAN DO.
A LOT OF FASTBALLS OVER THE
PLATE, WILL USE HIS SLIDER.
LIKE YOU SAW RIGHT THERE, USE
THAT SLIDER FOR A STRIKEOUT,
MOSTLY OUT OF THE ZONE.
SCOTT: BRENT ROOKER IS TRYING TO
FIND HIMSELF.
ONE FOR HIS LAST 20, IN A 0-2
HOLE.
HE HAD SURGERY ON BOTH CORNEAS
IN EARLY MAY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING THAT
CAN HELP THE PITCHER, IF YOU
ASKED ME.
I THINK FOR ANY PROFESSION THAT
WILL HELP THE CAUSE IF YOU HAVE
VISION ISSUES.
WE HAVE SOME PLAYERS THAT HAVE
LASIX SURGERY.
IF THIS CASE FOR LOPEZ, IT HELPS
HIM.
THAT SENSE PAINFUL, TOO.
LATROY: HE HAD TO HAVE BOTH EYES
OPERATED ON, AND THAT IS PRETTY
TOUGH.
HE HAS DONE A GREAT JOB,
ESPECIALLY COMING OUT OF THE
BULLPEN.
HE DROPPED ONE OF HIS PITCHES, A
FASTBALL SLIDER GUY COMING OUT
OF THE BULLPEN.
ON THE MOUND AS A STARTER.
IT INCLUDES THE CURVEBALL, WHICH
LOOKS LIKE THE SLIDER, JUST A
SLOWER VERSION OF IT.
AND HIS CHANGEUP SOMETIMES.
SCOTT: HE CAN DIAL IT UP.
HE WAS A PRETTY BIG PROSPECT.
THAT DEAL, LOOKS TO BE LUCAS
GIOLITO.
CHECK SWING.
LATROY: FASTBALL IS ANYWHERE
BETWEEN 92 AND 98 WITH SLIGHT
CARRY.
TICKED UP HIGHER THAN THAT,
COMING OUT OF THE BULLPEN FOR A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME.
CURVEBALL.
SCOTT: ANOTHER CHECK SWING COME
AND HE DID NOT GO.
A PRETTY WIDE VARIANCE ON THE
FASTBALL VELOCITY.
YOU WILL HEAR LIKE 92 TO 94, 95.
THE FACT THAT HE CAN REALLY
SWITCH IT UP IN TERMS OF WHAT HE
BRINGS TO THE TABLE WITH THE
HEATER.
THERE IS 94 UP.
LOFTED, SHALLOW RIGHT, BACKING
UP HERNANDEZ.
AND HE HAS GOT IT.
THAT WILL RETIRE THE WHITE SOX.
1, 2, 3.
IN MINNEAPOLIS.
>> >> THEY ARE HARD TO CATCH.
PARTICULAR WITH TIM ANDERSON, HE
GETS IT DONE.
FROM THE 24-YEAR-OLD FROM TEXAS,
IT IS ANDERSON, PULLS IT TO
LEFT, AND WHAT A WAY TO START.
JUST LIKE YESTERDAY AT WRIGLEY
FOR TIM ANDERSON.
>> THE YOUNG MAN STARTED TO GET
HIS RHYTHM.
>> THIS ONE WELL TO CENTER,
LOOKS UP, AND JIMENEZ DOES IT
AGAIN.
HOW IS THIS FOR A FIRST INNING?
IT IS 3-0 WHITE SOX IN
MINNESOTA.
HE TAGS THIS ONE TO LEFT, DOWN
THE LINE INTO THE CORNER, AND
THAT BALL IS GONE.
A THREE-RUN SHOT FOR HIM.
HE HAS GOT DEEP TWICE IN THE
FIRST INNING.
>> GOOD TO SEE GIOLITO GOING
LIKE THIS.
>> IT HAS BEEN A GOOD NIGHT SO
FAR.
SLIDER HAS BEEN VERY GOOD.
OTHER UP AND DOWN, IN OR OUT,
THE FERTILE -- THE FULL ARSENAL
ON DISPLAY FOR LUCAS GIOLITO.
TAGS THIS WENT TO CENTER WITH
CAVE BACK, AND THERE IS SOME
HARD CONTACT.
STRAIGHTAWAY CENTER FOR YOAN
MONCADA.
SCOTT: NO SCORE TOP TWO AT
TARGET FIELD.
WE ARE ALWAYS INNOVATING HERE AT
YOUTUBE WITH OUR GAMES, SO FANS
WATCHING THE GAME OF THE WEEK
HAVE THE CHOICE OF LISTENING TO
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FEEDS.
YOU CLICK THE GEAR ICON AND YOUR
PLAYER.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON YOUR SCREEN,
AND THEN YOU CAN CHOOSE AUDIO
TRACK.
YOU CAN SELECT PRIMARY AND HANG
OUT WITH US, SCOTT BRAUN, LATROY
HAWKINS, LAUREN GARDNER.
AND RADIO CALLS.
ALL AUDIO IS SEAMLESSLY
INTEGRATED ON YOUR DEVICES SO
YOU DON'T MISS A MINUTE OF THE
ACTION.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
TRUST ME.
LATROY: SOUNDS LIKE A LOT, BUT
IT IS VERY SIMPLE.
SCOTT: EVERYTHING IS SUPER
SIMPLE.
WHEN I TALK TO FRIENDS, FAMILY,
WHEN YOU WANT TO WATCH THE GAME,
GO TO YOUTUBE.
READY TO WORK IN INNING NUMBER
TWO.
FIRST PITCH, SWING ON THE HANDS,
THAT IS GOING TO DROP.
FIND SOME SPACE IN CENTER FIELD.
JIMENEZ, USUALLY WHEN HE MAKES
CONTACT, GOES 100 PLUS OFF THE
BAT, AND HE GOES A LONG WAY.
LOOK AT HIM JUMPING UP AND DOWN.
LOOK WHAT I FOUND.
LATROY: THE OUTFIELDER, JK, IS
OUT THERE.
HE WILL HIT THE BALL OUT OF THE
BALLPARK.
JUST DROP THAT RIGHT OVER
POLANCO HEAD -- POLANCO SET
AHEAD FOR A LEADOFF SINGLE.
THE LITTLE JAM SHOT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM LOOKING AT HIS
THUMB LIKE, OK, I'LL TAKE THE
HIT, BUT MY THUMB DOESN'T FEEL
WELL RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: IN TIGHT TO BRIAN
GOODMAN.
JIMENEZ ON SUNDAY AND MONDAY PUT
TOGETHER TWO HOME RUN, HIGH
PERFORMANCES.
LATROY: VERY IMPRESSED WITH
BRIAN GOODMAN, ABLE TO WATCH HIM
PLAY, COME IN, TAKE THE SPOT IN
CENTER FIELD AND HOLD IT DOWN.
HE DIDN'T JUST GO OUT THERE AND
WAS THROWING IN EVERYTHING
BECAUSE THEY NEEDED SOMEBODY FOR
SOME HE TOOK FULL ADVANTAGE OF
HIS OPPORTUNITY.
HE'S A PRETTY GOOD PLAYER, MAN.
STILL A COUPLE OF BASES, HE CAN
REALLY PLAY THE OUTFIELD.
THAT WAS THE PLUS THAT HE REALLY
BROUGHT TO THIS TEAM.
HIS ABILITY TO KNOW CENTER
FIELD.
HE HAS SEEN OVER FOUR TIMES,
HOMERED AGAINST THEM.
SIX TOTAL PLATE APPEARANCES.
HE'S WALKED A COUPLE OF TIMES AS
WELL.
AGAIN WANTS THAT ONE BACK.
LIKES TO WORK VERTICALLY COME
AND YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF HIGH,
FASTBALLS A TICK ABOVE THE ZONE.
IT IS TEMPTING.
LATROY: GOOD FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL
THAT HE USES.
A LOT OF SPIN RATE.
SCOTT: A LOT OF EXTENSION, TOO.
THAT JUST MISSED.
LATROY: THE BALL VERY CLOSE COME
AS YOU CAN SEE THROUGH THE BOX,
THEY ARE NON-STRIKES.
YOU WANT THOSE PITCHES.
THE UMPIRE WANTS TO GIVE THEM TO
YOU.
NOT FULL BY JEFFRESS' ABILITY TO
FRAME IT AND LOOK LIKE A STRIKE.
SCOTT: POPPED UP.
AND THAT IS CALLED BY JK IN
CENTER FOR THE SECOND OUT.
MAKE THAT THE FIRST OUT.
NOW ANOTHER OUTFIELDER WHO HAS
PERFORMED REALLY WELL THIS
SEASON, IN LIMITED TIME.
HE DID MISS ABOUT THREE MONTHS,
A COUPLE OF IL STINTS WITH THE
RIGHT HAMSTRING STRAIN.
BUT WHEN ADAM ENGEL HAS BEEN
PLAYING, HE'S BEEN DANGEROUS.
5-13, 17 HOME RUNS ON THE
SEASON.
HE HASN'T PLAYED A TON, BUT HIS
POWER HAS TICKED UP
SIGNIFICANTLY THIS YEAR.
LATROY: AND THE CHANCE TO SEE
HIM PLAY AGAINST MANY OTHER
TEAMS BESIDES THE TWINS, HE'S IS
ALWAYS DOING SOME DAMAGE.
SCOTT: RIGHT BACK TO OBER.
THEY TURN TO AN RETIRE THE SIDE.
PERFECTLY EXECUTED BY THE BIG
MAN ON THE MOUND.
LATROY: A GOOD PITCH.
HIT THE BALL OFF THE END OF THE
BAT, GOOD TURN.
SECOND INTO FIRST.
>> IT IS UP TO ADAM ENGEL.
BASE HIT, STILL AT FIRST WITH
TWO GONE.
>> REFS NEITHER BACK, AND IT IS
GONE.
THIS GAME IS TIED ON ONE SWING
FROM ADAM ENGEL.
1-1, ABREU HITS ONE DEEP.
LEFT CENTER.
ON!
--
GONE! INTO THE BULLPEN.
THEY GO BACK TO BACK.
ANDY WHITE SOX LEAD 3-2.
-- AND
>> A COUPLE OF GROUNDOUTS.
HE PUTS THEM UPFRONT.
HOME ON NUMBER SIX.
>> GOT A CUT A.
IT DID NOT LET IT GET INSIDE.
-- GOT A CUTTER.
DID NOT LET IT GET INSIDE.
WHAT A NICE SWING.
>> ALEXANDER WITH A GOOD CLOSER
FOR THE WHITE SOX.
THEY DECIDED NOT TO RESIGN HIM.
END TIME.
THE BULLPEN, NEARLY PERFECT.
>> BOTTOM TWO.
LATROY MAY NOT LIKE THIS, BUT I
AM ALL ABOUT IT.
IT IS AN ART FORM THESE DAYS.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
BEST IN THE BUSINESS.
I KNOW YOU DO NOT LIKE THESE,
LATROY, BUT I KNOW YOU ARE A FAN
OF THE YOUTUBE POLL QUESTIONS.
YOU WILL HAVE TO PICK SOMEBODY.
NOT IN THE LINEUP TODAY, BUT YOU
KNOW HE IS ENERGIZING THE
DUGOUT.
HE IS PART OF OUR LIST, THE MOST
ENTERTAINING BAT FLIP ARE IN
BASEBALL.
-- FLIPPER IN BASEBALL.
NO-BRAINER?
LATROY: NO-BRAINER.
HE STARTED IT BACK IN 2018, WHEN
IT WAS STILL KIND OF FROWNED
UPON.
HE DID NOT CARE.
I AM GOING TO CELEBRATE EVERY
VICTORY ON THE BASEBALL FIELD.
I AM NOT ONE OF THOSE OLDER GUYS
WHO SAY, I DO NOT LIKE IT.
THIS GAME IS HARD ENOUGH.
MY CAN'T YOU CELEBRATE YOUR
SMALL VICTORIES?
SCOTT: FANS LOVE IT.
LET'S BE REAL.
LATROY: GUYS GET TO SHOW THAT
CHARACTERS AND THEY GET TO BE
THEM.
WHATEVER YOU WANT, YOU GET THE
BAT FLIP AND EASIER TO DO ALL
YOUR LITTLE DANCES OR WHATEVER
YOU ARE DOING.
HE COULD TO DO ALL OF THAT, AND
IT IS GOOD FOR THE GAME.
IF IT IS GOOD FOR THE GAME, I
LOVE IT.
SCOTT: WE HAVE OUR LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY SECTION WITH YOUTUBE
CREATORS.
LET'S HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ON SOME
OF THE BEST THAT FLIPPERS -- BAT
FLIPPERS.
FOULS THAT ONE OFF.
SHE HAS LOOKED FILTHY OUT OF THE
PEN IN HIS SHORT TIME THERE,
THIS SEASON.
ANTICIPATING A SOLID START.
SO FAR, SO GOOD.
LATROY: HE HAS BEEN THROWING THE
BALL WELL.
A COMMENT ABOUT HIM GOING BACK
TO TRIPLE-A AND WORKING ON HIS
DELIVERY TO SMOOTH THINGS OUT.
SCOTT: ANGLE GOING BACK AND --
ENGAL GOING BACK AND CHASING IT.
TWO OUT IN THE SECOND INNING.
LATROY: HE GOT HIM A BREAKING
BALL.
HE HAD TO GO DOWN AND GET THAT
BALL OFF THE GROUND.
IN RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
HE WAS PLAYING TO THE OPPOSITE
FIELD.
WE TALK ABOUT -- IT IS HIS
ABILITY TO HIT.
HE FINDS A WAY TO GET HIS HITS.
I DO NOT CARE IF IT IS A LEFTY
OR A RIGHTY.
SCOTT: THEY MOVED HIM DOWN AT
THE IN THE LINEUP, A CLEANUP
HITTER TODAY BECAUSE THEY KNOW
WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION, IT WILL GET A GOOD AT
THAT.
THEY MET MAX UP THERE LATELY TO
HELP HIM TRY TO FIND THINGS.
THERE IS MIGUEL.
LATROY: HE HAS BEEN HOVERING
AROUND THAT POINT TO 10 MARK.
HE WAS BELOW THE MENDOZA LINE
FOR A WHILE.
THIS TEAM NEEDED HIM TO DO THAT
AFTER THE NELSON CRUZ TRADE.
SCOTT: CRUZ IS A BIG MENTOR FOR
HIM.
DOES NOT BUY ON THE 95.
A STRIKE.
GETTING SOME ANSWERS FROM OUR
YOUTUBE CREATORS.
ALWAYS IN THERE EVERY WEEK.
HE STARTED THE WAY THAT -- BAT
FLIPS ARE NOW.
BIG CUT AND A MISS ON 96 DOWN
THE MIDDLE.
LATROY: TALK ABOUT THAT SPREAD
BETWEEN HIS FASTBALL, 92 TO 98.
WHEN YOU SEE THAT, SCOTT, IT IS
MORE SO GUYS VAMPING IT UP.
THEY ARE VAMPING IT UP,
ESPECIALLY SCORING POSITION.
SCOTT: HE IS NOT STRETCHED OUT
YET.
IT IS A SLOW ROLLER, ON THE
RIGHT SIDE.
ONLY PLAYS TO FIRST.
HERNANDEZ MAKES IT.
LET'S BRING IN LAUREN GARDNER.
WE ARE GOING OVER THE BAT FLIPS.
I WANT YOUR ANSWER AND ALSO, A
LITTLE MORE, PLEASE.
LAUREN: I AM WITH LATROY.
HE INVENTED THE MODERN DAY BAT
FLIP.
FOR THE NEXT IN RATION, YOU HAD
TO GO WITH TATIS JR..
HE PLAYS THE GAME WITH SO MUCH
JOY.
YOU KNOW WHO DOES LOVE A BAT
FLIP?
TONY LA RUSSA.
HOW IN THE OLD SCHOOL APPROACH
COMBINED WITH THE NEW SCHOOL?
SHE EVEN ADMITTED THAT HE WAS
NOT FULLY ON BOARD WITH IT THIS
OFF-SEASON, BUT THEY MET UP IN
SPRING TRAINING AND HAD AMAZING
CONVERSATIONS.
THEY BOTH REALLY RESPECT ONE
ANOTHER.
THE COMMON BOND IS WINNING.
ALMOST A COMPETITIVE EDGE.
HE JUST WANTS TO SIT AROUND AND
TALK ABOUT IT.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS ODD COUPLE IS
THE PERFECT COMBINATION.
SCOTT: THE COMMON BOND IS THE
ESSENCE OF WINNING AND THE
MENTAL ASPECT OF IT.
THAT WAS A GOOD 10 MINUTES OF
OUR CONVERSATION THIS MORNING
WITH TONY.
LATROY: I ENJOYED THAT PART OF
THE CONVERSATION VERY MUCH.
HE COMPARED HIM TO MICHAEL
JORDAN WITH HIS BURNING DESIRE
TO WIN.
TONY BEING A LOT OLDER THAN MOST
OF THE MANAGERS AND TAKING ON
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF GETTING
THIS YOUNG TEAM TO THE NEXT
LEVEL, I'M SURE I'M NOT THE ONLY
PERSON WHO DID NOT KNOW HOW IT
WAS GOING TO GO.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND.
HE EVEN SAID, SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HE SEES, HE DOES NOT LIKE.
YOU CANNOT CONTROL EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO LET THEM BE FREE AND
ENJOY THEMSELVES.
SCOTT: LOOK, HE IS THE THIRD
OLDEST TO EVER MANAGE A GAME IN
MAJOR LEAGUE HISTORY.
HE TAKES THE CAKE.
97 YEARS OLD AND HE WAS -- 87
YEARS OLD AND HE WAS STILL
MANAGING BASEBALL.
DUSTY IS 72 YEARS OLD.
A SWING AND HE DID NOT GO.
LATROY: A GOOD, HARD SLIDER FROM
LOPEZ.
YOU CAN SEE THAT BALL, BREAKING
DOWN.
ALMOST GOT IT.
YOU SEE THE SLIDER AND IT IS NOT
GOING HORIZONTAL.
IT IS GOING STRAIGHT DOWN.
SCOTT: HE HELD UP AGAIN.
LATROY: YOU SEE HOW HIGH --
TEMPTING THAT HIGH FASTBALL IS.
HARD FOR THEM TO PLAYOFFS OF IT.
GOOD NUMBERS AGAINST LOPEZ.
TWO HOME RUNS.
HAD SOME VERY GOOD AT-BATS
AGAINST LOPEZ.
FACED HIM A LOT AS AN INDIVIDUAL
RIVAL.
SCOTT: OFF THAT ONE.
IT IS 3-2.
LATROY: LA PAZ HAS HAD A COUPLE
OF 3-2 COUNTS ALREADY.
HIS JOTT -- JAKE CAVE'S JOB IS
TO GET THAT GUY AND FROM THIRD
BASE.
-- A FROM THIRD BASE -- IN FROM
THIRD BASE.
GETTING A REAL FEEL, AN EYE TEST
.
SCOTT: IT LOOKS LIKE IT WILL NOT
LEAVE THE INFIELD.
GARCIA MAKES THE CATCH.
THAT WILL NOT GET THE JOB DONE.
LATROY: YOU SEE JAKE CAVE IS NOT
HAPPY WITH HIMSELF.
YOU HAVE TO GET THAT RUN IN.
AN EASIER OPPORTUNITY FOR A BASE
HIT.
YOU HAVE A SLIDER HOVERING OVER
THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT HE SHOULD
HAVE PUT A BETTER SWING ON THE
BALL.
SCOTT: NOW IT IS RYAN JEFFERS
TURN.
I FELT THAT HE WAS ALREADY AT
THE PLATE.
HE WAS CLOSE, I'M TELLING YOU.
LATROY: HE IS PROBABLY THE GUY
ON THE TEAM THAT DID NOT HAVE
TOO MANY AT-BATS.
A YOUNGER GUY, NOT TOO MANY
AT-BATS.
SCOTT: THE CATCHER TAKES 95.
IT IS LOPEZ TODAY AND LANCE LYNN
TOMORROW.
IN IOWA FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IT WILL BE AESTHETICALLY
PLEASING TO WATCH, I WILL TELL
YOU THAT.
LA PAZ TRYING TO CRACK THE
ROTATION TEMPORARILY.
THIS IS A TOUGH ROTATION TO BE A
PART OF BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN
STANDOUT PERFORMANCES,
CONSISTENCY AND DURABILITY.
LANCE LYNN IS IN THERE COME
EVERY FIVE DAYS.
HE WAS PITCHING LIKE A CY YOUNG
CANDIDATE AS WELL.
SWING AND MISS STUFF.
WE WILL TALK TO LUCAS VERY SOON,
AFTER THE BOTTOM OF THE THIRD.
LATROY: WHEN YOU HAVE A STRONG
ROTATION LIKE THAT AND A VERY
GOOD BULLPEN -- YOU HAVE KIMBREL
.
KOPECH HAS BEEN THROWING THE
BALL.
SCOTT: LOVE HAS LOOKS RHYME --
REVITALIZED.
WE HAVE NO SCORE IN THE SECOND
AT TARGET FIELD.
>> SO GOOD WITH THE GLOVE.
HE GOT HIM.
WHAT AN ARM.
HERNANDEZ WILL GLOVE IT.
A LONG THROW.
WHAT A PLAY.
IT IS A 4-3 GROUND OUT.
COME ON.
>> MIGHT AS WELL BE 9-3.
>> HE HAS GOT IT.
ENDING THE INNING AS HE PLAYED A
LOT OF RIGHT WITH A NICE CATCH
TO END THE INNING.
TO THE GLOVE SIDE.
>> PLAYING SOME SPARKLING
DEFENSE.
>> THAT IS GOLD GLOVE KIND OF
STUFF.
WHAT A PLAY BY 10 -- TIM.
>> GONE!
THAT IS AN ENORMOUS INSURANCE
HOME RUN.
HIS FIRST WHITE SOX HOME RUN.
>> THAT IS A TERRIFIC ADDITION
TO THIS PUBLIC -- THIS BALLCLUB.
>> LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE SHORTS.
WATCH AND CREATE VIDEOS ON
YOUTUBE.
MANY YOUTUBE CREATORS JOINING
US, ALONG WITH THE MLB CHANNEL,
THE WHITE SOX AND THE TWINS, ALL
ADDING TO THE UNIQUE VIEWING
EXPERIENCE.
YOU CAN VIEW THE LIVE COMMENTARY
ON YOUR COMPUTER AND MOBILE
DEVICE.
WE WILL KEEP AN EYE ON THE
DISCUSSION.
WE WILL CHAT WITH THEM AND I
WOULD LIKE TO NOW CALLED OUT
QUESTIONS FOR LUCAS GIOLITO, WHO
WILL JOIN US ABOUT 10 TO 15
MINUTES FROM NOW.
I WILL ASK THE QUESTIONS FROM
OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS TO LUCAS.
LATROY: DID YOU SAY 10 TO 15
MINUTES FROM NOW?
SCOTT: WHATEVER YOU WANT.
LATROY: HOW ABOUT SIX MINUTES
FROM NOW?
SCOTT: A SIX MINUTE INNING WOULD
BE IMPRESSIVE.
OTHER TREATS THAT WE HAD TO THE
YOUTUBE EXPERIENCE, MIKE DEPPE
-- MIC'ED UP PLAYERS.
THAT IS THE BEST PART OF THE
WEEK.
YOU DO NOT WANT TO HEAR
YOURSELF, YOU WANT TO HEAR THE
PLAYERS.
LATROY: I LIKE THAT.
THEY GET TO BE UNFILTERED.
SCOTT: I CALLED THE FUTURES GAME
AT THE ALL-STAR'S GAME.
YOU WERE BRINGING IT.
YOU COULD FIND THAT ON YOUTUBE,
I'M SURE.
SOME EXCELLENT SOUNDBITES FROM
LATROY HAWKINS.
LATROY: MY DAUGHTER TEXTED ME
DURING THE GAME SAYING, YOU NEED
TO WATCH YOUR MOUTH, YOUNG MAN.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE GOOD STUFF.
ORGANIC CONVERSATIONS.
HE HAS BEEN GOOD SO FAR.
TOUGH TO SQUARE UP THE HEATER.
PICKING UP VELOCITY.
A 12 ROUND SELECTION.
NOT HIGHLY TOUTED.
SHE IMMEDIATELY STARTED DEALING.
IT WAS ACROSS THREE LEVELS OF
THE MINOR LEAGUE WITH DAYTIME
NUMBERS.
I LIKE HIS PEACE.
THAT IS WHY I SAID 10 TO 15
MINUTES.
LATROY: HE WILL GET THE BALL AND
GET GOING.
SCOTT: ANOTHER SLOW ROLLER.
IT IS CLEANED UP EASILY.
HERE IS THAT GOODNESS YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR.
HE HAS THE MIC.
>> WHAT IS THE PLAN OVER THERE?
YOU TRYING TO THE -- DRAG THE
BALL RIGHT FIELD OR LEFT FIELD?
OK.
THAT IS WHAT I AM GOING TO TRY
TO DO, NEXT AT-BAT.
LATROY: YOU HEARD HIM.
HARD CONTACT FASTBALL DOWN THE
MIDDLE.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE GOOD STUFF
THERE.
IT IS AUGUST AND THEY ARE HAVING
A TOUGH YEAR.
JORGE HAS BEEN THEIR BEST HITTER
WITHOUT NELSON CRUZ IN THE FOLD.
HE LIKES IT.
OPPOSITE FIELD, BASE HIT.
HOW COOL WAS THAT CONVERSATION?
LATROY: MOST OF THE TIME WHEN
THE GUYS ARE TALKING ON THE
BENCH, THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT IS PARTICULAR TO
THE GAME.
TALKING TO ONE OF THE HOTTEST
HITTER IS IN THE LEAGUE.
HE TOLD HIM.
HE PUT THE BALL DOWN THE MIDDLE.
HE SAID, THAT IS WHAT I AM GOING
TO LOOK FOR AS WELL.
DID NOT PITCH TONIGHT ALL LAST
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
WE MISSED A COMPLETE SEASON.
IN 2019, HE DID NOT GET
DOUBLE-A.
SCOTT: HE IS AUDITIONING FOR A
ROTATION SPOT.
LATROY: THIS PUNT OF THE SEASON
WHEN YOU ARE IN A POSITION THAT
THE TWINS ARE, THEY ARE GOING
OUT THERE TO AUDITION, TRYING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF AN
OPPORTUNITY.
SCOTT: ZACK COLLINS TRYING TO
WIPE AWAY A SKID.
THERE HE IS, GETTING READY FOR
HIS CONVERSATION WITH YOU, ME
AND ALL THE YOUTUBE CREATORS,
WITH THEIR QUESTIONS.
LATROY: JUST WATCHING HIM AND
HOW HE WAS ABLE TO CHANGE HIS
ARM ANGLE, BACK TO WHERE IT WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I THINK HE WENT TO THE TUTELAGE
OF HIS HIGH SCHOOL COACH.
HE HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
INCREDIBLE, SINCE THE REVAMP OF
HIS ARM ANGLES.
HIS ABILITY TO THROW THOSE
PITCHES -- HIS CHANGEUP IS THE
BIGGEST SEPARATOR.
SCOTT: AND COLIN STRIKES OUT.
LATROY: ANOTHER FASTBALL.
SLIGHTLY ELEVATED.
TALKED ABOUT HIM BEING ABLE TO
USE THE FOUR SEAM FASTBALL.
HE THOUGHT THE BALL WAS GOING TO
BE -- WITH HIM HAVING A HIGH
SPIN RATE, THE BALL NEVER SEEMS
TO TAKE THAT DIP.
IT STAYS TRUE.
SCOTT: BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
ORDER WITH CESAR HERNANDEZ.
ONE OF THE SITES CHEMICAL --
CAME AGAINST -- I WATCHED HIM
LAST START ON FRIDAY AGAINST
HOUSTON.
SHE WAS PRODUCING SOME SWING AND
MISS WITH THE FASTBALL.
FIRST TO THIRD.
IN THERE IS GARCIA.
LATROY: THAT WAS A CHANGEUP.
NOT A BAD PITCH.
STAYING BACK ON THE BALL AND
FALLING BACK TO THE BARREL.
ENOUGH OF IT TO PUNCH THAT BALL
INTO CENTER FIELD.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE NEXT STEP IN
THE PROGRESSION.
HE TOLD US, JUST LEARNING HOW TO
SPIN THE BASEBALL A LITTLE BIT
BETTER.
TIGHTENING THEM UP BECAUSE THE
FASTBALL HAS PLAYED SO WELL.
LATROY: THEY LASTED TWO OUTS.
THEY FIND A WAY TO GET THAT
RUNNER FROM THIRD BASE, A.
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
CHANGEUP NOT BEING ONE OF HIS
BETTER PITCHES.
HIS LAST START, HE HAD SOME
TROUBLE WITH IT, LEAVING IT
ELEVATED.
IF HE COULD FIND A WAY TO GET
THAT DOWN, IT COULD BE A USABLE
PITCH FOR HIM.
SCOTT: 94, UP AND IN.
TWO FOR 38.
THAT IS SURPRISING.
I THINK THAT NUMBER WILL START
TO TURN AROUND.
LATROY: HE IS ALWAYS A THREAT.
13 HOME RUNS SOFI.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THE TWINS GAME
PLAN, HE HAS TO TIE THOSE HANDS
UP.
TRY TO STAY AWAY FROM THE MIDDLE
OF THE PLATE.
GET THE BALL AS CLOSE TO THEM AS
POSSIBLE.
SCOTT: GOT HIM.
FISHING FOR SOME HIGH CHEESE.
LUCAS GIOLITO WILL JOIN US IN
JUST A MOMENT.
>> A HIGH FLY LEFT FIELD OFF THE
BAT.
HE TOUCHED OFF A THREE RUN HOME
RUN WITH TWO OUT.
GARVER PUTS THE TWINS OUT FRONT.
>> DEEP DOWN THE LINE.
THAT BALL WILL BE FAIR AND A
HOME RUN.
A THREE RUN NINTH INNING SHOT
DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
>> IN THE FIELD, A LONG RUN.
HE MAKES THE CATCH.
A DIVING CATCH.
A HIGH FLY TO RIGHT FIELD.
WAY BACK AND GONE.
THE TWINS BREAK IT OPEN.
19 AND 20 TODAY.
NUMBER 20 IS A BIG ONE.
BAREHANDED.
THROWN OUT.
WHAT A PLAY.
>> IT WAS DO OR DIE.
HE CAME IN CHARGING WITH A BIG
RIGHT HAND AND HE THREW A BULLET
RIGHT ON THE MONEY.
WHAT A TERRIFIC PLAY.
SCOTT: LAST OF THE THIRD, WHITE
SOX AND TWINS.
NO SCORE YET.
NICE PITCHING FROM LOPEZ.
WE ENTERED OUR FIRST POLL
QUESTION TODAY, THE MOST
ENTERTAINING BAT FLIPPER IN
BASEBALL.
LOOK AT FERNANDO TATIS JR. THIS
THING.
THE FANS WEIGHED IN HEAVILY.
ANDERSON PICKS UP 44 -- 34%.
THOSE TWO RECEIVING THE MOST
DOES.
LET'S GET THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION FROM OUR FRIEND, LUCAS
GIOLITO, WHO JOINS US FOR THIS
INNING.
LUCAS, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
HELP US OUT HERE.
>> I AM GOOD.
JUST CHILLING TODAY.
SCOTT: GOOD MORNING.
HOW MUCH COFFEE?
>> I HAD A COUPLE COFFEE
BEVERAGES THIS MORNING.
LATROY: I PREFER COLD COFFEE.
>> I PREFER COLD COFFEE.
SCOTT: HOPEFULLY A HOT WAFFLE.
>> YES.
REYNALDO LOPEZ GETTING THE SPOT
TODAY.
BEFORE WE GET INTO EVERYTHING
ELSE, WE NEED YOUR ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION WE ASKED EARLIER.
THE MOST ENTERTAINING BAT FLIPP
ER.
TELL BILLY HAMILTON HELLO.
>> WE GOT THE CLOWN CORNER OVER
HERE.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE AT.
I DO NOT USUALLY HANG OUT ON THE
SIDE TOO MUCH.
BUT YOU HAD ME OVER HERE FOR THE
INTERVIEW, SO THEY MIGHT BE
DOING STUFF.
I DO NOT KNOW IF THE CAMERA CAN
PICK HIM UP.
I DO NOT CARE WHAT THE POLLS
SAYS.
HE HAS DONE IT ALL.
LATROY: THAT IS WHAT I SAID.
HE ORIGINALLY STARTED IT AND
MADE IT COOL AGAIN.
>> NO DISRESPECT TO TATIS JR..
SUPER EXCITING PLAYER, BUT I
THINK TIMMY IS THE KING OF THE
BAT FLIP.
I DO NOT KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
LAST WALKOFF HOME RUN.
HE TOSSED IT 25 FEET IN THE AIR.
LATROY: IF YOU GET A WALKOFF,
YOU DO WHATEVER YOUR BODY TELLS
YOU TO DO.
SCOTT: IF IT IS GOING THAT HIGH,
IT IS COMING DOWN.
LUCAS GIOLITO IS WITH US.
NOW A CHECK OVER TO FIRST.
HOW DO YOU THINK LOPEZ LOOKS
TODAY.
HE HAS PUT TOGETHER A GOOD
SEASON SINCE HE HAS BEEN UP HERE
.
>> WE CAME UP TOGETHER IN THE
NATIONALS ORGANIZATION.
THESE GUYS.
WE ARE GOOD.
WE CAME UP TOGETHER, SAME LEVEL,
ALL THE WAY FROM ROOKIE BALL,
DOUBLE-A, AND HE WAS ALWAYS
BETTER THAN ME, LIKE SUPER NASTY
STUFF, UP TO 100.
HE HAD A GOOD CURVEBALL AND
CHANGEUP.
A COUPLE HARDSHIPS, STUFF THAT
WE ALL GO THROUGH AS BASEBALL
PLAYERS.
THIS YEAR, HE MADE A COUPLE
MECHANICAL ADJUSTMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING AROUND SPRING TRAINING
TIME.
A LITTLE BIT OF AN ADJUSTMENT
PERIOD WITH THOSE.
HE HAS BEEN FANTASTIC, SINCE
GETTING CALLED UP.
I SEE HIM AS A MAN ON A MISSION,
PROVING HOW GOOD OF A PLAYER HE
IS.
HE IS COMMANDING THE BALL.
A GOOD ONE SOPHIA.
SCOTT: HE HAS GIVEN UP -- A GOOD
ONE SO FAR.
SCOTT: HE HAS GIVEN UP JUST ONE
HIT SO FAR.
LUCAS COME HOW STRANGE WAS IT TO
THROW A NO-HITTER WITH NO CROWD
BEHIND YOU?
WHEN DID YOU REALIZE WHAT YOU
WERE DOING?
HOW DID YOU KEEP YOURSELF
LOCKED-IN?
>> IT WAS JUST ONE OF THOSE --
THERE WE GO.
SCOTT: ONE AWAY.
>> IT WAS ONE OF THOSE SPECIAL
NIGHTS, AS AN ATHLETE, THAT
COMES EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE,
WHERE IT WAS LIKE I HAD THAT
PEAK PERFORMANCE FROM THE GET
GO.
I DID EVERYTHING THAT I DID TO
NOT LET GO OF THAT.
I WAS ABLE TO HAVE A GREAT
NIGHT.
IT IS NOT EVER 100% THAT THE
PITCHER DID THIS THING.
IT WAS A SPECIAL NIGHT.
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE WHITE
SOX HOME KYLE DAVIES THAT IS THE
ONE THING ABOUT IT THAT GETS ME.
WE DID DO IT IN FRONT OF AN
EMPTY STADIUM.
I FELT A LOT OF LOVE FROM OUR
FANS AFTERWARDS.
LATROY: HE SAID IT DID NOT
MATTER BECAUSE YOU WERE
LOCKED-IN.
>> 2020 WAS A LITTLE WEIRD AT
THE BEGINNING FOR ALL OF US.
JUST FINDING OTHER WAYS TO GET
THAT ADRENALINE, EVERYBODY IS
DIFFERENT.
FOR ME, I APPRECIATE A NICE,
PACKED STADIUM.
BY THAT POINT, WE WERE ALL
PRETTY USED TO IT.
SCOTT: THIS IS MAX KEPLER.
LOPEZ DEALS AND THAT IS A BIT
DOWN.
NEXT QUESTION, LUCAS, WHEN ON
THE ROAD, WHERE IS YOUR FAVORITE
PLACE TO PITCH?
LATROY: MINNESOTA?
>> I DO LIKE PITCHING HERE.
IT IS A NICE BALLPARK.
I LIKE TO PITCH INSIDE.
THE DOME STADIUMS -- ONE FOR
SURE IS HOUSTON.
I LIKE THE VIBE.
I LIKE THE AIR CONDITIONING AND
TAMPA AS WELL.
NOT SO MUCH FOR THE STADIUM BUT
HAVING THAT CLOSE SPACE.
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THE WIND OR THE SUN.
SCOTT: HITTERS OFTEN DO NOT LIKE
TO HIT AROUND THERE.
KAPLER THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND IT
IS A STRIKE.
LATROY: A VERY GOOD PITCH FROM
LOPEZ.
A GOOD SLIDER.
I GOT IT ON THE LINE.
GONZALEZ DID A GOOD JOB ON THAT
PITCH.
CALLING A STRIKE A STRIKE.
COMING FROM A PITCHER, LUCAS.
WE COULD PROBABLY FIND SOME MORE
HEADSETS.
>> THEY ARE WONDERING IF YOU
WANT TO GET ON HERE.
HE KEEPS LOOKING AT ME.
LATROY: HE LOOKS BORING.
SCOTT: FIRST A CHECK.
THAT IS THE BEST.
SCOTT: --
>> THAT IS THE BEST.
SCOTT: HOW GOOD DOES IT FEEL?
GOT HIM EASY.
THAT IS THE BEST MOTIVATION.
>> WE LOVE TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER
ON THE SOUTH SIDE.
LATROY: THE UMPIRES JUST REFUSE
TO CALL THE BOW.
MANY HAVE THAT KNEE-JERK
REACTION.
I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT YOU ARE
PICKING GUYS OFF.
>> I FOUND A CERTAIN THING THAT
I CAN DO THAT HELPS.
LATROY: I UNDERSTAND.
SCOTT: TELL US AFTER YOUR
PLAYING DAYS.
WE UNDERSTAND.
HE WAS SO FAR.
NOT EVEN CLOSE AT FIRST BASE.
I REMEMBER THE LIKES OF KEN
KAISER AND MERIWETHER.
SCOTT: I LOVE A GOOD PICKOFFS.
WHO DOES IT?
0-1, SOPHIA TODAY.
MLB'S CHANNEL IS ASKING A
QUESTION.
ARE YOU GOING TO THE CORN
TOMORROW?
>> I AM PUMPED TO NOT BE
PITCHING IN IT BECAUSE I WILL BE
THERE AS A FAN.
I LIKE THE MOVIE, BUT I HAVE NOT
SEEN IT IN A WHILE.
I DO NOT KNOW IF KEVIN COSTNER
IS GOING TO BE THERE.
IF HE IS, IT WOULD BE COOL TO
MEET HIM.
I SAW FISHERS OF THE CORN MAZE.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
SOME GUYS TRYING TO DO THE CORN
MAZE.
SCOTT: I THINK IT IS SHAPED LIKE
THE MLB LOGO.
IF THAT HELPS YOU AT ALL, DURING
HERE EXCURSION.
I WANT YOU TO WIN.
LATROY: DO NOT RUN AGAINST BILLY
HAMILTON.
HE MIGHT LOSE.
>> JUST MISSED TO RECORD.
--
SCOTT: JUST MISSED.
THE WORLD IS WATCHING ON
YOUTUBE.
THAT BALLPARK LOOKS INSANE.
I HEARD THAT THE DIMENSIONS ARE
PRETTY TIGHT.
MAYBE NOT THE WORST THING.
YOU ARE GREAT WITH HOME RUN
PREVENTION, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I
AM SAYING.
>> I AM NOT GREAT WITH HOME RUN
PREVENTION.
HOPEFULLY WE GET A WIN, BUT I
HAVE ENJOYED THE EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE BEEN JEALOUS OF THE OTHER
TEAMS.
THEY GO OUT TO DO WORLD SERIES
GAMES, SO THIS SHOULD BE FUN.
SCOTT: WE DID A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING AND HE RIGHT OUT OF
THE DANGER ZONE.
GOOD TO TALK TO YOU.
LUCAS GIOLITO HANGING OUT WITH
US.
LOPEZ AVOIDED ANY DAMAGE.
>> MAKE FUN OF ME AND FRONT OF
MY BALLCLUB?
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> FERNANDO CLEARED EVERYBODY
OUT OF THE WAY.
I WILL TAKE CARE OF THIS, AND HE
DID.
>> EVERYBODY SCATTERS APART.
>> LAUNCHES ONE TO DEEP CENTER
FIELD.
ON THE BOARD WITH HIS FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE HOMER.
>> CHECK IT OUT.
HE IS READING.
LET'S SEE HOW LONG THEY STICK
WITH IT.
THIS IS A LONG SILENT TREATMENT.
USUALLY THEY ARE CELEBRATING BY
NOW.
>> ICE I'M TRYING TO GET CLOSE.
I REALIZED I WAS GOING OVER.
♪
[SLOW-MO SCREAM]
SCOTT: WE CLIMB INTO THE FOURTH
INNING IN MINNEAPOLIS.
HAVE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
NOTABLE TRADE DEADLINE
ACQUISITIONS.
IT WAS WILD.
NELSON CRUZ LEAVES THE TWINS TO
GO TO THE RAYS.
ANTHONY RIZZO GOING TO THE
YANKEES.
CRAIG KIMBREL SHOWS UP ACROSS
TOWN.
REVIEW SHOCKED AT THAT ONE MORE
THAN THE REST?
LATROY: IT KIND OF SHOCKED ME
THAT THEY PULLED THAT OFF.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GO WITH
CRAIG KIMBREL.
SCOTT: FOR THE BIGGEST IMPACT?
LATROY: YES.
SCOTT: JAKE CAVE RUNNING IT DOWN
FOR THE FIRST OUT.
DO YOU THINK THAT WILL BE THE
DEAL COME PLAYOFF TIME?
LATROY: YES.
HE JUST SOLIDIFIES A SPOT IN
THAT BULLPEN, WHERE THEY
PROBABLY HAD A LITTLE ISSUE.
TO ADD ANOTHER CLOSER.
TWO ALL-STAR CLOSERS IN THE
BULLPEN.
THEY HAVE HENDRICKS AND KIMBREL.
THEIR STARTERS ARE GOING SIX
INNINGS APIECE, SOMETIMES MORE.
THEY HAVE TO COVER FOR MAYBE
THREE OUTS?
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THE TEAM GOES
WHERE THE PITCHING GOES.
SCOTT: THEY ARE BUILT FOR
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
BY THE WAY, THAT PULL QUESTION
IS LIVE -- POLL QUESTION IS
LIVE.
LATROY: KOPECH.
KOPECH IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHO
WAS A STARTER.
HE HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD, COMING
OUT OF THE BULLPEN AT 90 MIGHT
-- AT 98 MILE-PER-HOUR SINKER
THAT HE THROWS.
SCOTT: PRETTY GOOD FROM THE LEFT
SIDE.
IT BRINGS SOME BIG STUFF.
HE MENEZ UP THE MIDDLE.
A SOLID SNACK.
A BASE HIT, HIS SECOND OF THE
DAY.
YOU MENTIONED KOPECH.
A NEW MONIKER FOR THIS TRIO AT
THE BACK END OF THE BULLPEN, THE
PONYTAILED GANG.
IT IS EASY TO SEE WHY THEY ARE
CALLED THAT.
YOU CAN SEE THE PONYTAIL ACTION
ON THE BACKEND FOR THEM.
97, 97 -- THEY ARE STRIKEOUT
MACHINES.
ADD IT ALL UP AND YOU ARE IN
TROUBLE IF YOU FACE THE WHITE
SOX IN OCTOBER.
LATROY: THE THREE-HEADED
MONSTER, THE THREE HEADED GANG
COMING AT YOU.
SCOTT: THE PONYTAIL DOES NOT
HOLD BACK THE VELOCITY.
CONFIRMED.
ONE OUT IN THE FOURTH.
A STRIKE.
THAT IS WHERE HE LIKES TO WORK.
LATROY: TWO OF THOSE HITS BY
JIMENEZ.
SCOTT: HE HAS BEEN HANGING OUT
IN THE 60 RANGE.
I THINK THEY WILL LET HIM GO UP
TO THE 80 RANGE, IF THEY ARE
STRESS-FREE, BUT WE WILL SEE.
THERE IS NO HARD LIMIT.
THEY WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS WITH
HIM BECAUSE HE HAS NOT PITCHED
MUCH LAST FEW SEASONS.
LAST YEAR -- HE IS NOT A BIG
LEAGUER AND WAS NOT AT THE
ALTERNATE SITE, SAID HE WAS NOT
PITCHING IN COMPETITIVE ACTION.
LATROY: HE LOST SOME VALUABLE
TIME.
BEING ABLE TO MAKE IT TO THE BIG
LEAGUES -- HE HAS NEVER THROWN
MORE THAN 80 INNINGS IN A
SEASON.
SCOTT: A NICE CATCH AND
PIROUETTE.
GOODWIN BEATS OUT THE THROW.
LATROY: LOOK AT THE TWINS,
SHIFTED RIGHT THERE.
KIND OF THREW THAT BALL TO THE
GLOVE SIDE.
HE HAD TO GATHER HIMSELF.
WHEN YOU PLAN A SHIFT, GUYS HAVE
TAKEN BALLS FROM DIFFERENT
ANGLES AND HAVE A LOT MORE
GROUND TO COVER.
IT'S THE DEFENSE OUT A LITTLE
BIT.
SCOTT: THAT IS A DOUBLE PLAY ON
ABOUT HALF THE BATTERIES IN THE
LEAGUE.
ADAM ENGEL ON THE GROUND.
THERE IT IS.
HE MAKES THE PLAY AND THE INNING
IS OVER.
BARELY -- BOTH PITCHERS MAKING A
NAME FOR THEMSELVES SO FAR THIS
AFTERNOON.
IN THE FOURTH, STILL NOTHING.
>> AS LONG AS LUCAS GIOLITO CAN
REMEMBER.
>> I HAVE ALWAYS HAD ANIMALS IN
THE HOUSE.
>> I HAD FISH, A BEARDED DRAGON,
AT ONE POINT --
>> HIS WIFE WILL SOON BE
FINISHING UP THAT SCHOOL.
-- VET SCHOOL.
>> IT HAS BEEN A GREAT
EXPERIENCE.
>> A STUDENT RUN NONPROFIT HAS
BEEN RESCUING KITTENS SINCE
1980.
>> HERE HE IS.
THIS IS LIONEL.
>> LIONEL IS ONE OF THEIR
FOSTERS.
THEY ALSO HAVE A DOG WHO HAS
BECOME A PRETTY GOOD TRAVELER.
GIOLITO IS SELLING SHIRTS TO
RAISE MONEY FOR THE ORPHAN
KITTEN PROJECT.
>> I HAVE A PROGRAM THAT IS
GROWING NOW.
MY GOING TO DO SOMETHING WITH
THIS OR AM I GOING TO PLAY
BASEBALL, GET A BUNCH OF MONEY
AND DISAPPEAR?
THAT IS NOT REALLY WHAT I AM
INTERESTED IN.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE FOURTH WITH
NO SCORE IN MINNEAPOLIS.
TIME FOR OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
WILL FOCUS ON A YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATOR IN OUR LIVE COMMENTARY
SECTION.
TODAY WE FOCUS ON ANDY RULLO.
OVER 40,000 SUBSCRIBERS AND OVER
2 MILLION VIEWS.
HIS YOUTUBE CAREER COME,
BEGINNING VIDEOS.
HE LOVES THE MARINERS AND HE IS
HANGING OUT WITH US IN THE LIVE
CHAT.
SAY HELLO TO US AT SOME POINT
AND WE WILL INCLUDE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION DURING THE BROADCAST.
LOPEZ WAS EXCELLENT DURING HIS
TIME ON THE MOUND.
22 YEARS OLD, E.R.A., SOUTH OF
THREE ON THE SEASON.
HE CAN DIAL IT UP.
REMEMBER HIS DEBUT LAST YEAR.
WHAT A 1.5 ON THE RADAR GUN.
LATROY: THAT FASTBALL COULD BE
-- HE THROWS A SLIDER, 81 TO 91
MILES PER HOUR.
BIG, SWEEPING SLIDER, THROWING
IT HARDER LATELY THAN HE FIRST
DID WHEN HE CAME INTO THE LEAGUE
LAST YEAR.
A GOOD MIX.
SCOTT: HE HAS MISSED ON HIS
FIRST THREE.
LATROY: TENNESSEE IS IN WHAT
CONFERENCE?
SEC?
HE WENT FROM SEC TO THE BIG
LEAGUES.
THE BIG LEAGUES OF COLLEGE
SPORTS AND PROFESSIONAL
BASEBALL.
I LOVE IT.
SCOTT: CIRCLING AROUND AND
FINDING IT.
ONE AWAY.
AFTER POLANCO IS RETIRED, --
THIS MAY NOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM.
IT MAY NOT BE DISSEMINATED
WITHOUT EXPRESS, WRITTEN
CONSENT.
A DOUBLE BACK IN THE SECOND.
95 DOWN BROADWAY SCOTT: THE
CHANGEUP -- DOWN BROADWAY.
IT IS ABSURD.
LATROY: LEFT-HANDED HITTERS LOVE
TO USE THE SLIDER MAKES.
HE IS GOING TO GO FOR THE PUNCH
OUT MOST TIMES WITH THE SLIDER.
SCOTT: AS MUCH AS I WAS BUMMED
THAT WE WERE NOT GETTING THE
OTHER START, THIS BULLPEN CAN
BRING IT.
I'M SURE YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
LATROY: THE GOOD THING IS WE ARE
GOING TO SEE THEIR BULLPEN OUT
THERE TODAY.
YOU WILL GET A CHANCE TO SEE AT
LEAST FOUR OF THEIR BULLPEN
ARMS.
SCOTT: LAST FOUR GAMES HAVE GONE
WELL.
THERE IS ANOTHER.
THAT BRINGS US TO MIGUEL, HE IS
MIC'ED UP TODAY.
>> YOU NEVER WATCH MY MOVES?
-- MY MOVIE?
MY DOCUMENTARY.
WES YOU GOT A MOVIE?
-- >> YOU GOT A MOVIE?
>> THEY CALL IT MR. WILSON.
SCOTT: FIRST BASE CONVERSATIONS
ARE EPIC, ESPECIALLY WITH THAT
GUY.
HE HAS THE LINES.
THAT IS TRUE BY THE WAY.
THERE IS A DOCUMENTARY.
WHEN HE WAS 16.
I THINK THEY ARE PUTTING
TOGETHER A SEQUEL TO THAT.
I THINK SO.
LATROY: I WILL HAVE TO DOUBLE
CHECK THAT.
SCOTT: A LOT HAS CHANGED SINCE
HE WAS 16.
HE IS GOOD IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERA.
AN OUTCOME PLAYER.
LATROY: HE HAS TAKEN A LOT MORE
WALKS THIS PAST YEAR, BUT HE
LOVES TO SWING AT THAT HIGH
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: NO GO.
IT IS 1-2.
THIS IS SINCE THE 1900S.
THE OUTCOME PERCENTAGE.
THE CHANCES ARE ONE OF THOSE IS
HAPPENING.
LATROY: RUSSELL BRANYAN.
HE COULD HIT THE BALL.
A BIG, STRONG GUY.
CHRIS CARTER.
SCOTT: I'M SURE YOU'VE FACED THE
NUMBER TWO ON THAT LIST AS WELL.
LATROY: MIGHT HAVE FACED A GUY
AT THE HEAD OF THAT LIST AS
WELL.
SCOTT: HE WANTED THAT ONE.
LATROY: THE CHANGEUP GOING UP
THEY.
IT IS LIKE SOME GUYS FASTBALL.
NOT A BAD PITCH, JUST NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO GET A SWING FROM
MIGUEL.
SCOTT: STATCAST LIKED IT.
HE PULLS IT UP ON HIS NEXT
PITCH.
TO TO BE OUTS.
THE WHITE SOX BULLPEN TAKING
OVER IN THE FOURTH.
STILL SCORELESS.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THIS ONE IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> STRENGTH THREE.
THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> THAT WAS -- STRENGTH THREE.
-- STRIKE THREE.
THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: NEW THIS SEASON IN THE
GAME OF THE WEEK, LIVE ON
YOUTUBE SERIES.
IT IS THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
MOBILE DEVICE, COMPUTER -- WHO
WILL RECEIVE THE TROPHY?
IT HELPS US DECIDE WHO WE ARE
TALKING TO, POSTGAME.
PULLING OPTIONS LATER IN THE
SHOW.
THE TRADE DEADLINE ACQUISITION.
THE BIGGEST IMPACT THIS SEASON.
ANTHONY RIZZO IN SECOND PLACE
WITH 30% OF THE VOTE.
WE --
LATROY: WE SAW A FIST BUMP.
SCOTT: HE HELPED TO INFLUENCE
THE CROWD.
GOOD JOB.
PICKING UP TWO QUICK STRIKES.
LET'S SEND IT DOWN TO LAUREN.
LAUREN: OF COURSE LATROY IS A
INFLUENCER.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
HE FOUND OUT HE WAS PART OF IT
WHEN HE WAS EATING BREAKFAST
OVER THERE IN JAPAN.
HE HAS HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HE
HAS DONE IN THE PAST, HE COULD
BE A PART OF THIS TWINS REBUILD.
HIS LAST FULL SEASON, HE WAS
9-4.
IF THIS TELLS YOU ANYTHING, HIS
NICKNAME IS ACE.
SCOTT: IT DOES NOT GET BETTER
THAN ACE.
YOU ARE OUT THERE IN JAPAN
TRYING TO WIN A MEDAL.
HOLD UP.
LET ME PICK UP A MEDAL FIRST.
THE TWINS ARE EXCITED TO HAVE
HIM.
HOLDING BACK ON THE BUNT IS
GARCIA.
NOT AN ERROR.
LATROY: A PICKUP FOR NELSON
CRUZ.
I WAS HERE WHEN NELSON WAS
TRADED.
HAVING JOANNE, LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS AND LOOKING AT HIS PITCH
USAGE, REALLY GOOD.
HE IS A SECOND BASEMAN.
SCOTT: ONE HUNDRED MATT -- 105
MILES PER HOUR OFF THE BAT.
LATROY: WHAT THEY LIGHT THE MOST
WAS HIS FASTBALL.
THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW QUICKLY
THE BALL GETS ON YOU.
IT LOOKS EVEN MORE LIVELY THAN
THAT.
SCOTT: SIMMONS HAS IT.
FIRING IT BACK INTO THE INFIELD.
LATROY: A PERFECT THROW.
SECOND BASE.
HE IS SUCH AN INSTINCTUAL
PRAYER.
HIS DEFENSE GETS OVER.
HE WAS BEHIND SECOND BASE.
HE CAME AROUND TO MAKE THE PLAY.
HE HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DID NOT TAGGED FIRST BASE.
BASEBALL I.Q. IS OFF THE CHARTS.
HE HAD A PLAY AT SECOND BASE.
OHTANI WAS AT SECOND BASE.
OHTANI LEAPT OFF OF SECOND BASE
AND HE THREW THE BALL TO GET
SHOHEI BACK.
SHE WAS RUNNING FROM HIS
POSITION TO THE BAG.
IT WAS COMING FROM POLANCO.
HE COMPLETELY MISSED IT.
SCOTT: SOMETIMES YOU ARE TOO
FANCY.
PERFECT BEHIND THE BACK, BUT YOU
ARE NOT READY FOR IT.
HE IS LEVEL.
HE CAME UP WITH THE BASEBALL.
STEPPING AWAY FROM IT
JUST-IN-TIME.
THEY ARE STILL TALKING ABOUT IT.
THAT IS WHAT IMPRESSED ME AS
WELL.
YOU MAKE THE CATCH AND AVOID THE
COLLISION, FOR THE MOST PART.
IN HIS BRAIN, HE IS LIKE, I HAVE
TO MAKE SURE I GET IT TO FIRST
BASE.
LATROY: WHEN I THINK OF SOME OF
THE GREATEST SHORTSTOPS OF MY
TIME -- HE ALWAYS GOT THE BAR --
HE ALWAYS GOT THE BALL THERE.
HIS INTERNAL CLOCK WAS ALWAYS
RIGHT.
SCOTT: HE'S LIKE, MOVE OUT OF
THE WAY.
I HAVE TO THROW IT TO SECOND.
2-1 ON COLLINS.
NOW 3-1.
LATROY: HE HAS DONE A GREAT JOB
OF NOT WALKING GUYS.
GETTING TOWARDS THE BOTTOM OF
THE LINEUP.
THE GUYS ON BASE.
REALLY STARTING TO COME UP.
SCOTT: WE SHOWED YOU OUTS ABOVE
AVERAGE.
STATCAST HELPS US OUT.
HELPING TO DEFINE YOUR OFFENSIVE
DEFICIENCY.
SIMMONS IS TOP FIVE ON THE LIST.
OFFENSIVE RUNS SAVED IS A
POPULAR STAT.
HE IS COMPETITIVE WITH THAT
STAT.
IT REALLY HELPS TO SUM UP THE
SEASON.
THE BALL FOUR.
OK.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
TAKE US BACK TO WHAT SIMMONS
JUST DID.
LOOK AT HIM GO.
LATROY: SEE WHERE HE STARTED AT.
A MUCH EASIER PLAY FOR THE
SHORTSTOP.
HE STARTED RIGHT BEHIND SECOND
BASE AND CALLED THAT BALL BEHIND
THIRD BASE, IN FOUL TERRITORY.
THIS IS THE FUNNIEST THING, TO
SEE WES JOHNSON, WHO IS
VERTICALLY CHALLENGED GUY, STANO
BAILEY OBER ON THE MOUND.
BAILEY TOLD ME, WHEN WES COMES
OUT TO TALK TO HIM, HE TRIES TO
WALK TO THE BACK OF THE MOUND SO
HE CAN SEE HIM EYE TO EYE.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS DOING,
STANDING ON THE BACK NOW.
SCOTT: THAT IS RESPECT.
THAT IS REALLY COOL.
GOOGLE IS HELPING TO POWER MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL WITH STATCAST TO
TAKE YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME
THAN EVER BEFORE.
THE OFFICIAL CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THANK YOU FOR HELPING US OUT
WITH THAT LAST PLAY.
THANK YOU, BAILEY OBER, FOR
SHOWING RESPECT TO YOUR COACH AS
A ROOKIE.
I'M SURE HE APPRECIATES THAT.
LATROY: THIRD TIME AROUND THE
LINEUP FOR BAILEY OBER.
SEE IF HE CAN GET A FEW MORE
OUTS.
SCOTT: IT IS A GOOD TEST FOR
HIM.
CESAR HERNANDEZ SINGLE THE LAST
TIME UP, STRUCK OUT THE FIRST
TIME UP.
I MENTIONED OBER LOOK PRETTY
GOOD EYE-TEST WISE AGAINST THE
ASTROS.
HE GAVE UP TWO HOME RUNS BUT I
CAN SAY WITH CONFIDENCE BOTH
WERE MINUTE MAID PARK SHOTS,
JUST OVER THE WALL.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE LEFT THE
YARD HERE.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN MUCH LOUD
CONTACT FROM A TEAM THAT DOES
PLENTY OF IT.
LATROY: WHAT WAS THE PROBABILITY
OF THOSE BALLS BEING OUT IN
OTHER BALLPARKS?
SCOTT: VERY LOW.
LATROY: I LOVE THAT STATCAST, BY
THE WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: YOU CAN DO AN OVERLAY OF
THE BALLPARKS TO SEE IF IT WOULD
HAVE LEFT THE YARD AND OTHER
LOCATIONS.
THAT IS WHAT I DID.
HE WAS OK.
WHERE WAS THAT?
LATROY: THAT WAS NOT A STRIKE, A
LITTLE ELEVATED.
OTHER ONES WERE CLOSER.
YOU CAN SEE THE WHITE SOX DUGOUT
CHIRPING A LITTLE BIT TOO MANY
GONZALES.
SCOTT: DO YOU GO RIGHT BACK OUT
THERE?
LATROY: I WOULD.
HE IS GIVING THAT PITCH.
YOU MAY AS WELL GO WHERE HE IS
GETTING THE STRIKES.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BETTER
CHANGEUPS OBER HAS THROWN
, AT THE KNEES, NOT ELEVATED
LIKE THE PREVIOUS AT THAT -- AT
BAT WITH CAESAR HERNANDEZ.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET THAT BALL TO
CENTER FIELD.
NOTHING HE COULD DO WITHOUT BALL
BUT ROLL OVER AND FOUL IT OFF.
SCOTT: COLLINS ON FIRST, LAMB ON
SECOND.
BALL AND TWO STRIKES ON LEADOFF
MAN CAESAR HERNANDEZ. GOT HIM.
FIFTH STRIKEOUT THIS AFTERNOON
FOR BAILEY OBER.
LATROY: A COUPLE OF FASTBALLS,
ELEVATED FOR THE STRIKEOUT.
SCOTT: LG, WHAT ELSE CAN YOU
TELL US ABOUT THIS GENTLEMAN ON
THE MOUND TODAY?
LAUREN: HE CAN TELL YOU WHAT THE
WEATHER IS LIKE OUT THERE.
HE WAS KNOWN AS A SOFT TOSS OR
BEFORE HE WORKED ON HIS
MECHANICS IN THE OFF-SEASON.
HE ADDED A FEW TICKS TO HIS
VELO.
WE TALKED TO ROCCO BALDELLI
ABOUT IT, DID YOU DO ANYTHING
SPECIFICALLY TO INCREASE HIS
VELO?
HE SAID JUST THE ADRENALINE
PITCHING IN THE BIG LEAGUES
COULD ABSOLUTELY DO IT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE PITCH COUNT.
OUR RESEARCHER GAVE ME THIS
NUGGET.
HE REACHED A HIGH OF 95 AGAINST
THE CHICAGO WHITE SOX JULY 5,
BUT EVERY OTHER OUTING, 85 OR
BELOW.
SCOTT: NOTHING AND TWO.
CLEARLY HE IS PLAYING UP TO THE
COMPETITION.
LATROY: UNDERSTANDING HIS
OPPORTUNITY THIS YEAR, MAKING
STARTS, TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT.
I LOVE THE FACT, I LIKE TO SEE
YOUNG PITCHERS, WHEN THE
CATCHERS ARE GOING IN, THEY ARE
MISSING IN, NOT OVER THE PLATE.
HE HAS PITCHED VAUGHN VERY
TOUGH.
ALL THE FASTBALLS HAVE BEEN UP
AND IN.
THAT ONE WAS CLOSER TO HIS BODY
BUT GETTING A LOT OF SWINGS FROM
A BOND BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE HE
CAN HIT THE BALL, THE CLOSER IT
IS TO HIS BODY.
SCOTT: BIG CHASE UPSTAIRS.
BAILEY OBER PICKING UP ANOTHER
PUNCH OUT.
SIX ON THE DAY.
HE STRANDS TWO RUNNERS ON THE
FIFTH.
STILL LOOKING FOR OFFENSE IN THE
TWIN CITIES.
♪
>> 21-YEAR-OLD JUST CALLED UP
FROM BIRMINGHAM.
WILSON ALVAREZ ON THE HILL.
>> WILSON ALVAREZ PUNCHES OUT
THE SIDE HERE IN THE FIRST.
>> MELVIN SWINGS AND MISSES, AND
DOWN HE GOES.
THE ORIOLES LOOKING FOR THEIR
FIRST BASE HIT.
>> 1-0 OFFERING.
>> 0-2 PITCH.
THAT WILL DO IT.
THAT IS HEADING INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
YES.
THAT WILL RETIRE THE SIDE.
THERE IS A LOOPER.
WHAT A PLAY BY LANCE JOHNSON!
21-YEAR-OLD SOUTHPAW WILSON
ALVAREZ, IN HIS SECOND MAJOR
LEAGUE APPEARANCE, HAS JUST
THROWN A NO-HITTER.
SCOTT: MINNEAPOLIS TODAY, IOWA
TOMORROW FOR THE WHITE SOX.
THESE ARE THE CLASSIC UNIS THEY
WILL BE SUPPORTIVE FOR THE
FIELDS OF DREAMS GAME AGAINST
THE NEW YORK YANKEES.
THAT IS A FITTING LOOK FOR WHAT
WE ARE ABOUT TO SEE IN
TOMORROW'S CONTEST.
LATROY: I AM ALL FOR THE OLD
SCHOOL UNIFORMS, DIFFERENT COLOR
UNIFORMS.
I REALLY LIKE THE ALL-BLACK
UNIFORMS THEY HAVE.
THOSE ARE SICK.
SCOTT: NO LOGO ON THE CAT, NICE
AND CLEAN.
GET READY FOR THE FIRST MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL GAME IN IOWA
WHERE THE YANKEES AND WHITE SOX
WILL CLASH FOR THE MLB AT FIELD
OF DREAMS PRESENTED BY GEICO.
TOMORROW, AUGUST 13, 6:00
EASTERN TIME ON FOX.
EVERYONE IS BARRED UP FOR THAT
ON THE WHITE SOX SIDE.
WE HAVE BEEN CHATTING ABOUT IT
LEADING UP TO GAME TIME.
TRY TO NOT LOOK TOO FAR AHEAD AS
THEY FINISH UP THE SEASON SERIES
AGAINST THE TWINS THIS
AFTERNOON.
JAKE CAVE WITH A BUNT IN THE
AIR.
EASY GLOVED BY ANDREW VAUGHN.
ONE GONE.
LATROY, YOU AND I ARE GOING OUR
SEPARATE WAYS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK, BUT LAUREN GARDNER WILL
FOLLOW THE CHICAGO WHITE SOX
OVER TO IOWA.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT ONE,
AREN'T YOU?
LAUREN: I DON'T KNOW HOW I DREW
THE LONG STRAW IN THIS ONE BUT
SOMEHOW I AM HOPPING IN A CAR
AFTER THIS GAME AND DRIVING
DIRECTLY TO IOWA.
IT WAS REALLY FUN LISTENING TO
LIAM HENDRIKS ON MONDAY AND THE
PRESSER.
HE SAID HE WAS PART OF THE JAPAN
SERIES WITH THE A'S, AND
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE.
HE SAW THE MOVIE AS A KID IN
AUSTRALIA.
ANYTHING WITH KEVIN COSTNER WAS
GOING TO BE ON THEIR TELEVISION
SETS.
BUT HE DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND
THE CONCEPT, SO HE JUST SAW A
BUNCH OF GHOSTS RUNNING AROUND.
[LAUGHTER]
HE IS EXCITED TO PLAY IN THE
FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL GAME
IN THE STATE OF IOWA.
HE JUST HOPE THAT HE DOESN'T
STINK AND GIVE UP THE FIRST
MAJOR LEAGUE HOMER IN THAT
STATE.
HE IS LOOKING FORWARD TO DOING
THE CORN MAZE, LIKE LUCAS
GIOLITO SAID.
HE IS SO PUMPED TO BE A PART OF
HISTORY.
I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW EXCITED I
AM.
I DID NOT BRING MY GLOVE, SO I
WILL HAVE TO BORROW SOMEONE'S
LEFTY CLUB TO HAVE A CATCH.
SCOTT: YOU HAVE TO HAVE A CATCH,
GET INTO THE CORN MAZE.
LAUREN: I MAY GET LOST.
I MAY HAVE TO DROP A PIN AND
HAVE SOMEONE COME IN AND FIND
ME.
SCOTT: WILL THAT WORK OUT THERE?
I AM IN FROM AFAR.
WE WILL BE WATCHING, FOR SURE.
LATROY: I'M EXCITED.
I HAD NOT SEEN THE MOVIE IN
DECADES, BUT MAJOR TAKING THE
GAME THERE IS AWESOME.
SCOTT: GREAT IDEA.
IT WILL LOOK REALLY GOOD ON TV.
RYAN JEFFERS DOWN ON STRIKES.
LATROY: GOOD, HARD FASTBALL.
ELEVATED.
HITTERS CANNOT LAY OFF OF THOSE
HIGH FASTBALLS.
SCOTT: TREVOR LARNACH.
OFF-SPEED, STRIKE ONE.
GARRETT CROCHET IS NOT FUN TO
BASE.
-- FACE.
LATROY: HE IS TOUGH ON LEFTIES,
TOUGH ON RIGHTIES, BUT I'M SURE
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE FOR
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS.
SCOTT: USUALLY DOES NOT GO MORE
THAN AN INNING.
HE HAS HAD 25 PITCHES.
THE WHITE SOX HOPING FOR ONE
MORE BATTER.
WE MAY SEE THE GOBLET TODAY.
KOPECH, KIMBREL, HENDRIX.
LATROY: FASTBALL UP AND IN ON
TREVOR LARNACH.
TRYING TO GET OUT OF THE WAY.
SCOTT: HE DID, HE AVOIDED.
MANNY GONZALES TOOK A HIT.
OTHER WAY, AND THAT IS GOING TO
DROP.
IN MENEZ KEEPS IT IN FRONT OF
HIM.
IT IS A TWO OUT SINGLE FOR
TREVOR LARNACH.
LATROY: LARNACH WAS DRAFTED AS A
PROVEN HITTER, HIT WELL IN THE
MINOR LEAGUES.
WHEN HE GOT TO THE BIG LEAGUES,
HE WAS PULLING THE BALL A LOT.
TO SEE HIM TAKE THAT TO LEFT
EVEN OFF OF A HARD THROWING LEFT
HANDED PITCHER, THAT IS A GOOD
SIGN.
HE DIDN'T HAVE PROBLEMS SPRING
THE BALL ALL OVER THE FIELD BUT
ONCE HE GOT TO THE MAJOR
LEAGUES, DEAD PULL.
HE WAS NOT HAPPY ABOUT THAT, SO
A GOOD SITE TO SEE HIM HITTING
OPPOSITE FIELDS.
SCOTT: HE HAS A GOOD SWING.
PRETTY FROM THE LEFT SIDE.
24 YEARS OLD.
LATROY: OPPORTUNITY TO BE A VERY
GOOD HITTER IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
HE AND ALEX KIRILLOFF, TWO
PROSPECTS WITH THE TWINS.
SCOTT: KIRILLOFF HAD
SEASON-ENDING WRIST SURGERY LAST
MONTH.
SIMMONS WAS A STRIKEOUT VICTIM
IN THE THIRD.
THAT IS IN THERE.
LATROY: HIGH FASTBALL ABLE TO
CLIP THE TOP OF THE ZONE.
HOME PLATE, MANNY GONZALES,
FREELY CALLING THE HIGHER PITCH,
AS OPPOSED TO BALLS EAST AND
WEST.
SCOTT: JOSÉ RUIZ WARMING UP.
THAT MISSED.
BASE ON BALLS FOR SIMMONS.
LATROY: SOME CLOSE PITCHES.
SIMMONS DIDN'T BITE, EVEN THE
STRIKE AT THE TOP OF THE ZONE.
ABLE TO WORK HIMSELF A ONE-OUT
WALK -- TWO-OUT WALK.
SCOTT: MAKES SENSE, THOUGH, TO
STRETCH OUT CROCHET TO BE A
TWO-INNING GUY.
HE IS CAPABLE OF DOING IT, HAS
BEEN A STARTER BEFORE.
HE PITCHES WITH NASTY STUFF THAT
WE HAVE SEEN ON DISPLAY TODAY,
AND ALL SEASON.
TRYING TO GET A LITTLE MORE OUT
OF HIM.
LATROY: WHITE SOX PITCHING COACH
ETHAN CATCH GIVING HIM A
BREATHER.
TWO OUTS, LET'S FOCUS ON THE
HITTER, MAX KEPLER.
GET US BACK IN THE DUGOUT SO WE
CAN SCORE SOME RUNS.
I LIKE CROCHET'S DELIVERY, HIS
LEG KICK, THE DECEPTION HE
CREATES WITH THE HESITATION
AFTER HE KICKS HIS LEG, LIKE HE
STALLS OUT A LITTLE BIT AND THEN
EXPLODES TO THE PLATE.
A LOT OF DECEPTION WITH A LOT OF
QUESO COMING BY.
SCOTT: HE HAS THE STUD, POWERFUL
COMBINATION.
KAPLER DOESN'T GO AFTER THE
FIRST PITCH.
I FEEL BAD FOR LEFTY HITTERS,
PUT IT THAT WAY.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
KAPLER GOING IN THE LEADOFF SPOT
.
LATROY: TALK ABOUT CROCHET'S LEG
KICK, NOT AS BIG AS THE NORMAL
ONE.
THAT IS A SLIDE STEP, USE THAT
MORE WHEN YOU HAVE GUYS ON BASE.
A LOT OF TIMES WHEN NOBODY IS ON
BASE, TO DISRUPT HITTERS TIMING
BECAUSE THEY ARE LOOKED FOR THAT
BIG LEG KICK.
SCOTT: LARNACH AND SIMMONS ON
BOARD.
3-0.
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION NOT
DOING A TON.
.156, NO LONG BALLS, EIGHT
R.B.I.'S.
LATROY: YOU KNOW WHAT THEY CALL
THAT?
DOMINATION.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: LOCKING THINGS DOWN WHEN
YOU NEED TO.
LATROY: NOT JUST AGAINST THIS
TEAM.
THE ENTIRE WORLD OF BASEBALL.
SCOTT: HE FINDS THE ZONE.
LATROY: MANNY GONZALES CALLING
FOR THE HIGH PITCH.
CROCHET WAS ABLE TO CLIP IT,
HIGH, INSIDE FASTBALL.
TRY TO SOMEWHAT GET BACK IN THE
COUNT.
GOOD HITTER'S COUNT HERE FOR
KEPLER.
GET SOMETHING OVER THE MIDDLE OF
THE PLATE, HIT SOMETHING HARD,
DO SOME DAMAGE.
SCOTT: MOST OF THAT DAMAGE COMES
AGAINST PITCHERS WHO USE THEIR
RIGHT HAND, NOT THEIR LEFT.
KEPLER HAD A BREAKOUT 2019.
CHECK BACK TO SECOND, IT SALES
AWAY.
BOTH RUNNERS WILL MOVE UP.
LATROY: PLAY ON TO PICK LARNACH
OFF AT SECOND BASE, ALREADY
TRIED AT FIRST BASE.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS A BALL
THAT GARCIA COULD NOT HANDLE.
HE JUST MISJUDGED IT.
BOTH RUNNERS MOVE UP, SECOND AND
THIRD, 3-1 COUNT.
BASE HIT SCORES TWO.
SCOTT: NOW A FULL COUNT.
THIS WOULD BE THE DEFINITION OF
LOCKING DOWN WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE TWO OF THEM.
STILL LOOKING FOR SOMEONE TO
BREAK THE ICE SO FAR TODAY.
LATROY: SLIDER.
SCOTT: IT WORKED.
GARRETT CROCHET PICKS UP TWO
STRIKEOUTS IN THE FOURTH, TWO
MORE IN THE FIFTH WITH A LITTLE
PRESSURE.
TWO SCORELESS INNINGS.
WE HAVE PLAYED FIVE.
>> 30 YEARS AGO, I FELL IN LOVE
IN OCTOBER.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO RE-CREATE
THAT FEELING EVER SINCE.
SO LET'S TAKE IT BACK, TO GAME
SIX, THE METRODOME.
11 INNINGS DEEP.
I WAS SITTING JUST ROAD BEHIND
WHERE KIRBY'S HOME RUN LANDED.
THEN THERE WAS GAME SEVEN, AND
THE GREATEST WORLD SERIES OF ALL
TIME.
COINCIDENTALLY THROWN BY A
FELLOW KID FROM ST. PAUL.
IT WAS ONLY RIGHT THAT WE WENT
10 INNINGS, AND ENDED AT 1-0
WITH A WALKOFF.
THE 91 COLLECTION HONORS THAT
LEGACY AND PAYS TRIBUTE TO OUR
HOMETOWN, OUR EARLY YEARS, AND
OUR GREATEST MOMENT.
THERE IS NO MEMORY I CHERISH
MORE, AND I COULD NOT BE MORE
GRATEFUL DEAD TO BRING YOU THE
OFFICIAL 30TH ANNIVERSARY DROP
HONORING THE 1991 WORLD SERIES
CHAMPIONS, YOUR MINNESOTA TWINS.
LATROY: WE TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
BEEN WORKING FOR BAILEY OBER SO
FAR THIS AFTERNOON.
WE TALKED EARLIER IN THE
BROADCAST ABOUT HIS FASTBALL,
ELEVATED UP IN THE STRIKE ZONE.
ABLE TO GET STRIKEOUTS BY
SWINGING, ONE LOOKING.
ALL FASTBALLS ELEVATED, 93, 94
MILES PER HOUR.
ABLE TO THROW IT WHERE HE NEEDS
TO THROW IT.
TWO PUNCH-OUTS AGAINST VAUGHN,
IN AND ELEVATED AGAINST HIM.
SCOTT: HE HAS USED THAT
FOUR-SEAMER 50 OUT OF 74
PITCHES.
SLIDER, CHANGEUP, CURVEBALL.
BAILEY OBER, START NUMBER 13 IN
HIS CAREER.
HE STARTS A BREAK YOU WITH A
HIGH FASTBALL --ABREU WITH A
HIGH FASTBALL.
LATROY: VERY RARELY DO YOU SEE
GUYS PITCH WITH THEIR FASTBALL,
AND YOU HAVE TWO OF THEM IN THIS
BALLPARK.
LANCE LYNN AND OBER.
THEY CAN USE THEIR FASTBALL OVER
50% OF THE TIME AND THAT IS NOT
THE CASE ANYMORE IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
USUALLY A 50/50 SPLIT OR LESS
THAN THAT.
SCOTT: LOOK AT WHERE HE RELEASES
THE BALL, TOO.
LATROY: EXTENSION IS ABOUT SIX
FEET.
SCOTT: MORE.
I THINK IT IS 7'3", WHICH IS THE
SAME MARK AS TYLER GLASNOW, WHO
WENT HEALTHY IS THE BEST IN THE
BIZ, AND VERY TALL.
LATROY: THAT FASTBALL WAS RIGHT
DOWN THE MIDDLE.
BEING ABLE TO SHOW ABREU, VAUGHN
SOME OF THESE BIG HITTERS IN THE
WHITE SOX LINEUP FASTBALLS IN.
A LITTLE HESITANT TO JUMP OUT
THERE AND GET OUT TO THOSE OTHER
FASTBALLS.
THAT IS WHY YOU SEE THOSE
PICTURES GETTING -- PITCHES
GETTING FOULED BACK.
SCOTT: POLANCO CANNOT HANDLE
THAT.
NOT MUCH HARD CONTACTED A OPPO
BAILEY OBER BUT JOSE ABREU PICKS
UP A BASE HIT, HIS FIRST OF THE
AFTERNOON.
LATROY: I MENTIONED THE A'S
VESTMENT THESE WHITE SOX HITTERS
HAVE HAD TO MAKE OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
TAKING WITH THE DEFENSE IS
GIVING THEM.
ABREU IS A HOME RUN HITTER BUT
HE CAN ALSO HIT FOR AVERAGE.
HE WAS NOT AFRAID TO TAKE WHAT
OBER GAVE HIM.
HE SAW THE BIG OPEN SPOT IN THE
INFIELD FOR THE TWINS, HOW THEY
WERE PLAYING HIM TO PULL.
HE TOOK WHAT THEY GAVE HIM.
SCOTT: HERE IS EXAMPLE A.
ELOY JIMENEZ, TWO BASE HITS
TODAY.
MOST OF WHAT HAS BEEN LEADING
HIS BAT LATELY HAS GONE A LONG
WAY -- LEAVING HIS BAT LATELY
HAS GONE A LONG WAY.
LATROY: COUPLE OF HOMERUNS SINCE
ACTIVATED OFF OF THE I.L.
BROKEN BACK SINGLE TO JUST IN
FRONT OF JAKE CAVE, GROUND BALL
UP THE MIDDLE.
EVEN THOUGH HE IS 2-2 AGAINST
BAILEY OBER, RIGHT NOW, BAILEY
OBER IS WINNING, KEEPING THE
BALL IN THE BALLPARK.
THAT IS ONE THING I WAS SPEAKING
ABOUT, HE HAS TO KEEP THE BALL
IN THE BALLPARK.
THEY ARE LIKE THE TWINS, YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO PITCH THEM TOUGH.
YOU ARE NOT PLAYING SMALL BALL,
IT'S ABOUT BIG BALL WITH THESE
TEAMS.
SCOTT: THAT ONE IS TO LEFT.
GLIDING BACK IS LARNACH FOR THE
CATCH.
THE FIRST OUT IN THE SIXTH.
OUR THIRD POLL QUESTION OF THE
DAY ON YOUTUBE, EASY TO PLAY
ALONG.
GRAB YOUR MOBILE DEVICE, OR IF
YOU ARE WATCHING ON YOUR
COMPUTER SCREEN, IT IS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU.
FIRST COMING THE AL POSTSEASON
PICTURE.
RAYS LEAD THE DIVISION.
WHITE SOX IN THE CENTRAL.
ASTROS BY TWO GAMES.
WILD-CARD TEAMS AT THE MOMENT
ARE OAKLAND AND BOSTON.
NICE OVATION FOR BAILEY OBER AS
WELL.
LATROY: GREAT JOB BY BAILEY
OBER.
GIVING HIS CHANCE A GOOD -- HIS
TEAM A GOOD CHANCE TO WIN THE
GAME.
SCOTT: NEW PITCHER COMING IN.
HOLD THAT THOUGHT, POLL QUESTION
COMING IN IN JUST A MOMENT.
>> WELCOME TO A PLACE WHERE YOU
ARE GUARANTEED TO FIND OUT
SOMETHING ABOUT THE CHICAGO
WHITE SOX PAST, PRESENT, AND
FUTURE THAT YOU DIDN'T KNOW.
>> YOU ARE NOW WATCHING SOX TV.
♪
>> I TRUST EVERYTHING I THROW.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT ON
THROWING.
WHATEVER I THROW, I AM BETTER
THAN THE HITTER.
>> STRUCK HIM OUT, LIAM
HENDRIKS.
>> HE IS GUIDING PITCHES WITH A
LOT OF EMOTION.
HE IS IN ATTACK MODE.
>> HE BUSTED HIM WITH MORE HEAT.
>> IF YOU DON'T THINK I CANNOT
SUCCEED, I WILL PROVE YOU WRONG.
WATCH ME.
SCOTT: WATCH ALL OUT OF MARKET
REGULAR SEASON GAMES LIVE OR
ON-DEMAND ON MLB BIG INNING.
EXCLUSIVELY ON MLB.TV
.
BLACKOUTS AND OTHER RESTRICTIONS
APPLY.
OR JUST STAY IN MINNEAPOLIS.
SUN SHINING.
TEMPERATURES IN THE HIGH 80'S,
LOW 90'S.
I SHOWED YOU THE DIVISION
STANDINGS TWO MINUTES AGO.
NOW WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHICH
AL TEAM HAS THE BEST CHANCE TO
REACH THE WORLD SERIES?
ONE OF THE CURRENT DIVISION
LEADERS OR OTHER?
LATROY, STAY HOT.
LATROY: I WILL GO WITH THE
ASTROS.
SCOTT: YOU LIKE WHAT THEY ARE
BRINGING TO THE TABLE?
LATROY: THEIR ABILITY TO SCORE
RUNS, LEADING THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE IN SCORES, IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN.
THEY HAVE A REALLY GOOD BULLPEN,
CLOSER IN RYAN PRESSLY.
ALTUVE HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING THIS
YEAR.
26 HOME RUNS SO FAR?
SCOTT: THEY LEAD THE LEAGUE IN
RUNS SCORED, YOU ARE CORRECT.
THEY DON'T STRIKEOUT MUCH.
THIS GUY CAN PICK UP SOME SWING
AND MISS.
CALEB THIELBAR, 34 YEARS OLD,
MINNESOTA NATIVE.
HE TAKES OVER FOR BAILEY OBER,
WHO HAD HIMSELF A DAY.
LATROY: LAST PITCHED ON SATURDAY
AGAINST THE ASTROS, GAVE UP TWO
RUNS.
FASTBALL, 87 TO 94.
CURVEBALL, REALLY GOOD PITCH.
A LOT OF 12 TO 6 ACTION, RETAINS
THE SPEED ON IT.
WHAT IS UNUSUAL ABOUT HIM, HE
CAN SLOW -- THERE WERE A SLIDER
FROM THAT ARM SLIDE.
A LOT OF GUYS YOU DON'T SEE WITH
THAT ARM HIGHER UP AND ABLE TO
THROW A SLIDER.
USUALLY A FOUR-SEAM AND
CURVEBALL, BUT HE HAS ADDED THE
SLIDER TO HIS REPERTOIRE.
SCOTT: DOWN ON STRIKES IS BRIAN
GOODWIN.
THIELBAR ENTERS AND PICKS UP A
STRIKEOUT.
TWO DOWN IN THE SIXTH.
LATROY: SHOWED HIM A SLIDER AND
CAME BACK WITH A FASTBALL.
THAT FOUR-SEAM JUST AS TRUE AS
CAN BE, BACKSWING.
SCOTT: I JUST WANTED TO REMIND
YOU ABOUT THE COURTESY OF MGM,
WHEN YOU SAID I WILL TAKE A 2-0
GAME.
LATROY: PITCHER'S DUEL SO FAR.
SCOTT: A LOT OF GAME LEFT.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT.
REYNALDO LOPEZ HAS BEEN GOOD
WHEN HE HAS APPEARED FOR THE
WHITE SOX THE SEASON, GAVE THEM
THREE SOLID INNINGS.
IF YOU WATCHED BAILEY OBER
STARTS THIS SEASON, YOU SEE A
YOUNG PITCHER DEVELOPING INTO A
BIG LEAGUER.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE BELONGS.
LATROY: YOU GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LEARN ON THE JOB.
THIS IS PROBABLY HIS FIFTH TIME
FACING THE WHITE SOX.
HE HAS FACED THIS TEAM A LOT THE
SEASON.
HE HAS GOTTEN BETTER EACH TIME
HE HAS FACED THEM.
HIS STUFF HAS GOTTEN BETTER.
REMEMBER WHAT THESE GUYS HAVE
DONE TO THEM, WHAT HE NEEDS TO
DO TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SCOTT: HE KEEPS PICKING UP
STEAM.
SANO CATCHES THE POP UP IN FOUL
GROUND.
JOSÉ ABREU IS STRANDED.
MID SIX IN MINNESOTA.
>> THAT BALL IS HIT DEEP.
STRETCH.
MAKES THE CATCH.
YOU GOT TO BE BLEEPIN ME.
>> IT IS THE BEST COMPLEMENT YOU
CAN PAY ME, WHEN THAT GUY FROM
WALL STREET JOURNAL CALL ME LAST
YEAR AND SAID WE DID A SURVEY,
AND YOU ARE NUMBER ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
I SAID YOU JUST MADE MY DAY.
HIGH AND DEEP, WAY BACK.
NOT QUITE OUT OF HERE.
DAG GUMMIT.
WHEN WE LOSE, THERE IS NOT ONE
PERSON IN THE CLUBHOUSE WHO IS
MORE UPSET THAN I AM.
POPPED HIM UP.
GILLESPIE, AND NOW BECKHAM.
AND WE FIND YET ANOTHER WAY --
THAT IS HARD TO BELIEVE.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE GETTING ME.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME!
SCOTT: PLAY BALL IS BASEBALL AND
SOFTBALL'S INITIATIVE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE THOUGHT AND EXCESS
BUT WAYS TO PLAY THE GAME FOR
ALL.
GO TO PLAY BALL.ORG AND FOLLOW
ON TWITTER, FACEBOOK, AND
INSTAGRAM.
MLB ORIGINALS SEASON TWO IS LIVE
EVERY WEEK.
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
SCOTT BRAUN, LATROY HAWKINS,
LAUREN GARDNER BRING YOU THE
ACTION.
WE ARE ON THE ROAD FOR OUR MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK FOR THE FIRST
TIME THIS SEASON.
JOSÉ RUIZ, E.R.A. IN THE 3.5
RANGE NEXT OUT OF THE BULLPEN
AFTER LOPEZ AND CROCHET.
LATROY: THE WHITE SOX KEEP
RUNNING GUYS OUT THERE THAT
THROW 95 PLUS MILES PER HOUR.
THAT GOOD QUESO.
FASTBALL, CHANGEUP.
SOME GOOD CARRY.
CURVEBALL, 83 TO 90.
SCOTT: HE STARTED OUT AS A
CATCHER IN THE PADRES SYSTEM,
DECIDED TO PITCH IN 2016.
IT IS WORKING OUT.
LATROY: FIRST PITCH FOR A
STRIKE.
SCOTT: TWO STRIKEOUTS TODAY FOR
WORKER -- ROOKER.
TWO STRIKES AGAINST HIM.
THEY ARE GOING RIGHT AFTER HIM.
LATROY: STEADY DIET OF SLIDERS,
FASTBALLS IN.
HAS NOT MADE MUCH CONTACT TODAY
BUT I HAVE BEEN -- SEEN HIM HIT
THE BALL IN THE THIRD DECK HERE
IN LEFT FIELD ON A HANGING
SLIDER.
IT WAS LOUD AND FAR.
SCOTT: PAINT ON THE CORNER FROM
RUIZ.
THIS IS AN OUTFIELD FULL OF
FORMER FIRST ROUNDERS.
YOU TALK ABOUT KIRILLOFF, ROOKER
, LARNACH.
WHAT ABOUT BYRON BUXTON?
THIS IS A SPECIAL TALENT, AND
THAT PROBLEM HAS BEEN KEEPING
HIM ON THE FIELD.
THE LATEST INJURY FOR HIM WAS ON
A HIT BY PITCH.
LATROY: TWO DAYS AFTER COMING
BACK FROM HIS HIP INJURY.
WHEN HE IS OUT THERE, HE BRINGS
SO MUCH TO THIS TEAM.
SCOTT: FIRST PITCH SWINGING,
POLANCO, IT IS GOING A LONG WAY.
ENGEL GIVES IT A LOOK BUT FORGET
ABOUT IT!
JORGE POLANCO MUSCLES UP, AND
THE TWINS ARE ON THE BOARD
FIRST.
NUMBER 21 ON THE SEASON.
HE IS THE ROCK OF THE OFFENSE.
LATROY: POLANCO HAS BEEN
SWINGING THE BAT WELL FOR THE
LAST 50 GAMES.
FASTBALL OVER THE OPEN PLATE.
DID NOT NEED TO TURN AND BURN ON
THAT BECAUSE THE BALL WAS A
LITTLE BIT AWAY FROM HIM.
HE DROVE THAT BALL RIGHT INTO
THE WHITE SOX BULLPEN FOR A SOLO
SHOT.
SCOTT: FIRST PITCH, KNOCKS OFF
THE GLOVE.
IT IS CLEANED UP BY RUIZ.
OUT NUMBER TWO.
THAT IS NICE POP FROM YOUR
SECOND BASEMAN.
LATROY: OPPO TACO.
HE HAS BEEN PULLING THE BALL A
LOT.
THAT SHOWS YOU HE HAS THE
ABILITY TO HIT THE BALL OUT OF
THE BALLPARK WITHOUT HAVING TO
PULL IT.
SCOTT: 416 FEET.
THAT IS A GOOD HOME RUN RATE IN
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS.
SEVEN IN 13 GAMES.
LATROY: HE HAD AN INCREDIBLE
10-GAME ROAD TRIP THE TWINS JUST
GOT OFF OF ON SUNDAY, TAKING
THREE OUT OF FOUR IN HOUSTON.
SCOTT: WITH AN EXCLAMATION POINT
ON SUNDAY, HE PUT TWO OVER THE
WALL.
THIS MAN IS CAPABLE OF DOING
DAMAGE, TOO.
LATROY: DESPITE THE TWINS
RECORD, THEY HAVE PLAYED BETTER
RECENTLY.
SCOTT: IT WAS THE SURPRISINGLY
SLOW START FOR THE BACK-TO-BACK
DIVISION CHAMPS.
THEY HAVE BEEN .500ISH SINCE THE
NIGHTMARE.
LATROY: WHEN DID THE NIGHTMARE
START, MARCH 31?
SCOTT: PRETTY MUCH.
FOR ABOUT A MONTH, YOU CAN LOSE
YOUR WAY OUT OF A DIVISION RAYS
PRETTY QUICKLY.
LATROY: EVERYBODY IN THIS
DIVISION NEW THAT IT -- THERE
WAS A GOOD CHANCE IT WOULD BE A
DOGFIGHT WITH TWO TEAMS, THE
WHITE SOX AND THE TWINS.
THE WHITE SOX HAVE DEFINITELY
TAKEN CONTROL OF THE
DIVISION, YOUNG, EXCITING, VERY
GOOD BULLPEN.
THEY HAVE ALL THE PIECES THEY
NEED TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
NOT JUST THE CENTRAL DIVISION
CHAMPIONSHIP, TALKING ABOUT A
WORLD SERIES CHAMPIONSHIP.
SCOTT: AND IMPACT POSITION
PLAYERS COMING BACK IT FEELS
LIKE ONCE A WEEK NOW.
JIMENEZ, ROBERT, GRANDAL SOON.
JUST STARTED A REHAB ASSIGNMENT,
ANNOUNCED TODAY.
LATROY: I REMEMBER BEING IN
SPRING TRAINING, HE ELOY JIMENEZ
GOT HURT.
JUST THINKING, THAT IS A HUGE
BLOW TO THEM, HOW WILL THEY MAKE
UP FOR THAT PRODUCTION IN THEIR
LINEUP?
LEFT FIELD, NOT AN ABOVE AVERAGE
DEFENDER, OK?
BUT WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE PLATE
IS FAR MORE VALUABLE TO THE
TEAM.
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO IT.
ALL THE DECISIONS THEY MADE, THE
GUYS THEY BROUGHT UP TO FILL
THAT VOID ALL PLAYED EXTREMELY
WELL.
SCOTT: IT HAS BEEN A REVOLVING
DOOR IN THE OUTFIELD.
CREDIT THE WHITE SOX FRONT
OFFICE FOR FINDING REPLACEMENTS
THAT PLATE AT AN ABOVE AVERAGE
RATE.
LATROY: GIVE CREDIT TO GUYS LIKE
JOE MCEWING, FRANK, JERRY
NEHRING, MIGUEL GONZALEZ, GUYS
WHO ARE THERE, SHELLEY DUNCAN,
MIGUEL CAIRO, GUYS WHO HAVE BEEN
AROUND THE GAME A LONG TIME,
UNDERSTAND HOW TO GET A PLAYER
PREPARED TO BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS
POSSIBLE.
LARISSA GIVING THEM THE ABILITY
TO GO OUT AND DO THEIR WORK.
SCOTT: TONY KNOWS HOW TO BUILD A
COACHING STAFF.
LATROY: I REALLY ENJOYED THE
CONVERSATION TODAY.
THAT WAS MONEY.
SCOTT: BALL FOUR.
SANO IS A TWO-OUT BASE RUNNER.
LATROY: LISTENING TO LA RUSSA
GIVE OTHER MANAGERS A LOT OF
CREDIT.
HE SPOKE ABOUT HIS CONVERSATIONS
WITH TOM KELLY, THE MUTUAL
RESPECT THEY HAVE FOR ONE
ANOTHER JUST FOR COMPUTING WITH
ONE ANOTHER OVER THE YEARS.
NOT JUST RESPECT BETWEEN THE
MANAGERS BUT THE RESPECT FOR
EACH TEAM HAD FOR EACH OTHER.
JERRY NARRON ON THE SCREEN.
SCOTT: THIS IS JAKE CAVE.
STRIKE ONE FROM RUIZ.
TONY WEARS THAT WING AROUND --
RING AROUND.
HE HAS A FEW.
WHEN YOU ARE HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH SOMEONE AND
YOU LOOK DOWN AND YOU SEE, HE
HAS ONE OF THOSE WORLD SERIES
RINGS ON GOING AFTER, HOPEFULLY
A LITTLE MORE JUICE.
LATROY: HE HAS A RESUME, THAT IS
FOR SURE.
HE HAS A BASEBALL CARD, RESUME
AS A MANAGER, GETTING THE MOST
OUT OF HIS PLAYERS.
A LOT OF MANAGERS ARE NOT ABLE
TO DO THAT, THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
MAGIC.
I LIKE TO CALL IT MAGIC BECAUSE
EVERY GUY DOES NOT HAVE IT.
I LIKE TO SAY ROCCO HAS THAT
MAGIC, GETTING THE BEST OUT OF
HIS PLAYERS, PUTTING THEM IN
POSITION WHERE THEY HAVE THE
CHANCE TO BE THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL.
SCOTT: HE IS EXTREMELY
WELL-LIKED WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION.
IT IS VERY EASY TO SEE WHY.
LATROY: JUST TALKING TO LA
RUSSA, THE RESPECT HE HAS FOR
ROCCO BALDELLI.
THAT IS COMING FROM A GUY WHO
HAS BEEN IN THE GAME OF BASEBALL
LONGER THAN HE'S BEEN LIVING.
SCOTT: OLDEST MANAGER VERSUS
YOUNGER MANAGER.
ADVANTAGE DAY TO THE YOUNGEST
MANAGER THANKS TO HIS MOST
CONSISTENT BAT THIS SEASON,
JORGE POLANCO.
THE TWINS ARE TRYING TO GRAB
THIS SERIES.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> 3-2.
TO THIRD.
MONCADA.
CARLOS RODON HAS THROWN A
NO-HITTER.
AFTER EVERYTHING HE HAS BEEN
THROUGH, THE ELBOW AND THE
SHOULDER, SUPREME ON APRIL 14,
2021.
HERE IS A PITCH.
LAST TWO RIGHT.
IT IS GONE!
WHITE SOX WIN IT.
WHAT A SHOT BY GAVIN SHEETS!
>> GAVIN SHEETS ON A 3-1
FASTBALL, HE LET IT GO.
>> HE ONLY NEEDS ONE AT-BAT.
>> THE ELOY JIMENEZ, DO NOT WALK
ANYONE IN FRONT OF HIM.
WOW.
WELCOME BACK.
SEE YOU LATER.
5-3.
SCOTT: WE ARE INTO THE SEVENTH,
1-0, TWINS.
THE HOME TEAM HAD BEEN MISSING
THEIR SUPERSTAR FOR MOST OF THE
SEASON, ONLY PLAYED IN 36% OF
THEIR GAMES SINCE. 2018
IT IS A LONG INJURY LIST WE SAW
HIM THIS MORNING, BYRON BUXTON.
IN A MONTH'S WORK THIS YEAR HE
HAS LOOKED LIKE AN M.V.P..
HE IS THAT SPECIAL.
ALSO DEVELOPED HIS LEADERSHIP
WITHIN THE CLUBHOUSE.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE IS ON THE WAY
BACK SOON.
THE PROBLEM LATELY IS THE
LEFT-HAND FRACTURE ON A HIT BY
PITCH.
SOME MISFORTUNE AND SOME
BREAKDOWNS IN TERMS OF THE BODY,
BUT HE IS STILL YOUNG, AND USING
WITH POTENTIAL.
LATROY: WE SAW PROBABLY THE BEST
36 GAMES OF HIS CAREER.
M.V.P.-ESQUE.
I HOPING HE GETS ALL OF HIS
INJURIES BEHIND HIM AND HE CAN
FINISH HIS CAREER WITH NO MORE
HICCUPS.
HE IS A GENERATIONAL TYPE OF
PLAYER.
HIS ATHLETICISM, POWER, HIS ARM,
ABILITY TO RUN.
BUT WE HAVE TO GET HIM ON THE
FIELD.
WHEN HE IS ON THE FIELD, WE KNOW
HE IS THE BEST PLAYER ON THE
FIELD.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE LATEST, JUNE
21.
TYLER MAHLE THROWS WITH HEAT.
FRACTURES THE LEFT-HAND.
LATROY: JUST CAME BACK IN TEXAS,
FATHER'S DAY WEEKEND.
TWO DAYS AND TOOK A FASTBALL OFF
THE HAND.
I REMEMBER I WAS AT HOME
WATCHING IT IN THE THEATER, AND
I JUST STARTED SCREAMING.
MY WIFE IS LIKE WHAT IS WRONG
WITH YOU?
HE JUST GOT BACK.
BYRON CANNOT BUY A BREAK.
BUT THROUGH ALL THE INJURIES,
ATTITUDE HAS BEEN GREAT, ENERGY
HAS BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
WORKING HIS BEHIND OFF, TRYING
TO GET BACK IN.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU HAVE AN ELITE
ATHLETE LIKE THAT, YOU HAVE TO
PROTECT THEM FROM THEMSELVES
SOMETIMES.
THEY THINK THEY ARE READY.
EVEN THOUGH HE IS STILL BETTER
THAN A LOT OF PEOPLE AT 90%, WE
NEED HIM AT 100% WHEN HE GOES
BACK ON THE FIELD.
SCOTT: ESPECIALLY FOR A TEAM
THAT IS THINKING ABOUT 2022,
GIVING LOOKS TO YOUNGER PLAYERS.
LATROY: SOME GUYS HAVE BENEFITED
FROM HIM BEING ON THE I.L.
SCOTT: LAMB PULLS IT TO WRITE.
KEPLER IS THERE.
YOUNG OUTFIELDERS GALORE.
KIRILLOFF, LARNACH, ROOKER, ALL
FORMER FIRST-ROUND PICKS.
ALL YOUNG COME PICKING UP
PLAYING TIME.
KIRILLOFF, UNFORTUNATELY DOWN
FOR THE REST OF THE SEASON WITH
A WRIST INJURY.
THIS IS A CHANCE FOR THE TWINS
TO SEE WHAT THEY HAVE GOT PUT
SOME OF THE YOUNGER SERVICE.
IT DIDN'T HAVE TIME FOR THAT,
AND ROCCO BALDELLI SAID WE HAVE
HAD A VETERAN CLUB THE LAST FEW
SEASONS.
WON THE A.L. CENTRAL LAST YEAR
AND THE YEAR BEFORE.
THAT IS WHERE THE BOMBA SQUAD
NICKNAME CAME UP.
THE PROBLEM IS, IT IS WELL
DOCUMENTED, PLAYOFF RECORD, NOT
MUCH WINNING IN THE POSTSEASON.
LATROY: TWO OTHER GUYS ON THAT
BOARD THAT YOU JUST SHOWED WITH
THE OUTFIELDERS.
NICK GORDON PLAY CENTER FIELD,
NEVER PLAYED IN THE OUTFIELD
BEFORE.
FIRST TIME WAS IN A MAJOR LEAGUE
GAME IN CENTER FIELD.
ROB REFSNYDER, HE HAD A MONTH
PLAYING IN THE OUTFIELD WHERE HE
WAS VERY GOOD.
BROUGHT IN THE PRODUCTION
OFFENSIVELY THAT THE TEAM
NEEDED, EXTRA SHOT IN THE ARM.
HE PLAYED A VERY GOOD CENTER
FIELDER.
I DON'T THINK HE HAD PLAYED
OFTEN THAT MUCH AS WELL.
SCOTT: IT IS A NEW POSITION FOR
ROB, AND A BIT OF A NEW SWING
FOR HIM HAS GIVEN HIM RESULTS.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT AUSTIN MARTIN
WHO CAME OVER IN THE JOSE
BERRIOS TRADE.
HE CAN PLAY EVERYWHERE AND HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BE IN THE
POTENTIAL TO BE AN OUTFIELD FOR
THEM AS WELL.
FORMER FIFTH OVERALL PICK BY THE
TORONTO BLUE JAYS.
LATROY: AUSTEN IN THE PLAYING
SHORTSTOP.
I THINK HE GOT A COUPLE OF
AT-BATS, BUT WATCHING HIS
ABILITY CONTROL THE AT-BAT.
HE HAD AN 11-PITCH AT-BAT DURING
THAT GAME.
SCOTT: GARCIA IS THE FIRST BASE
RUNNER IN THE INNING.
EARMUFFS, TWINS FANS.
SORRY.
IT IS A GLOBAL BROADCAST, I HAVE
TO DO IT.
SOME ARE NOT AWARE OF THE
LONGEST EVER POSTSEASON LOSING
STREAK THAT IS UP AND RUNNING
RIGHT NOW SINCE 2004.
18 CONSECUTIVE LOSSES.
LAST TIME THEY PICKED UP A W IN
OCTOBER WAS THE 2004 ALDS GAME
ONE AGAINST THE YANKEES.
THIS IS INCLUDING ALL OF THE
NORTH AMERICAN PRO SPORTS.
LATROY: LAST TIME THEY WON A
PLAYOFF SERIES?
SCOTT: YES.
IT IS NOT LIKE IT IS A FRANCHISE
THAT HAS BEEN FULL OF LOSING.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME DIVISION
TITLES SINCE THEN.
LOOK BEHIND ZACK COLLINS.
LATROY: YOU CAN SEE THE SIGN
THAT TC HAS.
HI, TC.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
SCOTT: COLLINS SPITZ 12 LEFT,
FADING TOWARD THE LINE.
LARNACH IS THEREFORE THE CATCH.
MOVING UP TO SECOND, IN THERE
SAFELY IS LEURY GARCIA.
FLASHBACK TO 2004.
LAST W FOR THE MINNESOTA TWINS
ORGANIZATION IN THE PLAYOFFS,
YANKEE STADIUM, ALDS GAME ONE.
LATROY: JOE NATHAN VERSUS RUBEN
SIERRA.
SCOTT: WERE YOU STILL THERE?
LATROY: 2004, NO.
I LEFT AFTER THE 2003 SEASON.
SCOTT:  YOU HAD SOME GOODW'S.
2002, 2003 DIVISION TITLES.
YOU ARE LOOKING UP TO TC.
YES, WE SEE YOU.
LATROY AND THE TWINS MASCOT
GOING BACK AND FORTH RIGHT NOW
WHILE THERE IS A PITCHING
CHANGE.
TWO OUTS IN THE SECOND.
THAT IS ALL FOR CALEB THIELBAR.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> SEE IF HE CAN GET HIMSELF A
HANGING BREAKING BALL.
>> HIGH FLY, LEFT CENTER FIELD.
MIGUEL SANO SAYS THAT IS ENOUGH.
HE GOT A HANGING BREAKING BALL
AND HE ENDED IT.
WALK-OFF, TWO-RUN HOME RUN.
AND THE TWINS IN 12 PREVAIL.
>> FLY BALL INTO RIGHT FIELD,
DEEP.
DEEP IT GOES, TIE GAME!
UNBELIEVABLE.
A NO DOUBTER.
9-9 IN THE NINTH INNING.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
SCOTT: 1-0 TWINS OFF UP
POLANCO'S SOLO SHOT.
ANOTHER YOU TO PULL IN THE
BOOKS.
THE TEAM THAT HAS THE BEST
CHANCE TO WIN THE AL, THE WHITE
SOX TAKING 53% OF THE POLE.
PLENTY OF WHITE SOX FANS TUNING
IN RIGHT NOW.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION.
THE TWINS WON THIS DIVISION THE
PRIOR TWO YEARS.
NOW THEY ARE LOADING UP FOR THE
FUTURE, LIKE A MINI RELOAD.
IS THAT A FAIR ASSESSMENT?
LATROY: THEY ARE BUILDING.
WE WILL NOT SAY REBUILD.
SCOTT: THESE ARE TWO BIG PARTS
OF THE FUTURE FOR THE TWINS
ORGANIZATION.
THEY PICKED THEM UP IN THE JOSE
BERRIOS TRADE.
AUSTIN MARTIN AND SIMEON WOODS
RICHARDSON.
WE HAVE A GREAT BAT BACK AND
PLAY IN A NUMBER OF SPOTS, AND A
BIG ARM COMING TO MINNESOTA FOR
A PLAYER THAT MAY IMPACT THE
POSTSEASON RACE QUITE A BIT.
JOSE BERRIOS HAD A NICE SEASON
WITH THE MINNESOTA TWINS, NOW
WILL SPEND AT LEAST THE NEXT ONE
AND HALF SEASONS WITH THE BLUE
JAYS.
JUAN MINAYA TAKING OUT HERE IN
THE SEVENTH.
A RUNNER IN SCORING POSITION
BEHIND HIM WHO CAN MOVE.
LEURY GARCIA WORKED A ONE OUT
WALK.
CESAR HERNANDEZ NOW.
BIG-TIME POWER YEAR.
CAREER-HIGH 20 HOMERS.
LATROY: THAT IS BIG FOR HIM.
THE AVERAGE IS .237 ON-BASE
PERCENTAGE.
THOSE POWER NUMBERS FROM YOUR
SECOND BASEMAN, THAT IS
REMINISCENT OF A BRIAN DOZIER.
SCOTT: IT IS LEGIT.
CAREER-BEST EXIT VELOCITY,
BARREL PERCENTAGE, THE LAUNCH
ANGLE IS SIGNIFICANTLY UP.
HE IS CRUSHING FASTBALLS.
THREE HOMERS LAST YEAR IN 60
GAMES.
HE DID THAT IN A FEW GAMES TO
START THE SEASON.
HE HAS NOT SLOWED DOWN.
LATROY: GETTING SOME GOOD
PITCHES TO HIT, TRYING TO PUT
THEM IN PLAY.
TRY TO DO SOME DAMAGE.
SCOTT: JUAN MINAYA PICKING UP
THE PUNCH OUT.
HERNANDO'S IT WAS LOW.
A LITTLE BACK-AND-FORTH BUT THAT
WILL DO IT FOR THE INNING.
GARCIA STRANDED AT SECOND.
I KNOW LATROY IS CALLING IT A
STRIKE.
LATROY: NO, THAT BALL WAS DOWN
BUT YOU HAVE NOT SEEN MANY GOOD
DOLLARS -- MANNY GONZALES NOT
GIVE THAT AS A STRIKE.
>> ONE AWAY TO JOIN THE 3000-HIT
CLUB.
DEREK JETER HAS DONE IT.
>> THIS BALL IS GONE.
THE WHITE SOX WIN IT 7-6.
>> FROM THE CORNFIELDS OF IOWA,
THE FIELD OF DREAMS PLAYS HOST
TO THE YANKEES AND THE WHITE
SOX.
♪
>> IN THE GAME OF BASEBALL,
THERE IS A SPECIAL PLACE.
THEY HAVE BUILT IT, AND NOW WE
HAVE COME.
IT IS NOT HEAVEN, BUT IT IS
PRETTY DARN CLOSE.
SCOTT: IN THAT FIELD OF DREAMS
GAME IS GOING TO BE SPECIAL.
THE NEW YORK YANKEES WAS THE
CLASSIC UNIS.
DJ LEMAHIEU WILL BE THERE FOR A
YANKEE'S TEAM PLAYING PRETTY
GOOD BASEBALL.
GLEYBER TORRES ON THE INJURED
LIST RIGHT NOW.
AARON JUDGE, I WANT TO SEE WHAT
HE DOES WITH A BASEBALL AND THE
CORNFIELDS TO WORK WITH.
UNFORTUNATELY, TONY LA RUSSA
WILL NOT BE MAKING THE TRIP.
THERE WAS A DEATH IN THE FAMILY.
HE WILL MAKE A QUICK TRIP OUT TO
PAY A VISIT AND THEN COME BACK
TO THE WHITE SOX ON SATURDAY FOR
THEIR NEXT GAME AGAINST THE
YANKEES.
THAT WILL BE IN CHICAGO.
HE IS STILL THERE, STAYED IN THE
GAME.
JUST WANTED TO GET A LITTLE WORD
ON THE VERTICAL ASPECT OF THE
STRIKE ZONE FROM THE LAST HALF
INNING.
JUAN MINAYA PICKING UP THE
STRIKEOUT TO ESCAPE.
NOW, MATT FOSTER INTO THE GAME
AND JUST CALLED UP TODAY WITH
CARLOS RODON HITTING THE SHELF.
LATROY: FOSTER 28 GAME OF THE
SEASON FOR THE WHITE SOX, JUST
GOT CALLED UP FROM AAA
CHARLOTTE.
SCOTT: E.R.A. ABOUT HALF THAT
NUMBER IN AAA.
FOSTER WAS GOOD DOWN THERE.
COMING BACK UP AS AN EXTRA ARM.
WHITE SOX FANS ARE WORRIED ABOUT
CARLOS RODON, AT LEAST FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH ORGANIZATION,
IT SOUNDS LIKE JUST SOME
SORENESS.
ALSO KEEPING IN MIND, HE HAS NOT
PITCHED A TON.
THIS IS A LENGTHY SEASON FOR
HIM.
NOT THE WORST THING IN THE WORLD
FOR A TEAM WITH A DOUBLE-DIGIT
LEAD IN THE DIVISION.
LATROY: GIVING HIM A 10-DAY
REST, BREAK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
SEASON SO HE CAN RECHARGE HIS
BATTERY AND GET READY FOR SOME
OCTOBER PITCHING.
WIN FOR THE WHITE SOX
ORGANIZATION.
SCOTT: JEFFERSON STRIKES OUT.
LATROY: YOU MENTIONED FOSTER.
2.2 E.R.A. LAST YEAR, ELEVATED
THIS YEAR.
GOOD FASTBALL, 90 TO 95.
HE HAS A PLUS CHANGEUP.
CHANGEUP IS PREDOMINATELY HIS
BEST PITCH.
SCOTT: STUFF-WISE, THIS BULLPEN
IS RIDICULOUS.
THIS GUY WOULD BE A BIG PART OF
MANY OTHER BULLPENS.
LATROY: I AM SURE THE
ACQUISITION OF CRAIG KIMBREL
DIDN'T HELP HIM THAT MUCH.
SCOTT: KOPECH, CRIM BALL, --
KIMBREL, CROCHET THE BIG
OFF-SEASON SIGNING.
LATROY: LARNACH SQUARED AROUND
THE BUNT, NOT SURE IF HE WAS
STICKING ABOUT LAYING IT DOWN.
DEFINITELY DREW THE ATTENTION OF
JAKE LAMB AT THIRD BASE.
SCOTT: WHEN YOU SEE BUNT, DO YOU
THINK DIFFERENTLY FOR THE NEXT
PITCH?
NOWADAYS YOU ARE NOT EXPECTING
HIM TO DOUBLE UP, SO IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
LATROY: NOWADAYS YOU ARE NOT
EXPECTING HIM TO BUNT.
[LAUGHTER]
EVER.
IF YOU SQUARE AROUND A PITCH, I
LIKE TO THROW ONE RIGHT AT YOUR
FACE.
NOT AS COMFORTABLE.
SCOTT: LARNACH TO LEFT.
JIMENEZ GOT IT.
TWO AWAY IN THE SEVENTH.
GET EXCLUSIVE CONTENT FROM YOUR
FAVORITE TEAM, THE CHICAGO WHITE
SOX.
YOUTUBE.COM/WHITESOX, AND HIT
THAT SUBSCRIBE BUTTON TODAY.
LATROY: WHEN THE FIELD OF DREAMS
WAS PREMIERED IN 1989 -- YOU ARE
A LOT YOUNGER.
DID YOU THINK THAT MOVIE WAS
GOING TO STAND THE TEST OF TIME?
IT WAS A GOOD MOVIE, BUT I
DIDN'T KNOW, 32 YEARS LATER --
THAT IS PRETTY COOL.
SCOTT: IT IS THE AESTHETICS FOR
ME, THAT IS WHAT STOOD OUT.
THE CINEMATOGRAPHY, HOW COOL
THAT FIELD LOOKED.
I RECENTLY DID A SIT-DOWN
INTERVIEW WITH KEVIN COSTNER, HE
SAID AFTER THE SHOOT, I WOULD
KEEP THIS FIELD.
WE HAVE SOMETHING SPECIAL HERE.
I AM GLAD THEY KIND OF PRESERVED
THAT WHOLE AREA SO THAT WE CAN
DO WHAT WE ARE DOING TOMORROW IN
IOWA.
THAT IS WHAT STOOD OUT TO ME.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
LATROY: I HAVE NOT WATCHED IT IN
DECADES.
[LAUGHTER]
I TOLD YOU EARLIER.
I AM NOT REALLY INTO BASEBALL
MOVIES, JUST DOCUMENTARIES ABOUT
BASEBALL.
NOT MOVIES, DOCUMENTARIES.
LAUREN: I HAVE TO INTERJECT
HERE.
I AM LOVING THIS CONVERSATION,
BUT LATROY, WHEN YOU ASKED HIS
THOUGHT PROCESS, IF IT WOULD
STAND THE TEST OF TIME WHEN IT
CAME OUT IN 1989.
CAN WE PUT UP A POLL?
HOW OLD ARE YOU?
SCOTT: I DON'T GIVE THAT AWAY.
LAUREN: I WILL BE 25 FOREVER.
LATROY: EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW OLD
YOU ARE, EXCEPT FOR ME.
LAUREN: LATROY, YOU WERE ONLY
12?
LATROY: I WAS A SOPHOMORE IN
HIGH SCHOOL, SORRY.
LAUREN: I WAS TRYING TO GIVE YOU
LEEWAY.
LATROY: I AM 49.
I HAVE NO PROBLEMS WITH THAT.
I WAS GETTING READY TO BE
DRAFTED.
LAUREN: THAT IS EXPERIENCE AND
WISDOM.
LATROY: MY GRANDFATHER TOLD ME A
WHILE AGO, NEVER RESENT GROWING
OLD.
MANY WERE DENIED THE PRIVILEGE.
SCOTT: I LIKE THAT.
LATROY: YOU TALK ABOUT THE
CINEMATOGRAPHY, AESTHETICS, 2017
IT WAS SELECTED FOR PRESERVATION
FOR THE NATIONAL FILM REGISTRY
BY THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS FOR
CULTURALLY, HISTORICALLY, OR
AESTHETICALLY SIGNIFICANT.
SCOTT: SIMMONS TO WRITE.
GOODWIN RUNS IT DOWN.
HIGH-FIVES FOR PEOPLE EVERYONE
-- OR EVERYONE RUNNING TO THE
DUGOUT.
WE MOVE ON TO THE EIGHTH.
PITCHER'S DUEL TODAY.
THE BULLPEN IS TAKING OVER AND
LOOKING NICE.
SCOTT: 1-0 TWINS OFF OF A JORGE
POLANCO HOME RUN.
CHECK OUT SOME FORMER COMES
WEARING WHITE SOX UNIS.
IF THE WHITE SOX WIN A WORLD
SERIES THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR,
THE COUPLE PLAY A BIG PART OF
IT.
NOW SOME BULLPEN HELP WITH TO
PAIR AND KIMBREL FOR THE STRETCH
RUN.
JUAN MINAYA BACK TO WORK IN THE
EIGHT.
LATROY: WE CALL THAT BEING A
FRIENDLY NEIGHBOR.
SCOTT: I LIKE THAT.
LATROY: THEY DID NOT TRADE THEM
IN DIVISION COME OUT OF THE
DIVISION, OUT OF THE LEAGUE,
WHICH IS FINE.
THREE PITCHES.
QUICK STRIKEOUT FOR JUAN MANAEA.
THIRD K OF THE DAY FOR ANDREW
VAUGHN.
HE IS 0-4.
JOSE ABREU IS UP, MIGUEL SANO AT
FIRST BASE.
THEY HAD A CONVERSATION AND WE
ARE LUCKY BECAUSE MEGILL IS
MIC'D UP.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, I'M
HERE AT FIRST BASE WITH ONE OF
THE BEST HITTERS IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE, AND THE D.
JOSE ABREU.
SCOTT: HE IS HOSTING A SHOW.
THEY ARE GOING TO LOVE HIM ON
PLAY LOUD, THE YOUTUBE SHOW THAT
COLLECTS ALL OF THAT MONEY
CONTENT, PUT IT TOGETHER ON
YOUTUBE EACH WEEK.
THE MIGUEL SANO MIC'D UP TODAY.
LATROY: THAT WAS A ONE-MINUTE
INTERVIEW.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: JOSE MAY NOT KNOW THAT HE
IS MIC'D UP.
LATROY: WHY ISN'T HE SPEAKING
SPANISH?
COME ON, NOW, MIGUEL.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ABREU WITH A BASE LAST TIME UP.
SCOTT: 1-3 TODAY, 84 RBIS.
LOOK AT JUAN MANAEA GO.
LATROY: ABREU IS A MACHINE, WHEN
GUYS ARE OUT THERE ON BASE
PATHS, A GOOD CHANCE HE WILL
BRING THEM AROUND TO SCORE.
REALLY GOOD CHANGEUP FROM
MANAEA.
ABREU FOUL TIPPED THAT BALL INTO
JEFFERS GLOVE.
HE DOESN'T LIKE TO STRIKEOUT.
SCOTT: GOING UP AGAINST THE
HEAVY HITTERS IN THE EIGHTH
INNING.
MANAEA STRUCK OUT VAUGHN AND
ABREU.
NOW IT IS JIMENEZ.
PLAYING LEFT FIELD TODAY.
I WAS CURIOUS TO ASK TONY LA
RUSSA ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HITMEN IS AS AN
OUTFIELDER VERSUS BEING A DH.
THE CONVERSATION GOES YOU ARE
THE SAME GUY BECAUSE HE LIKES TO
PLAY IN THE FIELD, SOMETIMES
FEELS LIKE HE IS BETTER AT THE
PLATE WHEN HE GETS TIME IN THE
OUTFIELD.
THERE ARE OTHER EXCELLENT
OUTFIELDERS THAT ARE PART OF THE
MIX.
HIM AND IS COMING OFF OF AN
INJURY.
LATROY: WHEN YOU ARE HITTING,
JUST HIT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE IF
YOU ARE DH OR LEFT FIELD.
JUST HIT.
THAT IS ALL WE WANT YOU TO DO.
SCOTT: WHAT ARE THE WISE WORDS
YOU GIVE HIM TO TELL HIM THAT?
EXACTLY WHAT YOU MENTION, THAT
IS THE LINE.
KEPLER BACK AT THE WALL.
GOT IT.
IT IS A QUICK EIGHTH FOR JUAN
MANAEA.
STRIKEOUT, STRIKEOUT.
AND THEN JIMENEZ WITH NOT ENOUGH
MUSTARD ON THE BALL.
STILL 1-0, MID EIGHTH.
>> EVER A TIME WHERE YOU ARE
LIKE I WANT TO QUIT, I DON'T
WANT TO DO THIS ANYMORE?
>> A MATTER FACT IT WAS, AFTER I
GOT DRAFTED.
STARTED MY CAREER OFF 0-26.
CALLED MY DAD, I AM COMING HOME.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THIS ANYMORE.
NO YOU ARE NOT, YOU GOT IT.
THE NEXT DAY, I SEE HIM PULLING
UP.
HE LITERALLY DROVE THROUGH THE
NIGHT TO COME WATCH THE GAME.
FIRST GAME I HIT MY FIRST HOME
RUN IN PRO BALL.
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE WHERE I WAS
A LITTLE HOMESICK MAYBE.
NEVER WENT AWAY FROM MY PARENTS
UNTIL I GOT TO PRO BALL.
ONE OF THOSE WHERE SOMETHING
HAPPENED.
I PRAYED THAT NIGHT, ALLOW ME TO
GET A HIT, EVERYTHING WILL BE
FINE.
SEEING MY FAMILY, MY MOM, MY DAD
.
THAT PUT A SENSE OF HAPPINESS IN
ME.
LIKE I SAID, GOT MY FIRST HIT,
FIRST HOME RUN AS A HITTER.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
SCOTT BRAUN, LATROY HAWKINS,
LAUREN GARDNER.
YOU CAN GO BEHIND THE SCENES AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT YOUR FAVORITE
PLAYERS.
WE ARE IN THE BALLPARK.
FEELS GOOD TO BE HERE.
LATROY: YES, INDEED.
SCOTT: I MISSED THE SMELLS, THE
CROWD.
BACK ON THE ROAD FOR THE REST OF
THE SEASON.
WE GET TO WATCH CRAIG KIMBREL IN
PERSON.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT HIS LINE ON
THE SEASON.
6.00 E.R.A. IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.
IN 2021, HE IS BACK.
IT TOOK A BIG HAUL TO GET HIM.
YOU CAN TECHNICALLY HAVE HIM
AFTER THE SEASON, YOU CAN PICK
UP THE OPTION.
IT COULD JUST BE A FEW MONTHS
FOR ONE OF THE BEST RELIEVERS IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
FIRST PITCH SWINGING IS MAX
KEPLER.
LATROY: CRAIG KIMBREL IS ONE OF
MY FAVORITE PICTURES.
JUST WATCHING HIM.
HIS FOCUS, HIS ABILITY TO ATTACK
HITTERS IN THE ZONE.
THAT YEAR IN 2019, HE DID UP
SIGNING LATE.
PICTURES -- PITCHERS WHO SIGNED
LATE, THAT USUALLY DOESN'T
HAPPEN DURING THE SEASON.
THEY DON'T HAVE GOOD YEARS.
IT TAKES SOME TIME TO GET BACK
INTO THAT MODE THEY WERE IN
BEFORE.
SCOTT: REMEMBER WHEN LANCE LYNN
SIGNED WITH MINNESOTA.
HE COULD NOT FIND THE ZONE.
LATROY: THAT WAS A GUY WHO
ALWAYS THROUGH STRIKES.
IT TOOK HIM SOME TIME.
SCOTT: AND THEN HE LOOKED LIKE
HIMSELF AFTER THE.
THIS IS NICE.
KIMBREL HAD HIS STRUGGLES THAT
COUPLE OF SEASONS, BUT HE IS
BACK IN A BIG WAY.
HAVING A CAREER YEAR.
LATROY: MOST OF THE TIME PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT HIS FASTBALL.
HIS BREAKING BALL IS
DEVASTATING.
THESE HITTERS ARE GOING UP THERE
CHALLENGING.
SCOTT: MY BACK HURTS WHEN I
WATCH HIM SET UP.
NO ONE DOES IT LIKE THAT.
LATROY: VERY INTIMIDATING.
SCOTT: RECORD -- ROOKER STAYS
ALIVE.
I HOSTED A CRAIG KIMBREL STARE
DOWN CONTEST.
IT IS ON YOUTUBE.
LATROY: I LIKED IT.
SCOTT: HE WON MOST OF THOSE
BATTLES.
LATROY: THEY WERE HOVERING
AROUND MIDDLE IN.
A LOT OF REPORTS THAT HE HAS
BEEN SPOTTING UP HIS FASTBALL.
HE HAS HAD SOME SUCCESS.
SCOTT: HE HAS TIGHTENED THAT UP
THIS YEAR.
GOOD AT BAT FROM BRENT ROOKER.
HE DOESN'T MIND.
YOU ROLLER COASTER FINISHES.
BUT USUALLY WINS THE MATCHUP IN
THE END.
THERE IS ANOTHER ONE.
LATROY: KIMBREL SAYS, I AM DONE
MESSING AROUND WITH THE BREAKING
BALL.
SEE IF I CAN GET A FASTBALL OVER
THE TOP OF YOUR HANDS.
SCOTT: HIGH HEAT.
NEVER EXPECTED A 1-0 GAME TODAY.
LATROY: WE HAD A FEELING IT
WOULD BE A PITCHER'S DUEL.
SCOTT: DAY GAME AFTER A NIGHT
GAME, WHITE SOX FORWARD TO
TOMORROW IN IOWA AGAINST THE
YANKEES.
A COUPLE OF UNDERRATED PICTURES
STARTED THIS GAME -- PITCHERS
STARTED THIS GAME.
ALEX COLOME GETTING SET THE
PITCH THE NINTH.
POLANCO IS SWINGING AT THE FIRST
PITCH MORE THAN EVER IN HIS
CAREER LATROY: HE IS TAKING HIS
THOUGHTS -- SPOTS.
SCOTT: IT IS GONE.
NO, OFF THE WALL.
COULD NOT CLEAR THE WALL.
POLANCO WILL END UP RACING TO
THIRD WITH A TRIPLE.
LATROY: HE THOUGHT ABOUT RACING
HOME.
[LAUGHTER]
SLIGHTLY ELEVATED.
WASN'T ABLE TO GET OVER THAT
HIGH WALL IN RIGHT FIELD.
NONETHELESS, A TRIPLE.
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET THIS RUN
HOME.
SCOTT: IT HUNG UP FOR A WHILE.
I THINK HE THOUGHT HE HAD IT.
I THOUGHT HE HAD IT FOULING OFF
THE FIRST PITCH.
LATROY: NOT AN EASY PLAY.
ONCE HE SAW IT OFF THE BRICK
WALL OUT THERE, HE FIGURED HE
HAD A GOOD SHOT OF GETTING TO
THIRD BASE.
WHEN YOU HAVE GUYS ON
BASE, WHO
DO YOU WANT HITTING?
SOMEONE ON YOUR TEAM WILL HAVE
TO SCORE.
I DON'T WHAT YOU TO THINK THAT I
AM AGAINST PITCHERS.
I AM TRYING TO SEE IT FROM BOTH
PERSPECTIVES.
SCOTT: POLANCO IS THE ONLY
OPENING DAY POSITION PLAYER WHO
HAS AVOIDED THE INJURED LIST.
SOMETIMES HE HAS BATTLED THROUGH
INJURIES.
IT WILL HANG UP LONG ENOUGH TO
MAKE THE CATCH.
NO EXTRA INSURANCE FOR THE
TWINS.
ALMOST A HOME RUN FROM POLANCO.
INSTEAD, IT IS A TRIPLE.
WE HAVE PLAYED EIGHT.
>> LET'S GO.
>> THEY DID HAVE AN EDGE.
AN INSPIRATIONAL MAN OF SPIRIT.
>> COULD YOU UNDERSTAND HIM?
MOST PEOPLE CANNOT UNDERSTAND
HIM.
>> YOU HAVE TO TALK TO BE A
LEADER.
THAT IS WHY LEADERS ALWAYS HAVE
BIG MOUTHS.
>> HE IS THE BEST MANAGER I HAD
A CHANCE TO PLAY FOR.
SKIES LOSE.
BRINGS A LOT OF ENERGY.
>> HE IS REALLY GOOD AT KNOWING
HIS CLUBHOUSE DAY IN AND DAY
OUT.
>> THOSE GUYS WILL GO ANYWHERE
WITH ME.
>> PLAYING FUNDAMENTAL BASEBALL,
THE WAY IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
PLAYED.
>> THAT SCORES THE TYING RUN.
THE WHITE SOX HAVE TAKEN THE
LEAD.
>> THIS IS AN UNBELIEVABLE THING
THEY HAVE GOING HERE IN CHICAGO.
SCOTT: THE DIFFERENCE TODAY,
JORGE POLANCO CONTINUING TO
IMPRESS.
OPPOSITE FIELD WITH THAT SHOT.
LATROY: HE IS SO LOCKED IN RIGHT
NOW.
HE HAS BEEN PULLING THE BALL
WITH A LOT OF AUTHORITY.
SCOTT: ALEX COLOME TO TRY TO
SHUT THE DOOR FOR A SECOND
CONSECUTIVE DAY.
PICKED UP BY THE TWINS FOR THIS
SEASON.
VERY ROCKY BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR.
THE WHITE SOX HAVE DOMINATED THE
SEASON SERIES.
BUT THE TWINS ARE PLAYING THEM
TODAY WELL THIS WEEK.
LATROY: THEY HAVE PLAYED BETTER
AGAINST ALL THEIR OPPONENTS IN
THE LAST 14 DAYS.
HE HAS BEEN THE ULTIMATE
PROFESSIONAL.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN HIM THIS YEAR.
HE IS NOT WHERE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO BE AT.
SCOTT: HERE WE GO AGAIN HE WILL
USE THAT CUTTER ABOUT 66% OF THE
TIME.
LATROY: IS CUTTER TO GET UP TO
93.
SOME OF THAT SAME MOVEMENT.
SCOTT: INTO THE SHIFT.
GOODWIN IS THE FIRST OUT.
MIGUEL SANO MAKES THE CATCH FROM
JORGE POLANCO.
>> GET OUT.
YOU ARE THE BEST.
WHAT A HITTER.
OPPOSITE FIELD.
HE IS SHOWING THE POWER.
SCOTT: I THINK WE HAVE A FUTURE
BROADCASTER.
LATROY: IT IS SO COOL TO SEE HOW
FAR HE HAS COME.
HOW COMFORTABLE HE IS SPEAKING
ENGLISH.
THAT IS A TESTAMENT TO HIM AND
HIS HARD WORK THEY WORK HARD AT
IT.
SCOTT: ADAM ENGEL.
A BOLOGNESE STRIKE.
REMEMBER THE CONVERSATION FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE GAME.
HE WAS QUIZZING BLANCO ABOUT HIS
APPROACH.
HE SAID HE JUST HAS TO GO UP THE
MIDDLE AND HIT THE BALL HARD
EVERY TIME.
AND HE DOES.
HE GOES DEEP UP THE MIDDLE.
TWO OUTS IN THE NINTH.
LATROY: ADAM ENGEL HAD A
FASTBALL YESTERDAY TO
STRAIGHTAWAY CENTER FIELD FOR A
HOME RUN RID THAT PITCH RIGHT
THERE WAS A CUTTER.
IT KIND OF BACKED UP A LITTLE
BIT.
REALLY GOOD PITCH.
TWO OUTS IN THE NINTH INNING.
SCOTT: LAST CHANCE, JAKE LAMB.
HE SINGLED IN THE FIFTH.
JUST A DAY OFF FOR YOAN MONCADA.
HE WILL BE BACK IN THERE
TOMORROW.
LAMB IS A FORMER ALL-STAR.
LOOK AT THAT BENCH.
THAT IS A STACKED BENCH.
LATROY: A DAY GAME AFTER A NIGHT
GAME.
GIVING SOME OF HIS STAR PLAYERS
THE AFTERNOON OFF.
SCOTT: NICE CROWD TODAY IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
BEAUTIFUL DAY FOR BASEBALL.
LATROY: PEOPLE ARE JUST HAPPY TO
BE OUT.
SCOTT: OVER 22,000 FILLING UP
TARGET FIELD TODAY.
YOU ARE APPEARING IN THE NINTH.
LATROY: A CUTTER DOWN.
SEE IF HE CAN GET JAKE LAMB TO
SWING OVER TOP OF THAT.
HE TRIED.
THAT WAS WAY OUT.
SCOTT: LET'S SEE IF COLUMN A
CONFINED THE ZONE.
THAT IS A FOUL BALL.
THIS IS THE 19TH AND FINAL
MEETING OF THE SEASON BETWEEN
THESE TWO TEAMS.
THE WHITE SOX HAVE TAKEN 13 OF
THEM.
LATROY: I'M SURE THE WHITE SOX
ARE UPSET THEY DO NOT GET TO
FACE THEM ANYMORE.
SCOTT: OK.
NOW A FULL COUNT TO JAKE LAMB.
LEURY GARCIA IS LOOMING.
LATROY: SO FAR ALEX COLOME HAS
BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PITCH
HIM AWAY.
SO FAR NOTHING OVER THE HEART OF
THE PLATE.
SCOTT: IF HE CAN HIT IT A LONG
WAY.
LATROY: THAT IS THE REASON THE
TWINS ARE STAYING AWAY FROM HIM.
SCOTT: THEY CONTINUE TO DO SO.
PICKING AROUND THE EDGES AND
WALKING JAKE LAMB.
LATROY: NOT A STRIKE.
HE DID WALK THAT GUY.
EARLY IN THE YEAR, HE PROBABLY
WOULD NOT HAVE WALKED HIM RID HE
PROBABLY WOULD'VE MISSED WITH
SOMETHING OVER THE PLATE AND GOT
HURT BY.
HE IS A BABEL -- HE IS ABLE TO
STAY AWAY FROM THE HITTER IN A
SPOT LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: HERE IS GARCIA.
FIRST PITCH, CHOPPER.
POLANCO MAKES THE PLAY, GAME
OVER.
THE TWINS TAKE IT 1-0.
50TH WIN OF THE YEAR FOR
MINNESOTA.
HERE COMES THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME QUESTION.
LATROY: I WILL GIVE IT TO JORGE
POLANCO.
HE HIT THE HOME RUN.
WITHOUT IT, WE ARE SITTING HERE
GETTING READY TO SEE THE BOTTOM
OF THE NINTH.
SCOTT: WE WILL SEE IF THEY
LISTEN TO YOU.
LET'S HIT THE POSTGAME SHOW.
IT IS PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE.
LAUREN GARDNER WILL BE JOINING
US SOON AS THE TWINS WILL OFF A
W AND A SERIOUS VICTORY.
CHICAGO WILL MOVE ON TO IOWA.
FIRST EVER MAJOR LEAGUE GAME
PLAYED IN IOWA.
THE FIELD OF DREAMS GAME
TOMORROW.
THEY WERE MISSING SOME PRETTY
BIG BATS FROM THE LINEUP TODAY.
LATROY: THEY WERE.
GIVE THE TWINS CREDIT.
THEY WENT OUT THERE AND PITCHED.
NOT MUCH OFFENSE FROM EITHER
TEAM.
ONE RUN HAPPENS TO BE ENOUGH TO
WIN THE GAME.
THIS WAS A WELL PITCHED GAME.
A LOT OF FUN.
A FUN GAME TO CALL.
I ENJOYED IT.
SCOTT: I LIKE WATCHING THE
PITCHING AND LISTENING TO YOU GO
OVER WHAT THE STARTERS WERE ABLE
TO PUT TOGETHER, BOTH OF THEM
WERE EXCELLENT.
BAILEY OVER WAS SPECIAL.
THE BULLPENS FROM BOTH SIDES
REALLY SHOWED A BIG.
LATROY: THE WHITE SOX HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE BULLPEN, AND
INCREDIBLE ROTATION.
ONE BAD PITCH, BLANCO HIT THE
BALL OUT OF THE BALLPARK, THEY
CAN LIVE WITH THAT.
THEY DID NOT GIVE UP A CROOKED
NUMBER.
THEY PUT THE BALL OVER THE
PLATE.
THE TWINS HAVE PLAYED A LOT
BETTER THE LAST 10 DAYS.
A LOT OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THEY HAVE THROWN THE BALL
OVER THE WAY.
THAT INCLUDES STARTERS AND
RELIEVERS.
SCOTT: JOINING US RIGHT NOW IS
JORGE POLANCO.
WITH THE HOME RUN AND LATER THE
TRIPLE.
CONGRATS.
WE CAUGHT SOME SOUND AS MIGUEL
SANO WAS MIKE DEPP TODAY.
HE SAID THE PLAN WAS UP THE
MIDDLE, THAT THE BALL HARD.
>> WE WERE TALKING.
LET'S GO UP THE MIDDLE.
LATROY: WE TALK ABOUT HOW YOUR
HEALTH BEGAN.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
I AM FEELING GREAT.
IT HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT MOMENT
FOR ME.
BUT NOW I FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE.
I CAN GIVE 100%.
SCOTT: WE ARE SHOWING THE HOME
RUN.
416 FEET.
WOULD YOU SAY THAT IS THE
BIGGEST REASON YOU HAVE TURNED
IT UP IN THE MONTH OF JULY?
DO YOU FEEL BETTER THAN YOU HAVE
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF SEASONS?
>> I JUST FEEL BETTER.
OR HEALTHY.
IT FEELS GOOD TO BE HEALTHY.
SCOTT: WHAT ABOUT THE TRIPLE
UNIT JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO?
I THOUGHT IT WAS LEAVING THE
YARD.
WE ALL WATCHED IT TOGETHER.
WE ALL WISH THAT WALL WAS
SHORTER.
>> I WISH.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A HOMER.
AS SOON AS I REALIZED I WASN'T,
I BEGAN TO WORRY.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
THAT WOULD HAVE LEFT THE YARD IN
SEVEN OTHER BALLPARKS.
YOU END UP WITH A TRIPLE.
YOU WILL TAKE IT.
NOW YOU PICK UP THE TROPHY.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
>> I WATCH A LOT OF YOUTUBE.
SCOTT: IT WILL HAVE YOUR NAME
ENGRAVED ON IT.
I LOVE IT.
CONGRATULATIONS ON WINNING THAT
AWARD.
WHAT HAS IT MEANT TO YOU SUSIE
REALLY THE ROCK OF THE OFFENSE
THIS YEAR?
I KNOW NELSON CRUZ HAS BEEN A
BIG PART OF THE ORGANIZATION.
BUT HE MOVED ONTO TO THE TAMPA
BAY RAYS.
YOU ARE THE GUY PEOPLE ARE
TURNING TO AS A VETERAN PRESENT.
>> I TRY TO GET EVERYONE
TOGETHER.
HAVE GOOD CHEMISTRY.
WE ARE JUST TRYING TO MOVE
FORWARD.
LATROY: YOU HAVE MADE HUGE
STRIDES AT SECOND BASE AFTER
PLAYING SHORTSTOP FOR A FEW
YEARS.
AS I TRANSITION THEM?
>> IT HAS BEEN GOOD.
AS SOON AS I WAS TOLD I WOULD
MOVE TO SECOND, I STARTED
WORKING ON IT.
I DID MY BEST TO GET
COMFORTABLE.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD PLAYING
SECOND.
LATROY: I WANT TO TAKE A PICTURE
WITH YOU AND THAT TROPHY.
SCOTT: HE IS AN ALL-STAR, HE HAS
THE TROPHY.
IT WAS YOU UP AGAINST OBER.
I THINK IT IS ONLY FAIR TO GIVE
SOME CREDIT TO THE PITCHING
TODAY.
THE BIG ROOKIE ON THE MOUND.
HE USES HIS SIZE.
WHAT HAS HE LOOKED LIKE?
>> HE LOOKS REALLY GOOD.
TODAY WAS SPECIAL FOR HIM.
HE THREW A REALLY GOOD GAME.
HE COMMANDED HIS PITCHES.
THIS WAS ONE OF HIS BEST OUTINGS
.
HE PICKS UP THE PACE.
WE A PATIENT -- WE APPRECIATE
IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
SCOTT: JORGE POLANCO, REALLY
WINNING BY A LANDSLIDE.
NOT CLOSE.
OBER IS A ROOKIE.
HE IS BUILDING UP HIS
REPUTATION.
LATROY: HE DID A GREAT JOB.
AS MANY ZEROS AS HE PUT UP
TODAY, HE STILL DOESN'T GET
ANYWHERE WITHOUT THE HOME RUN.
THAT WAS A HUGE HOME RUN.
THE ONLY RUN OF THE DAY.
THE ONLY RUN THAT THE TWINS
NEEDED.
SCOTT: YOU HAD LANCE LYNN
SCRATCHED FROM THIS GAME FOR
CHICAGO.
THE VATS DID NOT GET GOING WITH
THE WHITE SOX.
THE NUMBERS FROM CHICAGO CAN BE
DECEIVING.
SAME THING WITH THE HOME RUNS.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE SAMPLE
SIZE LATELY.
MAYBE JUST FOCUS ON THE SECOND
HALF OF THE SEASON.
SUDDENLY THE ELOY JIMENEZ IS
BACK, LUIS ROBERT CAME BACK,
YASMANI GRANDAL HAS BEEN MISSING
FOR A WHILE.
WHEN YOU PACK IT ALL AND THE
STARS ARE IN PLACE FOR CHICAGO,
THERE ARE NOT MANY WE IS IS.
THE IDENTITY OF THIS TEAM IS RUN
PREVENTION.
THE STARTING ROTATION IS AS GOOD
AS ANY BASEBALL.
THIS IS A FORCE.
LATROY: THIS TEAM HAS BEEN WELL
CONSTRUCTED OVER THE YEARS.
IT HAS ALL COME TO THIS POINT.
THEY WERE REALLY GOOD LAST YEAR.
THIS YEAR, EVERYTHING CAME
TOGETHER.
WHEN THEY PUT THIS TEAM
TOGETHER, THEY HAVE POWER, SPEED
, I'M SURE THE ROTATION IS
PROBABLY BETTER THAN WE THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE.
AND BULLPEN.
YOU ARE TAKING A CHANCE ON THAT.
THEY PROBABLY KNEW HE HAD THE
TOOLS AND THE PITCHES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT BEFORE.
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE DONE FROM
THEIR FRONT OFFICE PERSPECTIVE
HAS WORKED OUT OR THIS.
THEY DEFINITELY HAVE A REAL GOOD
CHANCE OF MAKING A DEEP RUN IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
SCOTT: ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY PICK
UP CESAR HERNANDEZ.
LUIS ROBERT IS BACK.
THINGS ARE LOOKING GOOD FOR THE
WHITE SOX.
ON THE TWINS SIDE, ASIDE FROM
THE SOUR TASTE IN THE FIRST
MONTH OF THE YEAR, THEY HAVE
BEEN ABOUT .500 ON THE SEASON.
IT IS TIME FOR THE YOUNG GUYS TO
STEP UP.
OBER REALLY SHOWED UP IN A BIG
WAY.
LET'S GO THROUGH HIS START.
HE WAS COMING OFF AN IMPRESSIVE
OUTING AGAINST HOUSTON.
AGAINST A DYNAMIC OFFENSE.
GOING UP AGAINST SOME PRETTY BIG
TALENTS.
THAT FASTBALL UP IN THE ZONE, IT
IS GOOD.
SCOTT: MY KEYS WHEN THE GAME
STARTED WERE HIS FASTBALL AND
GETTING STRIKEOUTS WITH HIS
FASTBALL.
ELEVATING IT IN THE ZONE.
HE HAD TO SPIN THE BALL.
HE DID A REALLY GOOD JOB USING
HIS SLIDER.
IT WAS A LOT BETTER.
THAT IS A TESTAMENT TO THE
PITCHING COACH AND THE BULLPEN
COACH GETTING OUT THERE AND
WORKING WITH THEM AND CONVEYING
TO HIM THAT YOUR FASTBALL IS
GOOD BUT YOU WILL NEED A
SECONDARY PITCH THAT YOU WILL
NEED TO WORK ON.
HIS SLIDER WAS VERY GOOD TODAY.
THAT COMPLEMENTS HIS FASTBALL.
IF YOU HAVE ANOTHER PITCH, IT
MAKES THAT OTHER PITCH SO MUCH
BETTER.
SCOTT: THAT IS A REALLY HEALTHY
MARK GOING UP AGAINST THE WHITE
SOX.
WITH HEAR WHAT HE SAID POSTGAME.
HE WAS VERY CONFIDENT.
HE WAS NOT WENDED OR TIRED.
I AM EXHAUSTED FROM THE.
-- THE HEAT.
SIX STRIKEOUTS.
THAT IS ONLY NEEDED.
YOU GUYS KICK OFF SEASON-LONG
HOME STAND WITH A SERIES VICTORY
OVER THE WHITE SOX.
HOW GOOD IS IT TO BE HOME IT
FEELS GREAT.
WE HAVE A LONG ROAD TRIP.
HOPEFULLY THE NEXT COUPLE SERIES
WILL DO THE SAME.
LAUREN: LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR
PERFORMANCE TODAY.
YOU WERE ABLE TO GO OUT THERE
AND SHUT DOWN ONE OF THE BEST
LINEUPS IN BASEBALL AREA >> WE
JUST WANTED TO ATTACK THESE
GUYS.
SEE IF THEY COULD MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS.
TRY TO MAKE THESE GUYS HIT OUR
BEST STUFF.
I RELIEVERS CAME IN AND PLAYED
GREAT.
LAUREN: GOOD EFFORT ALL AROUND.
WE THOUGHT IT WAS A HOMER BUT IT
WAS A TRIPLE.
WHAT DOES HIS PRESENCE MEAN TO
THIS CLUB?
>> IT IS GREAT.
THAT IS JUST TOO HE IS.
THAT IS WHO HE WILL BE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
A GUY WHO WILL GIVE US HIS ALL
EVERY SINGLE AT BAT.
YOU KNOW HE CAN DO SOMETHING
SPECIAL LIKE THAT EVERY TIME HE
GOES UP THERE.
LAUREN: IT WILL BE NELSON CRUZ
BACK IN MINNESOTA.
WHAT TYPE OF HOMECOMING WILL HE
RECEIVE?
>> HE WILL GET A STANDING
OVATION FOR SURE.
WE MISS HIM HERE.
I KNOW THESE GUYS WILL TRY TO
MIX IN SOME STUFF.
JUST BECAUSE THEY KNOW EACH
OTHER A LITTLE BIT.
IT IS ALWAYS COOL WHEN YOU SEE
OLD TEAMMATES COME TO PLAY.
LAUREN: THE WHITE SOX ARE FIRMLY
IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT IN YOUR
DIVISION.
WHAT WILL BE YOUR ROLE DOWN THE
STRETCH?
>> I KNOW IT HAS BEEN A TOUGH
SEASON.
BUT WE WILL TRY TO GET BETTER
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
LAUREN: CONGRATULATIONS.
I THINK HE ECHOED WHAT ROCCO
BALDELLI WAS TELLING US, THEY
ARE NOT JUST GOING TO LAY DOWN
AND GIVE UP.
THEY WILL FOCUS ON THE YOUTH.
THEY RESTRUCTURED SOME OF THE
DAYS HERE AT THE BALLPARK TO
FOCUS ON FUNDAMENTALS.
OF COURSE I HAD TO ASK HIM IF HE
PLAYED BASKETBALL.
HE SAID HE WAS VERY GOOD BUT
PITCHING WAS HIS THING.
SCOTT: OF COURSE.
YOU HAVE TO ASK WHEN SOMEONE IS
THAT TALL.
THANK YOU.
LATROY: HE MAKES ME FEEL SMALL.
SCOTT: HE DOES.
RUN PREVENTION WHEN IT WORKS.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE SPLITS.
PITCHING HAS BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
MINNESOTA.
WE THOUGHT WE WOULD SEE BETTER.
THE TWINS ARE PLAYING INSPIRING
BASEBALL DOWN THE STRETCH.
MUCH MORE A MOMENT.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> THAT WHAT IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CROUCHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
>> THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> DEREK JETER HAS DONE IT.
>> DEEP RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
THIS BALL IS GONE.
>> FROM THE CORNFIELDS OF IOWA,
THE FIELD OF DREAMS PLAYS HOST
TO THE YANKEES AND THE WHITE SOX
AREA >> IN THE GAME OF BASEBALL,
THERE IS A SPECIAL PLACE.
A PLACE FOUND DEEP INSIDE ANYONE
WHO HAS PUT THAT BALL.
A PLACE BILLED BY TRADITION AND
LIT BY THE WARM GLOW OF
MEMORIES.
A PLACE WHERE THE BOYS OF SUMMER
DREAM ABOUT FALL.
IT DOES NOT MATTER WHAT JERSEY
THEY WEAR.
THIS IS WHERE THEY PLAY THEIR
BEST.
A PROVING GROUND WHERE LEGENDS
ARE CULTIVATED.
A FIELD OF DREAMERS,.
THEY COME TO FULFILL A PROMISE
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
NUMBERS FOR THE HISTORY BOOKS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE GAME.
EVERY GENERATION HAS THEIR
CHANCE TO REWRITE MYTHOLOGY.
TWO AT THE PRESENT TO OUR
PASTIME.
HISTORY IN THE MAKING.
THEY STILL LONG TO COME BACK.
THEY HAVE BUILT IT, AND WE HAVE
COME.
IT IS IN HEAVEN, BUT IT IS
PRETTY DARN CLOSE.
SCOTT: IT IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE
HEAVEN.
IT IS GOING TO BE AWESOME.
1989 IS WHEN THAT FILM CAME OUT.
IT IS STILL BEING TALKED ABOUT.
THE STRUCTURE OF THE BALLPARK.
THE DIMENSIONS ARE PRETTY TIGHT.
HE COULD PRODUCE SOME LONG
BALLS.
SOME BASEBALLS THAT DISAPPEAR
INTO THE FIELDS.
LATROY: I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO
IT.
I WILL DEFINITELY TUNE IN.
IT WILL BE A GREAT DAY.
IT WILL BE HUGE.
SCOTT: A THOUSAND HANDS WILL BE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO WATCH THAT ONE.
IT IS A HOT TICKET.
IT IS SOLD OUT.
IT IS TOUGH TO FIND.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
LATROY: WHAT IS THE TEMPERATURE?
SCOTT: I'M SURE IT WILL BE HOT.
IT IS A NIGHT GAME.
UNDER THE LIGHTS.
MAYBE IT WILL BE A LITTLE
COOLER.
LET'S CHECK OUT THE POSTSEASON
PICTURE.
CHICAGO IS LEADING THE DIVISION.
YOU HAVE A YANKEE TEAM THAT IS
HUNGRY RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR A
DIVISION.
THEY ARE SEVEN GAMES BACK WITH
COMPETITIVE TEAMS IN FRONT OF
THEM.
THEY ARE A COUPLE OF GAMES AWAY
FROM A WILD-CARD SEED.
THEY MEET UP WITH THE RED SOX
EARLY NEXT WEEK.
THE YANKEES MATCHUP AGAINST
CHICAGO TOMORROW AND THEN THEY
WILL HAVE AN OFF DAY.
THE YANKEES WILL PLAY THE ANGELS
ON MONDAY AND THEN THE RED SOX
IN A SERIES NEXT WEEK.
YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF BIG TEAMS.
YOU LOOK AT HOW BIG THE ELOY
JIMENEZ AND JOSE ABREU ARE.
THE YANKEES WITH JUDGE AND
STANTON.
JOEY GALLO JOINTS THAT TEAM AS
WELL.
IT WILL BE AESTHETICALLY
PLEASING.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT BIG DUDES
SHOWING UP TO THE BALLPARK.
BIGGER DUDES THAN THE ONES WE
SAW IN THE MOVIE.
LATROY: THERE IS GOING TO BE
SOME STAR POWER.
GUYS LIKE STANTON AND JUDGE.
SCOTT: LANCE LYNN WILL BE
STARTING.
HE IS A BIG BOY ON THE MOUND.
THE CY YOUNG FRONT RUNNER AT
THIS POINT.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO GO TODAY.
THEY DECIDED TO PUSH HIM TO
TOMORROW.
THERE WERE A FEW REASONS GIVEN
TO US.
THE BULLPEN IS RESTED.
LET'S MOVE HIM TO WHERE HE WILL
HAVE MORE WORK.
THIS IS A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME
GAME.
YOU HAVE YOUR VETERAN CY YOUNG
FRONT RUNNER ON THE MOUND.
YOU ARE IN A DIVISION THAT YOU
HAVE A MUCH IN HAND AT THE
MOMENT.
IT MAKES SENSE THAT IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE HIM GOING, YOU GO TO
ONE OF YOUR OTHER TOP GUNS.
LATROY: WHY WASTE HIM ON
MINNESOTA WHEN YOU CAN A SHAM
BACK A DAY AND HAVE HIM START
AGAINST A TEAM THAT IS POSSIBLY
IN THE PLAYOFF HUNT?
WHEN YOU START BEING THOSE TYPE
OF TEAMS.
I THINK EVERYONE IN THE CENTRAL
DIVISION IS BELOW 500 YOU START
BEATING SOME OF THOSE TEAMS ATOP
OTHER DIVISIONS IN THE PLAYOFF
RACE, THAT IS WHEN YOU KNOW YOUR
TEAM IS UP FOR THE CHALLENGE.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GREAT CALL.
IT IS NOT NECESSARILY YOUR
FAULT.
YOU ARE TAKING ON TEAMS IN A
WEAKER DIVISION.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO GO THROUGH A
GAUNTLET SET STARTS WITH THE
YANKEES.
GAMES AGAINST THE RED SOX IN THE
BLUE JAYS.
THE TIME MATCHUPS COMING UP.
THE WHITE SOX HAVE A TRUE TEST
COMING UP.
LANCE LYNN WILL START THAT OFF
TOMORROW NINE.
THEY LOSE THIS SERIES.
TWINS TAKE TWO OUT OF THREE.
>> WE HAD SOME TIME WHERE HE WAS
REALLY SWINGING THE BAT WELL.
HE HURT IT.
IT JUST CAME OUT.
THE BIG HEARD -- HURT.
FROM THERE ON, THAT WAS IT.
IT HAS BECOME ONE OF THE GREAT
NICKNAMES IN BASEBALL.
YOU DON'T REALIZE HOW BIG HE IS
UNTIL YOU STAND NEXT TO HIM.
THIS GUY IS A MONSTER.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
ONE DAY HE CAME OUT TO BATTING
PRACTICE AT OUR PLACE AND HE HAD
AN ALUMINUM BAT.
IT WAS A JOKE.
HE WAS HITTING BALLS OVER THE
CONCOURSE.
600 FEET.
>> HERE COMES THE BIG HURT.
YOU CAN PUT IT ON THE BOARD,
YES!
>> LET'S GO.
I AM HERE AT FIRST BASE WITH ONE
OF THE BEST HITTERS IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE, M.V.P. LAST
YEAR, JOSE ABREU.
>> WHAT IS YOUR PLAN?
TRYING TO DRIVE THE BALL TO LEFT
FIELD, RIGHT FIELD, MIDDLE?
OK.
THAT IS WHAT I'M GOING TO TRY TO
DO NEXT HAVE BEEN.
>> YOU NEVER WATCHED MY MOVIE?
>> YOU HAVE A MOVIE?
>> THAT IS ME.
>> GET OUT.
THE BEST HITTER.
YOU ARE THE BEST.
WHAT A HITTER.
OPPOSITE FIELD?
OPPOSITE WAY?
WOW.
JORGE POLANCO.
1-0 AGAINST THE CHICAGO WHITE
SOX.
IT IS A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
YOU ARE UNBELIEVABLE.
SCOTT: YOU ARE THE MAN, THE
MIGUEL SANO.
THE GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
MIGUEL SANO IS A FUTURE
PLAY-BY-PLAY GUY.
CAN CALL THE GAME.
HE KNOWS THE STATS, HE IS MAKING
THE CALLS.
HE IS TELLING YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THE KONTOS --
CONTEST.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME WITH THE
MICROPHONE TODAY.
LATROY: IT WAS GREAT CONTENT.
I LOVE TO HEAR AND SEE THE
STRIDES HE HAS MADE WITH HIS
ENGLISH.
NOT VERY MUCH SPANISH.
HE WAS SO COMFORTABLE.
HE GAVE US WHAT WE NEEDED.
SCOTT: PURE GOLD.
YOU CAN HEAR MORE OF THE MIKED
UP CONTENT.
AND NOW WE WILL GIVE YOU THE
HIGHLIGHTS FROM THIS ONE.
THE ROOKIE MAKING HIS 13TH
CAREER START.
HE HAS BEEN BETTER IN THE MONTH
OF JULY.
SWING AND A MISS.
IT HAS A BIT OF A DIFFERENT
FEEL.
SOME EXTRA LIFE TO IT.
THAT IS PRETTY GOOD STUFF.
1-2-3 FIRST.
LOPEZ FINDS OUT HE WILL BE THE
MAN ON THE MOUND TODAY.
THERE IS A STRIKE OUT THREE
PITCHES.
THERE IS 94 UP.
BACKING UP.
HE HAS IT.
LATROY: HIS CHANGEUP IS THE
BIGGEST SEPARATOR.
SCOTT: THIRD K OF THE DAY FOR
OBER.
FISHING.
THAT SHOULD BE PLAYABLE.
ANDRELTON SIMMONS HAS IT.
THE HEADS UP TO FIRE IT BACK
INTO THE INFIELD.
THEY CHASE UPSTAIRS.
THAT WILL DROP.
THAT MISSED.
IT WORKED.
A COUPLE OF MORE STRIKEOUTS.
A LITTLE MORE PRESSURE.
JORGE POLANCO MUSCLES UP.
THE ELOY JIMENEZ HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE MOST POWERFUL HITTERS.
JUAN MINAYA IS EXCITED ABOUT IT.
THEY LOVE EACH OTHER.
BLANCO ALMOST MADE IT A TWO HOME
RUN PERFORMANCE ON THE DAY.
NINTH INNING ACTION.
ALEX COLOME LOOKING TO PICK UP
SAVES.
YOU HEARD ALL THE POMP AND
CIRCUMVENT FROM MY MIGUEL SANO.
A VICTORY FOR MINNESOTA BEFORE
THE WHITE SOX HEAD TO IOWA.
THE WHITE SOX ARE 19 GAMES ABOVE
.500.
THEY HAVE PUT TOGETHER A STRONG
SEASON.
GETTING STRONGER AS A BALLCLUB.
THERE ARE A FEW NOTES.
WHEN YOU HAVE SUCH A COMFORTABLE
DIVISION LEAD, HOW DO YOU
MAINTAIN YOUR COMPETITIVENESS.
YOU WANT THEM TO PLAY.
YOU WANT THEM TO STAY HEALTHY.
TO BE FULLY INTACT FOR OCTOBER
BASEBALL.
LATROY: A LOT OF THINGS TO GO
WRONG WHEN IT'S TIME FOR THE
PLAYOFFS.
THEY REST THEIR GHYZEL LITTLE
BIT EARLY.
SOME GUYS GET STALE.
THEY TAKE TIME OFF.
THEY TAKE TOO MANY DAYS OFF.
TONY LA RUSSA HAS A REAL GOOD
PULSE ON THIS TEAM.
A COUPLE OF OTHER GUYS DID NOT
PLAY.
THAT WAS JUST THIS GAME.
IT WON'T HAPPEN LIKE THAT MANY
OTHER TIMES.
ONE DAY OFF FOR TIM ANDERSON OUT
OF THE WEEK.
YOU HAVE TO STAY FRESH.
THIS TEAM IS BUILT TO MAKE A RUN
IN THE PLAYOFFS.
IT IS NOT BUILT TO BE KNOCKED
OUT IN THE FIRST ROUND.
THEY ARE GOING FOR IT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO HIT A GRAND
SLAM.
THIS IS THE YEAR.
WE COULD TALK ABOUT NEXT YEAR
BUT, THE CHICAGO WHITE SOX ARE
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
MAKING A DEEP RUN.
THEY WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO
EVERYTHING.
THEIR BULLPEN WILL HAVE TO STAY
SOLID.
THEY WILL HAVE TO HIT FOR POWER.
MOST OF THEM ARE GENERATED OFF
THE HOME RUN.
THEY CAN SCORE RUNS WITHOUT
HAVING TO HIT THE BALL OUT OF
THE BALLPARK.
THERE HITTERS HAVE MADE
ADJUSTMENTS OVER THE YEARS.
THE HITTER WILL TAKE THE SINGLE.
THEY WILL HIT THE BALL WHERE IT
IS PITCHED.
THAT IS PAYING DIVIDENDS FOR
THEM.
TIM ANDERSON DID NOT COME UP AND
SWING THE BALL THAT WELL.
NOT THAT GOOD OF A HITTER.
TAKE WITH THE TEAM IS GIVING
YOU.
WITH THE HOME RUNS HAPPEN
ORGANICALLY.
SCOTT: HE IS A CONSISTENT
HITTER.
THIS IS A BIG RUN FOR US.
IN PERSON.
I LOVE IT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
WE COME BACK TUESDAY, AUGUST 17,
BLUE JAYS AND NATIONALS.
COVERAGE BEGINS WITH OUR PREGAME
SHOW.
IT IS A NIGHT GAME.
WE WILL SEE YOU THEN.
OUR ENTIRE CREW HERE IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
WE WILL SEE YOU NEXT TIME ON
YOUTUBE.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]